the public order emergency commission is
now in session the commissions
good morning bonjour
uh just before we uh start I just want
to uh
give a bit of a message as to the events
of yesterday as as ever as many of you
know we had to interrupt the hearing
yesterday because our senior Council uh
Gabriel suddenly became indisposed
uh he was seen by medical professionals
and his episode was likely nothing
serious so he's expected to make a quick
recovery
after a few days of recuperation and
we'll be back uh with the commission
next week
he wishes to thank all who have reached
out to him with messages of support uh
and uh it's uh very appreciated by him
and and of course by the commission
so with that brief introduction and
reassurance
um we can go on to the next Witness
morning Mr commissioner
commission council at our first witness
today is Marlon degrom
morning right up here
thank you sir
well you swear in a religious document
or do you wish to affirm
I swear please with the Bible the Quran
or the Torah available Bible please
thank you
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
my full name is Marlon Armin degrand
m-a-r-l-i-n
-a-r-m-a-n and the surname is
d-e-g-r-a-n-d
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God I do thank
you
thank you very much
good morning Mr de Grant morning sir how
are you good to see you again
um
so Mr degrand uh you'll recall that you
met with commission Council on August
30th for an interview
yes I do remember that and we prepared a
summary of your the evidence that you
provided during that interview correct
yes so I'll just pull up at
wts703 so this is your witness summary
um which will come up on the screen do
you have any corrections uh to that
witness summary this morning I do not
great
and you can confirm this is the witness
summary that uh that you've seen you've
reviewed it yes perfect so have that
entered into evidence
um
you also will recall that um the
province of Alberta the government of
Alberta has prepared an Institutional
report
you've had the chance to review that as
well I have and I also understand that
you've sworn an affidavit attaching and
and confirming the content of that
institutional report I have and so just
for the record at the institutional
report is ALB dot i r dot seven zeros
one and then the affidavit is AFF
dot six zeros one five
thank you so Mr degrand I I understand
that you are assistant Deputy minister
of the public security Division and
director of law enforcement for Alberta
Justice and solicitor general is that
correct it's correct at the time that we
spoke we since had a ministerial uh
change in our department is now uh sort
of split to Justice on one side and I'm
with the newly created Ministry of
Public Safety and Emergency Services the
role stayed the same and and you're so
you're still a assistant Deputy Minister
that's correct and what was your um can
you maybe describe your responsibilities
at the time at the time of these events
that was the uh assistant Deputy
Minister and responsible for the
coordination I have a number of Duties
as the Director of law enforcement
primarily at that time was the
coordination of law enforcement in the
province uh we also are responsible for
oversight uh uh research and statistical
analysis uh crime prevention in a number
of other matters under Section 8 of our
police Act
and who did you report to at the time
the associate Deputy Minister now Deputy
Minister for our uh our department uh
Dennis Cooley
tastic
and they reported to to minister Savage
is that correct yes yeah our minister at
the time was Minister Savage inter
minister
thank you
and so my understanding is that you
would one of your rules was to liaise
with law enforcement on behalf of the
government and the solicitor general
that's correct liaison coordinate with
you maybe start by providing us with a
brief summary of policing services in
the province
certainly uh and very briefly we have of
course uh multiple levels of policing
the RCMP is the federal policing entity
in the province as it is anywhere in
Canada within Alberta we have a police
act which cons which uh dictates the
levels of uh responsibility for policing
being for communities over the threshold
of five thousand they're required to
have their own police force or a
municipal service they also have the
option to contract with the RCMP uh in
our in our promise Mr degree I could
just ask that you slow down a bit
because it's all being translated so
yeah especially when you know what the
the area you tend to talk a little fast
I think yeah I I probably do all the
time so thank you I will okay so
certainly uh there are multiple levels
as always saying Municipal policing is
responsible in communities of over five
thousand uh in seven of those instances
we have Municipal Police Services that
are tenant and self-administered
the number of instances 48 I believe the
communities have chosen to contract the
RCMP as their contracted Police Service
the RCMP is also our contracted Police
Service for the provision of provincial
policing in the remainder of the uh of
the province including First Nations and
metis settlements with the exception of
three communities which have
self-administered First Nation services
and so
um my understanding is in communities
under 5 000 though than the policing
would be provided by the RCMP that's
correct as the Provincial Police Service
and so that would include for example
Coots yes okay
and that's I believe that's the the K
division of the rcmb rcmpk division the
designation for all operations in
Alberta perfect thank you
uh can you maybe describe as well I
understand
um the sheriff highway patrol is is also
under your your purview can maybe
explain their role certainly uh the
sheriff's branch is a branch under my uh
Division and it entails a number of
discrete units one of which is the
sheriff's Highway Patrol Sheriff's
Highway Patrol Works closely with the
RCMP uh in the delivery of traffic
services and traffic safety across the
province uh in their their role insofar
as the the Border dispute at Coots was
directly in support of the rcmp's
operational response and we provided a
number of our officers to to the RCMP to
assist in in any number of areas
including traffic control and checkpoint
control uh under their Direction and
within their operations ordinarily the
sheriff's work
collaboratively and cooperatively with
the RCMP but independently from the RCMP
as a peace officer organization they are
not police officers they have a specific
mandate and specific authorities which
are quite broad but in the case where
they were providing Operational Support
at Coots they were working under the
command structure of the RCMP as part of
that response that was the
responsibility of the police force of
jurisdiction
so normally they would have uh
in all cases I guess they would have the
authority to enforce
um
the highway traffic act for example
would be a one of their key pieces of
legislation that they enforce yes that
certainly is a traffic safety act and a
large number of provincial and other
legislation they actually have uh
authorities for under the critical
infrastructure Defense Act in in other
pieces of legislation
and so maybe can you just explain a
little bit more why in this case
um they were they would operate at the
direction of of the RCMP certainly
um the event at the border specifically
was obviously a policing event and
police are charged with the
responsibility for administering are for
overseeing and addressing public order
events and in cases of uh you know
breaches of the law Etc
in that particular case the police force
of jurisdiction being the RCP has
overall command and control of the event
and it would be improper and problematic
for an independent agency such as the
sheriff's
to operate in an operational manner in
in that or an enforcement manner in that
in that event outside of the uh the
command and control of the rcmb as you
could
conceivably come at Cross purposes for
some of the strategies that we're
attempting to be embarked upon both from
a negotiation perspective or an
enforcement perspective et cetera so you
need to be coordinated in there has to
be one unifying command and one command
of control
apparatus for the response thank you
um you mentioned briefly there the
critical infrastructure Defense Act can
you maybe explain for us uh what what
that is what
um what does that law do
it is a piece of legislation in and I
probably am the the wrong person to to
give you a very detailed explanation on
it but it's in in a sense it allows for
to allow us for police in the province
to have another tool in their toolbox
when dealing with uh matters that that
uh
provide intrusions to or are or affect
the operation of critical infrastructure
in the province it's a it's not akin to
say the emergency act which is why we're
here today in the sense that if there's
no need for invocation uh it's much like
the traffic safety act the criminal code
or any other statute that's available as
a tool to law enforcement every day an
act that is in place in Alberta and is
your understanding that highways are a
piece of critical infrastructure under
that act that's correct okay thank you
and and who's able to enforce that act I
think you already mentioned the
sheriff's both the sheriffs and the RCMP
course yes any Police Service can in
their area of jurisdiction Municipal yes
thank you
um and so what kind of function
um you've already mentioned you liaise
with police do you play some sort of
oversight function as well we do have an
oversight function we have uh policing
standards that we develop in a collegial
manner within the province with law
enforcement and which we're charged with
ensuring are met
we have uh audit programs that we are
involved in and of course we are
involved in policy development uh and uh
giving advice to the government on
legislative changes that may or may not
be required
so I'd like to
talk now about Coots a little bit sure
um
so my understanding is that the province
was aware that a slow roll was uh headed
towards Coots and scheduled to arrive on
January 29th
yes we became aware of that through
information that was provided to us
through law enforcement and through our
provincial security intelligence office
where would you typically get your
situational information on an event like
this
we have a reasonably well developed
level of coordination between the law
enforcement entities in the province all
Police Services as well as our sheriffs
and and our provincial security and
intelligence office which allows for the
sharing of information and is near to
real time as possible between those
entities so that we can and of course
through the use of the criminal
intelligence service of Alberta within
our
within our law enforcement our combined
forces law enforcement entity alert
through those things we we receive
information on a regular basis on any uh
evolving situations that have an ability
to impact any area of jurisdiction or in
this case potentially multiple areas of
jurisdiction across the province and it
will ensure that it's shared not only
broadly within the law enforcement
Community but also provides insight for
myself
and you would have received all those
situational updates I received
situational uh updates from from my
folks for sure yes
and was the province aware of the
threats of a blockade prior to the uh
the arrival of the the Convoy at the
border or near the border the
information we were receiving at the
time uh through the RCMP was based on
their conversations with organizers uh
nothing that we saw indicated that
well there's always the potential for a
blockade but nothing we saw indicated
that that was the intent of the Slow
Roll Convoy there are a number of events
being planned including events at the
legislature and in Calgary uh and those
were all being monitored at the same
time uh the particular
Convoy that rolled from basically
Lethbridge to to the Coots border was
initially intended to be from the
information that was provided to us
um
a bunch of vehicles coming to the area
demonstrating through a slow roll and
leaving the area
um
mayor will I don't know if you heard his
testimony I did not few days ago he he
testified that he advised the premier
and and Minister Savage on September
27th of the risk of a blockade maybe we
can pull up uh cou five zeros one eight
three I'm sorry September oh my
apologies sorry
I I wrote up my notes late last night so
I understand it yeah no thank you
sorry January 27th of course
so here you see uh mayor willett's email
I became aware of an organized effort
plan to begin Saturday to totally block
all Northbound and southbound traffic
here at the Coots border crossing as
well as carway and Del Bonita
we're uh
were you ever made aware
that this information had been provided
to
to the Alberta Government
I can't say that I've seen this
um I'm not going to say for sure that it
didn't fall flow through the traffic but
I can't say that I've seen this before
and more generally where you provided
with any intelligence that there was a
risk yeah absolutely it was always as I
stated earlier that's certainly a risk
and it was risk that uh I'm sure there's
chatter around that as well on the
social media sites but the organizers As
I understood them from the conversation
is that the RCMP were having and I defer
to them to to speak in detail around
that uh we're saying that wasn't the
intent that stated there's always that
risk were you advised prior to the
arrival that there may be a a splendor
group potentially that had an intention
to blockade the Border
I don't remember anybody mentioning
Splinter groups within any of the
conversations I had at that time okay
that became apparent
on the day of the event though
that there was a group that splittered
off from the Thousand or so vehicles
that were initially there there's about
250 that
sort of splintered off and stopped and
blocked the road
um so mayor Willett testified that he
received a call the next day from
someone he believes to be from a
minister
um Savage's office
informing him that you know thank you
for the information at the the RCMP are
are on it you're not aware of
that phone call that discussion no no
I'm not sorry
um were you briefed on the rcmp's plan
for that event prior to the arrival at
the on the 29th I was
yeah and do you know uh whether there
was planning for the possibility of a
blockade
I'd want to defer probably to deputies a
block a deputy Commissioners a blocky on
that but the briefings I had were around
the fact that there's knowledge of the
Convoy the fact that the approximate
size of what we into what they
anticipated was going to be coming uh
their plans to reach out to Convoy
organizers distribute information speak
with individuals at checkpoints to make
sure they understood the rules around
not so sorry slow down uh not uh not uh
blocking the highway in both areas
giving them uh you know Direction on how
to lawfully protest within the area
those are all the plans that were
articulated to myself as well as
terms at a gross level or a high level
uh the the number of police officers
that would be uh you know brought to
bear in terms of managing uh the event
as it was unfolding and do you recall
what that number was for the country you
know I don't I'm sorry
um you were you were satisfied generally
with their plan I was
and obviously we will uh speak to them
about that as well but it's good to get
your your recollection
um have you formed an opinion since then
on on why the RCMP was not able to
prevent the blockade from setting in on
that day
I was never on the ground uh at the site
so I Rely heavily on
the information from the police and
and some measure of personal experience
but uh from the long past but
the reality is that the blockade
occurred spontaneously as I understand
it in the sense that
a number of vehicles were circuiting
down to the Border point
and back up and a Crossing in a bit of a
demonstration Circle which was slowing
traffic but not blocking it
and that at some point a number of
vehicles just decided to stop and block
the highway
which is of course contrary to the
assurances of the organizers and
contrary to the directions that were
given by police
so at that point in time uh
the the police on the ground were faced
with a very difficult program problem in
the sense that they had 250 ish Vehicles
blocking a highway thank you
you understood that the blockade blocked
traffic to and from the the Border
correct that's correct on on the
Canadian side
yes
um and and that it also prevented access
by Coots residents to Milk River and and
vice versa
I believe so yeah there were some early
conversations around the challenges that
the community of Coots was facing and I
know one of the things that the RCMP
informed me they were working with and
they managed to to gain support for was
creating access for the community to
roadways out of the area in the first
day or two of the event or a couple days
of the event
foreign
I think what you're telling me is you
understood it was a key artery for Coots
uh to to get to essential services and
certainly yeah certainly although I'm
not I'm not
as familiar with Coots to say if it was
the only uh artery but I believe it was
certainly key okay
you you spoke just now about
um
the RCMP briefing you about creating a
an alternate route for for residents
um can you maybe just tell me a little
bit more what you know about that I I
really don't know a lot more about that
other than to what was relayed to me
from the RCMP in the sense that they
were looking to create access for the
community and that it was resolved and
again I
I from memory I can't recall which day
but was resolved early on in those first
few days in the first few days that and
and that they would have successfully
created some alternative route when the
highway was fully blockaded for
residents to get out that's correct and
um is your understanding that that were
you ever advised that that route was
used for commercial vehicles as well
to across the border well not to cross
the border but one you know once they
had crossed the border to to kind of get
out uh
there was a number of as the RCMP
relayed to me that there were a number
of vehicles truck drivers uh sort of
caught up in the matter that didn't uh
want to be there but had no way of of
getting out and
I'm going from memory and I can't
remember which day it was but as again
on those early days uh there was some
progress made in discussions by the RCMP
with the protesters
to allow those that did not want to be
there to leave and I believe 25 30
trucks for or escorted out of the area
but beyond that there was no real Avenue
for truck drivers to go through when all
the lanes were blocked I think it's
important to note that throughout the
duration of the the event uh which was a
couple weeks there were you know the
majority of the time there actually were
were one lane of travel open both North
and South so fair to say to to your
knowledge there was no alternate route
available for commercial vehicles RCMP
was relying on essentially the good
faith of of the protesters well through
Coots as we crossed border crossing that
that would be accurate yes uh there are
other border crossings that very early
on uh efforts were made to ensure that
those remained open uh while the primary
border crossing to the United States
from Alberta is of course at Coots at
sweet grass the Del Bonita and carway
crossings are also available they have
more restricted hours and efforts were
made by our Transport Canada folks as
well as the RCM or sorry Transportation
Folks at Alberta not Transport Canada my
apologies uh transport to Alberta
Ministry and the RCMP to work with cbsa
and American officials to ensure that we
could extend the hours and the services
that were available on those border
crossings to facilitate travel uh to the
extent that could be done outside of
Coots itself when it was closed thank
you I might have some more questions on
that later but that's sure that's
helpful thank you
um
so my understanding from the the
institutional report is that on January
31st
um the RCMP was prepared to conduct some
enforcement action
um but that some protesters left around
that time and there was attempts to
negotiate with the remainder of the
protesters
um but that that was not ultimately
successful is that correct that's the
information that was relayed to me from
the RCMP absolutely and and what was
your understanding of why those
negotiations were unsuccessful at that
time
I actually couldn't speak to that uh I
can tell you that with some of the
protesters wanted to leave and others
indicating that they were interested in
transitioning to a lawful protest the
RCMP made the Tactical decision to
proceed with negotiations which seemed
reasonable and sound to me and uh and
they did so those were not those
ultimately proved unfruitful at that
time but I again I wasn't on the ground
having those conversations so it'd be
speculative for me to to say why they
didn't work out were you advised at this
around this time January 31st that the
protest leadership had was was not quite
clear yet
now I I can tell you that I was advised
as the matter progressed that it was
difficult to negotiate because there are
multiple areas
are multiple individuals that would come
forward and claim leadership and in this
case there was a group that there's the
initial leadership of the Convoy and
then there was The Splendid group and
then there was a group at this point in
time January 31st that came forward and
identified themselves as leadership and
we're speaking with the RCMP uh I think
later on and I'm not sure that was the
31st I think it was
in the subsequent days to follow other
groups identified thems or individuals
identified themselves as leadership and
not being represented by the folks that
had previously been speaking with the
RCMP and one of the one of the
difficulties that was expressed to me
from the RCMP was that they were getting
multiple
groups and uh and within the uh or fact
factions if you will within the the
global protesters
there are individuals with
a mixed group of
sort of motivations
uh within the group within the uh the
protest event itself and it was making
it difficult to to negotiate thank you
and um
is is one of the reasons that
enforcement wasn't pursued at this time
again January 31st
um because some more moderate elements
started coming forward and expressed an
intent to become a more lawful protest
had you been briefed on that that's what
the RCMP actually indicated to me and of
course their goal is always to resolve
peacefully with the minimal use of force
so the the they took advantage of that
and what did you understand a more
lawful protest to look like
with the flow of the the information
that the RCMP were stating is their goal
was always certainly in the in
throughout the event but certainly at
the start was to re-establish the flow
of traffic through the uh the Coots
border crossing
and did that succeed
as I indicated earlier there were times
when it was successful in a limited
fashion in the sense that one lane was
left open
and uh and there was varying degrees of
flow of traffic sometimes escorted
sometimes
free-flowing at a small smaller Pace at
some points the Border was processing up
to 50 of its normal uh kind of volume of
traffic uh through the area and then it
would be shut down
um
for a period of time reopening the
shutdown again and then ultimately was
shut down until it was resolved for I
think two or three days at the end
so around
the 10th 11th yeah somewhere there yeah
it was resolved on the I think the 14th
yes
and
were is your understanding that during
this time commercial vehicles were still
using
um the Coots point of entry uh maybe in
limited numbers but that was some there
was still activity at the support of
Entry when the lanes were open yes uh
there were as I stated though there were
periods where they would be shut down uh
there was a period where there was a car
accident that necessitated a shutdown uh
so it wasn't a constant flow and uh it
was interrupted at times and then
reopened and then interrupted at times
then reopened and maybe I just want to
clarify my my understanding is that
um
the
the the blockade was
I don't have a sense of the distance but
maybe a kilometer away from from the
actual yeah Customs point of entry and
so that's why I'm kind of making a
distinction between the two yeah it's uh
yeah you're probably almost as familiar
with Yuri as I am having never actually
traveled through that border Point
myself but my understanding of it is the
actual customs office is just south of
where the the blockade took place which
is on the uh two two highways uh you
know two sections of Highway four which
traveled down to it and there's a bit of
a crossover and come back up to it and
that was where the uh where the blockade
itself was uh the primary blockade and
there was another one that uh actually
uh sort of rose up up
up the highway closer to the community
of Milk River yes yes okay
so you you've already spoken about the
contingency planning that was made with
alternate point of entries
um
do you have a sense of what the impact
was of of having to reroute some of that
traffic to those other points of entries
can you speak to that
some of the challenges were
as they were expressed to me and of
course I wasn't in
personal conversation on many of these
things were that U.S officials
receive certain type of goods types of
goods only at certain checkpoints live
live animal stock
foodstuffs uh
heavy transports versus uh automobile
traffic private vehicle traffic and
there was
a lot of challenge in trying to extend
not only hours of operation but also
accommodate at alternate points of
contact for Customs clearance the
different types of commercial goods that
travel through that border Point uh and
I and I will not profess to be an expert
in that area it's uh it's it's an area
that I understood to be a challenge and
one that was worked on throughout the
event with our
folks from transportation agriculture as
well as their U.S colleagues and cbsa
thank you
if we could pull up a ALB
ERS one five seven three
um I understand that on February 3rd
um Deputy commissioners zablas zablocki
of the RCMP sent a letter
um to uh Minister Savage
requesting the deployment of additional
officers under the uh the ppsa right
that's correct and that's the Provincial
Police service agreement between the
province and the RCMP is that correct
what's between the province and Canada
right yeah and the RCMP is the service
provider and that's the article that
allows for
the RCMP
to move policing resources across
multiple business lines in order to
self-support when their resources
require that
and and this is the response uh from
Minister Savage and if we can just go
down a little bit so there's a response
the same day that approves the the
request correct that's correct
um
and it says if you go down to the fourth
line
um this is in response to a current
blockade near the cootsland border
crossing and intelligence suggesting
further blockades planned throughout the
province in my opinion this constitution
an emergency in the province of Alberta
under the Provincial Police service
agreement
um
so why was additional deployment
necessary uh according to the RCMP what
did they tell you about that yeah my
conversations with uh Deputy
Commissioner zablocki in those
conversations he indicated that of
course the resource draw to maintain
order and safety at the at the blockade
and of course manage other events that
were and could be happening across the
province was significant and uh there
are specialized resources that are used
in in those in those types of events as
well as general duty resources and his
intent through uh through invoking this
article of the Provincial Police
Services agreement was to reach out to
other provinces for extra resources so
as to give his team relief in the sense
that he could spell people off for a
period of time get them through a rest
period and then put them back into into
their role and he eventually obtained I
think 40 officers from British Columbia
that's correct
um can you tell us about here it
mentions intelligence suggesting further
blockades planned throughout the The
Province what can you tell us about that
I might have mentioned it earlier but
during the the events at Coots we also
had uh events uh in Calgary uh numbers
of people uh protesting and uh walking
marching through the community we had
events at the legislature in Edmonton uh
we had
intelligence and actual uh action of
rolling blockades in some some parts of
the province I think Fort McLeod and a
few others uh so I believe Tabor police
dealt with a with a minor event as well
and so there were
there were also tracking on social media
at different times uh calls
from individuals to
protest in other parts of the province
and create other traffic style slowdowns
that sort of thing so that those would
have been the events that I believe the
Deputy Commissioner would have been
referencing although of course he
and be able to speak to that himself
thank you
um so at this time and this is February
3rd what was your understanding of why
the RCMP had not yet been able to bring
the blockade to an end
um
by February 3rd at that point in time
they were still working on negotiations
with the
protesters
if memory serves they had a lane open by
then and there was North and South
traffic flowing through there
it also by then encountered difficulties
if memory serves with obtaining heavy
tow capacity should they have to move to
an enforcement action
I don't believe at this point in time
they were looking to execute on an
enforcement action
they were
engaged in constructive dialogue that
had been keeping the the lanes
open mostly uh for for North cell
traffic to some degree and we're hoping
for a peaceful and uh you know
non-enforcement uh oriented uh solution
but they also recognized they had
challenges logistically
should they go there
and by that time the RCMP had begun to
look for uh Towing resources correct
that's correct and did they feel
obtaining those resources would be
necessary to any enforcement action yes
they did you can remove the people but
we would still have
large numbers of large vehicles that
were blocking the highway
um I I take it you're familiar with
Alberta's Emergency Management Act
I'm familiar with it
you mentioned it before this is one that
you actually need to to invoke that's
correct okay
um
and and so under that act the government
of Alberta can declare a state of
emergency province
and are you aware that the use of that
act would have allowed Alberta to compel
the use of of Towing resources of
operators and also to prohibit access to
certain areas I am aware of that
provision of the octium
in your witness statement you say that
Alberta considered invoking this
legislation but that it was determined
not to be necessary
um can you explain the basis for that
assessment
so as a public official we of course
provide advice to elected officials
within that we explored the realm of the
possible in the sense that we did
identify the emergency act its
provisions and and the authorities that
would come with its invocation we also
identified a number of statutes that
provided law enforcement with effective
arrests and and charging tools to to
deal with the actions that were taking
place at Coots and
to be fair there are a number of
authorities that exist
sub or below the the emergency act that
would allow for police to arrest detain
and remove people from that area the
determination was made by our government
uh that given the number of tools that
were already available in statute to
police
the addition of the emergency Act
would have changed nothing in terms of
the uh the authorities that the police
required and you mentioned compelling
individuals to to cooperate
um
that that would certainly be something
that could be attempted but there's also
information that
many of the individuals within the
industry were fairly supportive
of
the protest or did not wish to be seen
to be involved in
taking action against the protest for
their own reasons and I won't speak to
those because I don't want to put myself
in their head but
the reality is that a compulsion to
somebody to
to provide support
could conceivably and probably have been
met just as easily with a refusal and
then you are left with a choice of
having to
now deal with enforcement in relation to
service providers
and still not be any further ahead in
terms of where you're trying to go we
ultimately thought there were more
appropriate and better Avenues
uh to seek that's that support one being
Canadian Armed Forces support from cfp
Edmonton and the other is ultimately
what we did do which was resolved
ourselves through the purchase of
equipment
thank you
um
did you did
what was the basis I guess for the
assessment
um that some people may not comply even
if compelled did you receive advice on
that from rcnp from intelligence or or
was it just that's I should make that
clear that's a that's a that's a very
personal assessment on my part that was
not advice that was provided uh to
anybody and I and I can't speak to uh
our government officials our Minister
and Premier and where their head was at
on that so I should be very clear about
that and that basis is just experience
and and the reaction
and this wouldn't have been February 3rd
this would have been much close to 8th
or 9th that I was getting from
from my folks that were engaged in
conversations with the industry when
they were attempting to solicit support
from for the RCMP to use their equipment
uh it was
categorically
dismissed and people were
either not returning our calls
point blank or telling us that they just
refuse to cooperate
uh did the did the RCMP ever request
that the this act be invoked no they did
not
foreign
six zeros one six
these are um text messages between
Minister Sani
former minister of transport and uh
mayor Willett
and we can go to the second page
we can go down a little bit
okay here so you'll see here on the
right
um mayor Willett
says he's talking about meeting with
protesters they need someone from
government to get a straight answer from
if it comes up are you still willing to
take a trip to Coots and she responds of
course I need to get clearance from the
boss and RCMP
um where you consulted on whether the
government should send an emissary of
sorts to to Coots to to meet with
protesters
to be clear I've not seen this until my
preparation for the inquiry and this was
provided to me uh so I I wasn't
consulted I know there were
conversations at one point of mlas
independently meeting with protesters
and having conversations with them and
that was I've not seen anything to
substantiate whether that actually
occurred or not uh
my information is that
it wasn't something that the government
was officially trying to do and but
again I can't speak to whether it
happened or not I do know that during
those conversations
we met with our we not not we myself but
our department spoke with our Minister
around that to make sure that
we knew what may or may not be taking
place and could convey that to the RCMP
of course who are still charged with
managing the event
um
the information that that was conveyed
to me was that there were no
certainly official meetings taking place
down there and that they would be guided
by the RCMP
who of course had operational command
and were engaged in negotiations so as
not to complicate
any conversations that they might be
involved in and you know what the the
reason for because my understanding is
that Minister Sani did not end up going
uh to Coots
um do you know what the the reason for
that decision not to officially engage
with the protesters I was I don't I
can't put myself in the ministry's mind
I apologize for that
um
I don't believe we received any requests
from the RCMP though to engage at that
level
okay so I suspect that might have been
the reason
um in the institutional report it says
that the the RCMP asked the sheriff's
Highway Patrol Patrol not to take
enforcement action until February 7th do
you do you remember that
yes I do okay and do you know why that
was the case
again the RCMP I believe we're asking
that we make sure that our officers did
not take unilateral enforcement actions
outside of their operational plan uh
I can only surmise and I will leave it
to deputies of Blocky to confirm but
that would have been to
ensure that any actions that we took
didn't interfere with any negotiations
that might have been ongoing with
individuals at the site
okay and so what changed on the seventh
because I I know after the seventh there
was a number of violations were were
issued you know what changed that that
would have been a a time at the time
there was a sort of a very moderate or
small enforcement uh I guess you could
determine enforcement initiative that
the RCMP wanted to engage in uh
basically starting with information if
memory serves correctly moving into I
think it was checkpoint 10 near Milk
River to have conversations with people
provide them with information start
charging Vehicles Etc so it would have
been a coordinated effort based on the
rcmp's operational plan and under their
direction that our officers would have
been involved in
do you know if any protesters left
because of that limited enforcement
action around that time
I can't say that I'm sorry
I'm sure the RCMP could tell you but I
just I just don't have that off the top
of my hand
um in in the institutional report it
states the province made an alternative
protest site available and we we heard
this from other Witnesses at Milk River
and that that would have been on
February 10th can you tell us how that
came about
absolutely the RCMP actually
suggested that it would be useful to
them in their conversations with
protesters
if we were to make available a site that
they could protest on that would meet
their visibility needs but not obstruct
traffic
we engage with transportation and
ourselves but primarily transportation
in developing a site near Milk River
which met the needs of the RCP on
property that we owned already and
transportation actually
put in the access and egress areas for
protesters and set up I believe even
Wi-Fi access for protesters to to be
able to utilize in order to facilitate
those that wanted to protest lawfully
at the site this was a a tactic that the
RCMP
I wish to engage in to
you know manage the the negotiations to
to migrate this to a lawful
and did the RCMP brief you on whether
that was done because there was buy-in
from protesters on something like that
or done in hopes that once it was set up
they could they could get buy-in do you
know you know they did I I don't recall
knowing whether it was one or the other
okay
there's a request and of course we do
what we could to assist so we did it
um the institutional report states that
the sheriff's Highway Patrol Patrol
maintains certain checkpoints at other
points of Entry to prevent blockades
near other points of Entry yeah yes
that's correct uh Del Bonita and carway
were the primary the primarily the land
ports of Entry that we're concerned
about and under the direction of the
RCMP our Sheriff's
set up checkpoints there to ensure that
Vehicles traveling down to those points
of Entry had legitimate business reasons
to be doing so and are you aware of
whether any
um
potential blockades were throat thwarted
by those efforts or not I'm not I I
couldn't speak to what could have been
so yeah it's it's possible but I'm not
aware of any anybody showing up and
being turned away in a in on mass if you
will
I I understand that on uh February 9th I
believe uh a charge under the critical
infrastructure Defense Act was laid
against uh Pastor Archer balowski that's
correct
um is that the only charge that was laid
under the that act
I don't want to misspeak your uh
something tells me it was
used twice but I certainly that's the
only one that comes to mind
so you understood that the act at
could apply to the situation oh
absolutely yeah and and certainly uh
commissioner is a block in the RCMP
would have a lot
more fulsome detail on on the charges
doing did the RCMP ever explain to you
why it wasn't
utilized uh more
why that particular Act was not utilized
more no I I know that enforcement was a
strategy that was being looked at on a
case-by-case basis moment-to-moment
situation to situation and they would
use it in a manner that
worked for them in terms of managing the
overall event but they never provided me
with
you know detailed explanations around
why this charge against this person why
not this charge against these people
that's an operational level of detail
that's
candidly not something I would normally
ask about and that was within their
discretion to decide under what act to
charge 100
did did the Alberta Government ever take
any steps to
um
to kind of
um
attempt to have the Act use more more
fulsomely during this period or anything
like that
no no in the sense that we we're very
careful throughout the entire event to
ensure that we were not directing
police
in their operational response we were
asking questions
of them around
planning what they had done
if to the extent that they could share
what they would share in terms of their
uh their intentions and things that we
could do to facilitate the resolution of
the event but we're very careful not to
direct them
um your understanding is that law
enforcement action in the early morning
of February 14th is what led to the end
of the blockade
certainly that was the beginning of
events that ultimately led to the event
I I would
I would hesitate to say that that was
the single
event that was causal in that sense
there was a lot of work that was done by
the RCMP and others uh in the days
leading up to that to develop
relationships Etc so I'd to what extent
was this a
that crystallizing event the soul uh
reason and how much of that was
facilitated by the Outreach that was
done in in the past and the you know
Communications that was done by the
government around the impacts of this I
I think there are constellation of of
factors that could have played a a part
in in those decisions but certainly
those enforcement actions were a
catalyzing event for sure
did you ever hear from RCMP that one of
those factors may have been
um the the
rumors that the emergencies act would be
invoked no no
um so when did you hear that they would
the the sorry let me back up the the
evidence we've heard is that protesters
met in the morning of February 14th and
decided they would be leaving the next
morning were you advised on the 14th
that they had made that decision I was
and do you recall around what time you
were advised it was very early in the
morning that I was advised of the
the enforcement actions seven
well very early for me sorry seven seven
thirty
um
now I'm struggling now to recall if it
was at that particular conversation or
in one of the conversations I had in the
morning that I was advised that it
looked like the protesters were now
dismantling I I want to think it was
kind of a little bit later on but
that would be speculative on my part it
was all within the morning certainly of
the 14th
So within the morning you understood
they were leaving it would be leaving
the next morning you know or in
beginning preparation that day actually
and there was already events taking
people taking down tents and and
structures and and leaving on the 14th
and and was it
[Music]
um
I forget his name uh Deputy Commissioner
zablowski is he the one who who would
have been briefing you on that that's
correct Deputy Commissioner Curtis
zablocki
thank you
and your understanding is that the next
morning
hey we're all gone
by early morning for all intents and
purposes operations were resumed on the
15th at the at the border point I think
there were still
there may have been individuals still
packing up Etc uh in the area and I'm
not sure if Milk River
uh
had fully transitioned to the lawful
protest site
would have been the 15th
16th but I believe operations at the
border resumed on the 15th so your
understanding with respect to Milk River
is that
throughout that day at some point the
protesters at The Milk River checkpoint
would have moved to the legal protest
site or at least some of them yeah the
yeah they moved or left yeah
majority actually left if my memory
serves me uh from the conversations I
have with the deputy
this may be too on the ground for from
your Vantage Point but are you aware of
any protesters moving from Coots
to that legal protest yeah I wouldn't
have that knowledge sorry
and so your understanding is no other
than the raid early that morning uh no
enforcement action had to be taken to
clear that to clear the blockade and
coos
there were a couple of arrests and some
vehicle seizures Associated to an event
prior to the search warrants and and the
and the further charges there uh so and
there of course were the earlier charges
that took place later on uh but yeah
outside of that in in the actual
clearing of the blockade that's correct
yeah yeah there there were no further
arrests Beyond I think there were 13
individuals that were arrested in those
initial hours and so your understanding
is none of the powers under the
emergencies act were used oh yeah the
Federal Emergency yeah no no
ah what about uh other protests in
Alberta at that time what was their
status if you can recall
we continue to have
protests in Calgary
for for quite some time after that as
well as in Edmonton around the
legislature uh in
both the Edmonton Police the Calgary
police and the RCMP and our sheriffs
were involved in in those we had
protests at the Calgary remed Center
involving individuals supportive of Mr
praslowski uh pawlowski I apologize if
I'm saying the name wrong it's not
intentional
around that individual and we had a
number of events that recurred uh for
for some time
and in your witness statement you state
that there was always a possibility that
protesters would attempt another
blockade but to your knowledge there was
no intelligence suggesting that might
occur so is your evidence then that
there was no credible threats of of a
blockade forming after the 14th my my
recollection of the intelligence
briefings that I were getting was there
were individual chatter like individuals
that would chatter about we need to go
back regroup and re-establish but there
was no uptake uh being shown on on the
open source information that we're
receiving and no information that was
indicating that this was anything other
than aspirational chatter from isolated
individuals and so I I think it'd be
fair to characterize that there was no
no intelligence surface that would
indicate that was a real
threat for that to evolve but that's not
to say that the police didn't
take Serious the possibility I believe
the RCMP remained uh you know present in
some numbers and and Milk River and in
the area for for some time afterwards
just to ensure that that didn't take
place and were you ever briefed on on
any factors that would have led to there
being no uptake
of those kind of
threats no no
okay
um
let's talk a bit more about towing
capacity
um so I understand that fairly early on
I believe February 1st The Province
began to make requests for for towing
resources correct
that sounds right yes and those requests
were always for both tow trucks and tow
operators that's correct okay so when I
I'll refer to tow resources but capacity
yeah I mean both
um
was and and I think you've already told
us that those that capacity was critical
and necessary if any enforcement action
was to be taken
in the event of mass enforcement
actually I guess I should clarify that
if we were going to go and remove all of
the protesters and and remove the
blockage if the RCP were to do that that
would absolutely have to be in place
you tell us a little bit about the
challenges the province has faced in
obtaining tow capacity
to begin with the RCMP as the police
force of jurisdiction made their efforts
uh and they had some limited success
very early on very very early on first
days uh that that support dissolved from
industry quite quickly they went a field
and that was local support they went a
field and garnered some limited support
which also is quite
quickly dissolved and then they were
struggling after that to find any
support anywhere both within the
province and commercially outside of the
province briefcase Saskatchewan I
believe they might even have looked to
to commercial entities in the South but
I'm I'm not 100 certain of that I'll let
them speak to that they approached us to
indicate the challenges that we're
facing
and they indicated that they were going
through their channels to seek support
from the Canadian government for the use
of heavy lift capacity that exists at
the uh the Canadian Forces based in
Edmonton
and we're looking for anything that we
could do to assist in terms of just
generally trying to uh to us to work
through that we initially when tasked
with trying to support them
uh supported their call
for Canadian Forces logistical support
and we also
embarked on a process a sort of a an
evolving process of attempting to secure
that lift capacity for them uh the first
was through revisiting uh the commercial
entities that they'd contacted as the
government to try and secure support for
them
uh we're unable to gain any support that
way we looked a field to the city of
Edmonton City Left Bridge City Calgary
industry uh Atco those sorts of things
uh cncp uh colleagues to the south of
the U.S border to try and
look for any capacity that we could get
there we had some very limited success
in the sense that we had one city that
was able to provide us with uh with a
heavy tow truck and
that's a minor uh sort of like a loader
type and small small crane uh support
from another city but not uh the
equipment that the RCMP required so in
support of our our ass to the Canadian
Forces we had the RCMP actually
set out
exactly what they needed for equipment
should they have to go to that type of
reinforcement action and that was what
constituted uh sort of our our our list
of of uh tow trucks and and capacity
that we sought out for them
eventually
um
we uh determined that there was not
going to be a Commercial Avenue there
and it was becoming apparent that we
weren't going to get access to the tow
capacity at cfp Edmonton
and um we were able to through a
multiple
number of uh sort of
online sites identify
private vendors who had uh lift capacity
used tow trucks if you will for sale the
commercial providers of those entities
it was a long waiting list to get
anything from the actual manufacturers
we'd explored that already we did manage
to secure
a small number on the weekend of I think
it would have been the 12th we had them
uh in place down in Lethbridge and
turned over to the RCMP and by the 14th
had identified and we're closing the
deal on the remainder of the list saved
two items
which were all uh I believe in place on
the 15th in uh in in the south for the
RCMP at their disposal
super thank you
um if we could pull up ALB
ERS one five three so I'll have just a
couple more
um specific questions on on this topic
but you've provided great overview so
thank you for that
um
so so my understanding and I think you
you've mentioned it is that
the RCMP had already made a request of
Public Safety Canada for assistance from
the Canadian Armed Forces correct that's
correct okay
and that they had declined to become
involved is that your understanding like
I I I can't say that they declined to
the RCMP to become involved I can tell
you that the r should be indicated they
weren't seeing the support whether they
had an answer or not I I really would
have to defer to them because I don't
recall them ever telling me whether
they'd been formally told no
okay
um
and and do you know whether any uh other
options were being explored other than
the Canadian Armed Forces uh
within the federal government for these
kind of resources
I I can't speak to specifically what
options were being explored whether they
were looking at Transport Canada or
other entities for their capacity I did
have conversations at various times
uh with the assistant Deputy minister of
Transport Canada Uh Kevin Brussels
um around our needs and around uh
efforts that we were making along with
what I described earlier and also
reached out to to Industry uh contacts
within Alberta as had our transportation
department to try and encourage them to
help us in finding support
so I did ask transport Canada's ADM if
he could reach into his contacts within
industry and and see if they could
Garner any support from us whether that
materialized and in into any efforts or
not I would have to defer to Transport
Canada on okay thank you let's go to ALB
uh
5097 so this is the February fifth
letter uh from Minister McIver
to ministers Mendocino and Blair can you
explain what the purpose of that letter
was while it comes up
I have a quick peek oh I believe this
was the the formal request
for again there had been informal
conversations as a given to understand
before this but this is a formal request
uh
from our minister to the federal
ministers for the deployment of those uh
heavy lift capacity resources that the
Canadian Forces possessed in Alberta to
assist us in removal of any uh equipment
should should the RCMP go to an
enforcement action this was a formal
request for that support and it says we
can see at the bottom of that first
paragraph
um
at the end of the third to last line the
Royal Canadian Mounted Police have
exhausted all local and Regional options
to alleviate the week-long service
disruptions at this important
international border
um so what was meant by that that vrcmp
had exhausted all options
that as I described earlier that's their
efforts to try and secure commercial or
or other you know industry or city
support to provide those those kinds of
supports that they needed so that was
only referring to towing capacity that's
correct your understanding that's
correct yeah this this letter was about
towing capacity
and then if we can go to the second uh
last paragraph
so you see there to support this
approach I'm requesting federal
assistance that includes the provision
of equipment and Personnel to move
approximately 70 semi tractor trailers
and approximately 75 personal and
recreational vehicles from the area so
that was the request yeah and it was
structured that way as opposed to the
way that the RCMP structured their
request to us in the sense that we have
former military personnel and indicate
that you don't actually ask for the
equipment you ask for the capacity and
they determine the equipment okay
and here it doesn't specifically
indicate that this was a request for
Canadian Armed Forces at resources but
but was your understanding was that that
was what you were looking for
certainly that was what we were looking
for although any capacity that could do
that whether it came from the CAF or
some other branch of the Canadian
government would have been
welcome but you weren't necessarily
specifically aware of other sources I
could think of no other source okay
certainly in province
um
I I understand that there was a a
conversation between Minister McIver and
Minister Blair on February 7th so two
days later following up on this uh
request
um and do you know what
um what the the response from Minister
Blair was at that time
I
off the top of my head now I can't
recall but I think the response was
something to the effect it it might be
in the I think in your institutional
report in a case that he raised some
some doubts about the use of yeah that's
where I was gonna I think he was
indicating that they were having
conversations with the chief of Defense
but they weren't
it wasn't positive at that time it
wasn't clear either way yeah it wasn't
looking like there was there was
hesitation
if we go can go to
alb401868 so these are the text messages
uh between uh ministers
McIver and Blair
we can go to page two
as if we can just go down
so um
February 8th
um Minister Blair says sorry for the
delay in getting back to you I spoke to
our minister of defense and conveyed the
importance and urgency of an answer we
can keep going down
from CAF she's speaking to the chief of
Defense staff this morning and will
advise you were you were advised that
that had taken place that they were in
Communications yeah I was advised to
that I'd not of course seen the the text
themselves until my preparation for the
inquiry but I was advised that those
conversations were taking place
and in parallel to this as you've
already described the province was was
undertaking its own steps to obtain
these resources correct that's correct
to whatever ability we could we're
looking for anything we could find
um
we'll come back to this but if we can go
to
alb40s at 1 3 2 8.
this is a
an email chain from February 12th we can
start at the bottom
so who as uh rayan legendese we've at
the time she was the deputy Minister if
I'm not mistaken of uh transport
transportation in uh governor of Alberta
and so she writes to you
um that she's communicating with
Transport Canada and that they've struck
a working group
and that would be a good idea to Loop
you into that conversation and if we go
up to the second email
you advise
um and and the federal government as as
you see is copied on this exchange
correct uh the Transport Canada
specifically
Mr Keenan you say we're actually
supposed to make several purchases today
as a matter of fact the number of
vehicles identified for follow-up so so
you were aware that you would
communicate with the federal government
that that was taking place at the same
time that's correct yeah and my
apologies for the type one there was I
believe intended to say poised but uh it
was also Saturday afternoon there sounds
kissy
and you say our biggest challenge
appears to be obtaining operators at
this time
though we might be faster on equipment
Acquisitions if we can combine efforts
and so were you uh
were you of the view that you were
making progress on the equipment but the
operators were still the largest issue
that's correct yeah we were making
progress by then we'd acquired some of
the list and were working on leads some
of which later fall through but others
that ultimately approved fruitful on the
13th and that was one of the things you
had asked the federal government for
that's correct it was my hope that we
were searching out with our team for
commercial capacity that we could
purchase and I was thought that perhaps
the federal government could
do the same and
we could just go up to the top
um
so again they're a third paragraph down
uh Transport Canada was coordinating a
working group
um in security to to
support local police provincial
authorities and and securing Truck and
Tractor removal capacity so you were
what was your understanding of of those
efforts maybe if you can describe that I
don't I actually don't have a lot of
information around the efforts that were
being made at the federal level we did
have uh a follow-up conversation uh the
next day with uh ADM brousseau uh and uh
pwgsc representative
prior to us actually completing the
purchase of the last group of equipment
uh but I'm not sure what efforts they
were actually undertaking at the federal
level it was unclear to me
we can go to ALB four
zeros1468 so that same day you had
Communications with Kevin brusso
um who is he he's the assistant Deputy
at the time he's assistant Deputy
Minister for Transport Canada
and if we can go down
um what were you providing him with here
on February 12th
this was on the 12th so this was the the
remaining items from the list that the
RCMP had provided us which we had yet to
acquire
uh so of course those those are those
the items uh we were still looking to to
get although I
again we had a
deal pending later that day that
ultimately fell through on much of this
and then we ended up acquiring it all on
it was saved the top two items we
acquired the rest of those on the 13th
on the 13th
uh well they were in our possession
14th 15th something like that okay the
Deal started on the 13th if we
um if we can so you provide them with
the list and then if we go up
oh sorry go down to the bottom actually
um
you I understand you guys had a phone
call that day
what do you recall being discussed
I think that was just a touch base I'm
going from vague recollection here so
please uh you know know that they're
this might not be 100 correct but from
my memory the conversation was fairly
generic in the sense that we were
touching base talking about the fact
that we needed to combine resources and
talking about uh what we had Acquired
and what we were trying to acquire and
that was the trigger for my for my
following email to him giving him the
list of what was outstanding again I'm
going from memory so I apologize if
that's not a 100 accurate and your
understanding at that time was that they
were still working on the request
they're working on ways to support us
that's correct yeah and in terms of the
Canadian Forces request you yes
um and did the Alberta Government ever
receive a formal response to the the
February 5th request not that I'm aware
of okay if we could go to
pb.can.nsc 50690
so um
my understanding and we'll see this when
the document comes up is that this is a
draft
response to to that request
we go down a little bit
you'll see a second paragraph below is
the current draft of our RFA request
response
if we go down
um
will go down a little bit further
sorry down more
okay
um
oh I'm sorry
okay so my colleagues and I have given
your request serious consideration we
have consulted key Partners to assess
our ability to assist you given the lack
of commercial resources the Canadian
Armed Forces would be the only Federal
asset that might potentially meet this
request unfortunately discussions have
made clear that the CAF have neither the
type of assets required nor the
expertise to do this without significant
possible risk was that sentiment ever
communicated to you
um
verbally or in in writing some other way
not not like that no no uh I know
there's
from personal experience I know there's
hesitance on the part of the Canadian
Armed Forces to be involved in any
police type actions domestically and I
understand that's a a an issue of
concern to to them into the government
account of course
um
obviously not
receive this yes it was a draft so I
don't think it was sent
um we have former
significantly high ranking
Canadian Armed Forces officers who are
now with the within the government of
Alberta including
uh Lieutenant Colonels Colonels
Brigadier generals major generals and a
lieutenant general who have experience
that
in command of
Canadian Armed Forces based in Alberta
surprised that
to read that they thought that the
assets
they don't have the assets required to
move those Vehicles given that
you know the the Armed Forces based in
from my personal knowledge in Alberta
has the assets to move tanks
uh leopard tanks being very large uh so
they can recover uh lift load and and
move tanks uh would have thought they
would add a capacity for this but
I'm not with Canadian Armed Forces
um
in terms of risk one of the things that
we made clear in our conversations
uh
internally and that the RCMP uh
I'll let them speak to it but I'm hoping
made clear as well as there would be no
use of any Canadian Armed Forces
personnel and enforcement capacity they
wouldn't be meeting protesters on the
ground uh the RCMP would be responsible
for
clearing and making safe the area and
any heavy equipment movement would take
place after that had taken place and the
CAF would have been there dealing with
equipment by people so
I'm not sure where the significant risk
heart comes from but again I can't speak
to uh to the caf's response or the
government account is response so I'll
let them explain their thinking on that
okay I just want to look at this
paragraph that starts with further and
it says I understand that Alberta has
the required legal authorities necessary
to enforce compliance
as a highway is considered essential
infrastructure and is unlawful to
willfully obstruct interrupt or
interfere with the obstruction
maintenance use or operation of any
essential infrastructure in a manner
that renders the essential
infrastructure dangerous useless and
operative or ineffective as per the
critical infrastructure Defense Act of
Alberta there are a number of
contraventions or other applicable
legislation that may also be enforced by
Alberta and its police forces I
encourage you to look at the actions
taken in Nova Scotia New Brunswick in
Ontario who have used new or existing
authorities to safeguard at critical
infrastructure
um
had had this type of sentiment been
communicated to you and your discussions
with the federal government uh that
Alberta ought to be
making better use of the enforcement
Authority at its disposal
it had not been communicated to me uh
but candidly it's a little off point to
the request in the sense that the
request was not for assistance in
bringing laws to bear that would
would enable our officers to conduct
enforcement actions we had as I
indicated earlier
considered all of the legislative
Authority that was available in the
toolbox for for law enforcement to deal
with this and felt that there was
sufficient I would agree with the
statement that there are sufficient
legislative authorities within existence
at the time
to give the police the authority to act
the challenge was that to support their
actions in that manner and to ultimately
remove those Vehicles we're required a
logistical capacity that the police
lacked not a legislative Authority but a
logistical capacity and we were looking
to the government of Canada and the
Canadian Forces to to help augment that
logistical capacity Gap
candidly the police already knew
about these this legislation and the
police didn't request any additional
enforcement at authorities no
if we can go to PB dot c a n four zeros
um one five one four
so this is a call at notes or or
yeah notes from a call on February 13th
between uh assistant Deputy minister
dalkadbab at
um
do you I believe you participate in this
call and there was adms from Manitoba
Ontario Alberta you recall this yeah I
recall the conversation with talalin if
we can just go down
um there's a a bullet marked Alberta
and bold
and I'd like to look at the second
bullet under that Alberta requests CAF
support
Alberta requests for CF support have
been denied but they are surprised at
their request to access reservists with
operational skills needed to drive
towing trucks was not accepted this part
of the request is news to us and we
committed to follow-up on this specific
point I should clarify these are notes
taken on on the I believe Transport
Canada side
um was your understanding
from this call that the request for the
towing trucks denied
that's correct uh there was also and I
think for clarity uh around the
reservist piece there was another
another proposal that was being
communicated and I can't tell you
through what channel but it was to for
the Canadian Armed Forces and the
governor County to consider uh the use
of some of the reservists that might
have
operator skills
to operate heavy lift equipment should
we acquire it we had some that were
identified but we could use a few more
and if there were a reservists within
the Canadian Air Forces who by virtue of
their experience in in their trades
might have that skill set we'd
propered up the idea that perhaps we
could use them
either on a
on a you know on a as a hired capacity
to us or through whatever whatever
mechanism might make sense to the CAF uh
on their own time uh to uh to support us
and uh
the response that I was made aware of
was that that would not be considered
that sorry that the
um use of those reservists would not be
would not be considered and and what's
your understanding from this call
um
that
Transport Canada had not considered
the the part of the request with respect
to operators yeah that reservist portion
that was actually something that neither
uh
until all or Transport Canada the ADM
from Public Safety Canada or his
colleague from uh from TC uh had
indicated they were aware of but they
were going to look into that
okay
if we can
um
Mr clerk I don't know if you still have
that text message exchange available
that I said I would come back to
foreign
from Coots
no Minister Blair and Minister McIver
uh it would take me a moment but it may
be quicker if you can provide yes I'm
just uh
sorry looking forward here
maybe it's ALB one six one eight six
eight maybe yeah
sounds like there's a consensus
thank you Mr commissioner
I I know I'm coming up on my time here I
I have I'd say
maybe five minutes left that's okay
okay thank you
if we could go to uh page three
if you go down
so there was a follow-up on February
10th and February 21st and and your
understanding is there was no answer
from the minister before the invocation
of the ACT based on the text exchange
that I see here but you had in the call
on the 13th you were aware
through Transport Canada they would not
be providing the tow truck resources
they had not been able to provide that
and I was aware from other conversations
that the CAF were not okay looking to to
assist
and so I'll just look at the response
here from Minister Blair on February
21st you may be aware that we invoke the
emergencies act on February 15 which
addressed the tow truck issue quite
effectively happy to answer any
questions you may have although and we
can continue
I'm sure the RCMP can advise you on how
it works a letter will be forthcoming we
can keep going
I understand prime minister spoke to
Premier Kenny about the emergencies act
but I you can keep going
uh will ensure correspondence follows to
you
and then Minister McIver responds we
receive no help until after Coots issue
is resolved and you know that
disappointed to hear you say otherwise
keep going
at to the next page
as I was disappointed to learn of your
reaction to our efforts to respond to
the threat to critical infrastructure
and the Integrity of our International
borders posed by these illegal blockades
fortunately the cacp the oacp and RCMP
and the Ontario Provincial Police have
been clear and unequivocal that these
measures have been essential to their
efforts to solve the criminal blockades
and
occupations we are all grateful that the
RCMP was able to resolve the very
dangerous situation I could safely
keep going to the next page
what is true is that Coots was resolved
on the 14th and we got our own tow
trucks after you could uh no not help I
guess continue your letter speaks for
itself
as does your lack of response until too
late
getting to the end
uh to be clear is your point that we
should have invoked the emergency's ACT
earlier
no you were too late and did the wrong
thing my point is saying nothing now
would have been better than not telling
the truth
um I wanted to ask you about this this
last text from Minister McIver that you
were too late and did the wrong thing
what is that in reference to
if you have an understanding yeah it's
it's difficult yeah it's very difficult
for me to to put my head directly into
the mind of uh Minister McIver uh
candidly though my understanding and
in interest from this based on our our
Global conversations within the Goa
where that we didn't require the
legislative Authority
of the emergency act to resolve our
issue we required it we required uh
logistical help that was available in
province
and it was denied to us so we found a
different way to
to address it that is
bought our torture bought the tow trucks
ourselves
thank you I that that's again in the
absence of being able to have
spoken to them directly on this that
that's my sense of it understood thank
you
um
just uh a last topic here and that won't
take me very long
um
my understanding is that
a first Minister's meeting was held on
February 14th where the the federal
government consulted with the premiers
of the provinces on the potential use of
the emergencies act you're generally
aware of I'm aware that that took place
yes that there was a meeting of the
first ministers on the 14th
and do you have any knowledge of whether
uh Premier Kenny was provided with
advanced notice of of that first
Minister's meeting
no I personally was not involved in the
conversations but uh I'm aware and have
viewed uh information from our premier's
office and as chief of staff that
outlines the fact that the premier was
not provided with advanced notice is
normally a process for engaging in the
setting of first ministers meetings
which will often be a week or more in
advance with agendas and topics uh the
information provided from our premier's
office is that there was no advance
notice and there was no advance notice
of topic there's no time to gather
information or brief uh the premier on
the emergency side because it was
unclear
yeah we did have a notice of of that
being there the the meeting on the 14th
thank you very much Mr Grant those are
my questions thank you
okay
um
well I think we can take the morning
break at this point uh so we'll take uh
15 minutes and come back
to uh proceed with the uh forever
examination and cross-examination so 15
minute break thank you so much
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
foreign
order a lot
the Commissioners we can be in the
commissary Pro
foreign
[Music]
okay first I'd like to call on the
government of Canada please
oh
thank you Mr commissioner Mr degrand my
name is Brendan vindian Heist and I'm
one of the lawyers for the government of
Canada in this matter good morning
sir in response to this series of
questions you were just asked about
whether Premier Kenny was consulted
about the setting of the first ministers
meeting I believe you said that this was
the information available to you from
the premier's office is that right
that's correct sir
and that is not information that we have
seen under oath or affirmation is that
fair
I
I could I will assume that's the case
I've not been following all the
proceedings of my apology you're not
aware of that I'm not aware of that now
and you yourself were not I take it
present at the first Minister's meeting
that's correct
and likewise you were not personally
present for Premier Kenny's telephone
conversations with the minister of
Public Safety for example that's correct
or the prime minister right that's
correct sir
and there's nothing you're aware of that
disables former Premier Kenny from
swearing his own affidavit about these
matters
I'm not familiar enough with the
proceeding to even comment on that but
no
you're not aware of anything that
disables him from testifying before this
commission should he have wished to do
so
lean into asking this witness a legal
question about whether or not there's
anything that prevents a former Premier
from swearing an affidavit
uh I I'm not sure it's a legal question
of wondering if the witness is aware of
anything that disables the former
Premiere from doing so well and actually
it all due respect actually would would
suggest that I'm not a lawyer and I
wouldn't actually probably be qualified
for that I'm not aware of that but I I
could very well be things there that I'm
not aware of okay fair enough
um let's turn to you sir you were an
assistant commissioner of the RCMP until
2018 is that correct
that's correct
and so you understand well here uh what
um the Deputy Commissioner is a blocky
and the other RCMP officers involved in
the Coots blockade went through yes
I I have a sense of it I was obviously
not on the ground but and it was not
operational at the time but I have
previous experiences that would
certainly inform on that and you respect
Deputy commissioners of Blocky and his
service in the discharge of his duties
and respect of Coots
absolutely yes and every work a division
of the RCMP policed the province of
Alberta during these events right
yes I have a great deal of respect for
uh Commissioners block and his command
team
you became an assistant Deputy minister
with Alberta Justice in 2018 right
uh that's actually not quite correct I
started as an executive my apologies you
would have no way of knowing this or so
it is I started as an executive director
uh so sort of the I reported to the
assistant Deputy minister at the time
Bill Sweeney and I became uh the ADM in
2021.
sorry I just wanted to be factually
accurate No No I appreciate that um just
going with uh yeah no of course you
would have no way to know that so
um
you swore the province's institutional
report uh in this proceeding as well
right yes I did Circle we'll come back
to that
now in the province of Alberta this
situation if I can call it that began
really on January the 29th is that
accurate yes from memory that's in terms
of the beginnings yeah who's the the
Slow Roll yeah
and if we go to ALB four zeros 10 10 at
page two
just pull up the initial report about it
to you sure thank you
if you go down to page two please
you see that um uh
I take it it's some Peter 250 I think
report reporting to you about the
blockage of the uh roads north and south
to the Coots border right yeah that uh
would be uh now Chief superintendent I'm
not sure if he was at the time Peter
2fik with Yar champagne
okay and it says in the second last
substantive paragraph there the
organizers have made calls to the
participants to move their vehicles but
the message has been ignored right
that's correct and the strategies are
being worked on to get those who are
participating in the stoppage to get
roadways moving again right
that's correct
okay if we go up to the first page
you see a report moving just a little
further up the page there's a report of
the officers who are deployed just to
the top please
there we go and you see the report from
Jason Delaney to Rick Gardner is that um
from the Alberta sheriffs you've got 12
members deployed Coots
yeah that's correct yeah that's uh on
the on the 29th and uh three of them
have been reassigned from call Dale to
reassigned from Red Cliff and uh two are
sent in from Lethbridge on overtime
right
three from Coaldale two from Coots uh on
the first day shift and then the evening
yeah three from Coots to reside from
Radcliffe and two from overtime that's
correct okay and they are CMP supplying
25 uh cbsa a dozen and this Canadian
Pacific Railway police uh a single
officer
yeah that's what it says yes correct
uh could we go to alb401312
page two
if you just go to page two please this
will be a tweet from the premiere issued
on uh or or tweeted on January the 30th
it says the blockade of the Coots border
crossing violates the Alberta traffic
safety act it's causing significant
convenience for lawful motorists
and continuously impede movement of
emergency service Vehicles this blockade
must end right that's correct and
um if you flip over to page three you'll
see that he issues a longer statement
which is to the rich is really to the
same effect yes that's correct yeah
and this had no effect on the Coots
process this had no immediate effect on
the Coots protest today I it would be
difficult for me to say What
individualized affected had but
ultimately we we still had a blockade
you still had a blockade okay can we go
to ALB four zeros one two five seven
please
foreign
this is a report which comes to you if
you could just move down the page please
uh that further down there we go and you
see it's being reported to you now
Tuesday the 1st of February uh that
you're receiving information about new
blockades on the Highway by Fort McLeod
on Highway 3 by Pincher Creek and calls
to block Highway 43 West of Grand
Prairie right that's correct and did you
interpret those as being a blockade
sympathetic in spirit to the blockades
at Coots
if they in fact were accurate that would
have been the assumption that was being
made uh but we just were making sure
that that information was passed on the
RCMP we're also who were also hearing
that and I believe the
at least two of the three might have had
some
activity but it was resolved reasonably
quickly
if we go to
alb1263 please ALB four zeros one two
six three
this is a February first intelligence
assessment provided to you sir thank you
and just want to make a few highlights
here of what some is brought to your
attention as well as that of some of
your colleagues from psio that's the
provincial Security Office yeah it's a
provincial security intelligence office
thank you
um so the first point is that there
doesn't appear to be centralized
leadership at this blockade right that's
correct it emerged from the so-called
Freedom Convoy movement right
emerge from in the sense that it's
inspired by and in support of that's
correct and if you go to Item B there
doesn't appear to be any overt Direction
being given between the Coots blockade
and Ottawa Freedom Convoy organizers
um although this is possible Right
anything's possible but there was no
information or intelligence to support
that although that of course was one of
the things that uh our the law
enforcement agencies was looking to to
determine okay it refers in the last
sentence under B there to be one of the
spin-off support events with the Ottawa
Convoy that gained its own momentum and
now appears to be self-supporting right
yeah that's correct uh individuals
outside of the blockade location appear
to be acting as entrepreneurs in
organizing support and Logistics right
that's correct you were seeing that yeah
that's uh what the information
intelligence that was being reported to
me was of course I relied on that okay
if you go further down the page
you see already that there are
individuals on Pro blockade social media
groups organizing phone campaigns to
threaten tow companies with financial
repercussions and to set up boycotts of
companies they believe have acted in
support of the police right
is that a serious concern to you at that
point already it was because it was of
course one of those factors that was
limiting the cooperation of the RCMP
were able to gain from that industry
if we go down the page further than to
spin off actions there's social media
comments calling on blockade supporters
to block in police to prevent them from
removing vehicles from the site correct
yeah those are individual comments that
were out there that's correct okay and
you're also hearing from your law
enforcement partners that support
convoys have bypassed or broken through
police blockades to deliver supplies
yeah
yeah that's correct there was even
reports of uh Vehicles such as farm
implements and tractors coming across
country over instead of on-road to to
get to the site it's a very open area
and it's very difficult to contain and
secure the PSA always reporting that
social media messages are promoting a
decentralized blockade of Highways
throughout Alberta yes
yeah there were individuals out there
calling for spontaneous action around
the province in support of the blockade
uh very little materialized other than
the the main concerns that emerged in uh
in Edmonton and uh Calgary although as I
indicated earlier there were some small
ones I think you saw them at former
cloud and uh Tabor like I mentioned
earlier and a few others
could we go um just to the very bottom
of the page now and see the last section
here intelligence gaps
um do you see that section I do sir
thank you and the two this refers to
areas where there just isn't visibility
uh from an intelligence perspective as
to the identity of the leaders in their
level of influence at the blockade site
right that's correct yeah it was very
difficult to find uh true to find
leadership and you've got an
intelligence Gap about how much support
is likely to manifest in the real world
from the calls for decentralized
blockade action exactly sir all right
um let's go now please to
alb401620 this is a February 1st report
concerning what's referred to as a brawl
uh near the blockade okay are you
familiar with that I think I know which
one you're referencing but I'll did you
happen to observe the testimony of Mr
van Finn uh boss no I did not actually
sir sorry okay
um if you go down the page uh it says
you're reporting here that you assume
others are well aware of this but if you
go down the page we'll just
see what's reported out to you
here we go
and this is a report
um about how the if you look at the
third sentence the crowd became
increasingly hostile at and made threats
against members that is law enforcement
members at the checkpoint to the point
where they surrounded the members right
that's correct yeah and the protesters
pushed through the barricades with their
vehicles and collided with vehicles
traveling Northbound on Highway 14. yeah
that is my understanding of is the
officers at this at the checkpoint uh
move their vehicles to avoid any
collision and then vehicles from the
checkpoint began to Traverse Southward
at least one was in the northbound lane
and collided with another vehicle that
was northbound in the northbound lane
and that is when the reference to the
brawl is uh there was a confrontation
that ensued between the participants in
the Collision that the RCMP and sheriffs
on scene had to break up yes and I know
you didn't have a chance to observe it
but when we were here with Mr higginboss
some
I believe he watched a video of that
incident taken by the driver oh oh okay
interesting yeah sorry I haven't seen
that well you can go back and watch it I
will thank you sir
um
could we go now please to alb401313
this will be a February 2nd report sir
on social media intelligence work being
done by psio okay thank you
um
in this case uh you'll see that you're
being informed
that uh from a web and social media
perspective the term bear hug is a
rising search query do you see that
yeah that's correct I think that was
information from other Ministries uh
Deputy ministers were receiving
intelligence that over various social
media platforms I think Facebook and
others that people were calling for a
bear hug which was a call to sort of
obstruct traffic uh throughout the
province if we go to ALB four zeros one
six one one this is still on the 2nd of
February and it's reporting on events in
Calgary
also associated with this phrase bear
hug
okay
thank you
just go down the page
there we go so this is a report coming
in
with respect to an operation bear hug
calling for truckers to block major
highways in Alberta
and at the top there's an operation bear
hug and Calgary
um intended to support the Convoy on the
5th of February which is this upcoming
weekend right
correct
I guess it's important to ensure that
this is characterized as aspirational
intelligence these are people that are
trying to develop uh these these things
uh I don't think we ever
developed significant intelligence in
this area but certainly there were some
sporadic and small-scale events
uh you'll see in that second paragraph
that there's um uh ask whatever you want
to call it forward-looking intelligence
that there's a plan to gather near The
Minister's house yeah
okay that's correct and if you go down
the page a bit just to scan through it
you'll see that there's events being
reported on in the southern region north
central Fort McMurray regions and peace
region right
yeah the uh if you're looking at the
North Central region those are
unconfirmed reports uh and then peace
region again unconfirmed reports of
activity around there of
uh or plans uh plant activity calls to
block every road yeah those are calls
yeah that's correct sir
um this term bear hug are you familiar
with the term as uh having been promoted
by an outfit called Canada unity and a
gentleman named James bouter
I'm not actually no I'm sorry you
haven't made a bit of a disadvantage
there sorry that's fair enough
um at any rate it's it's it's
clear by February the second when you're
receiving these reports that there's the
potential for
uh police resources becoming somewhat
stretched in the province is that fair
oh absolutely depending on how things
manifest themselves and evolved but
that's certainly the point of the
intelligence was to make police aware
and the RCMP is police of jurisdiction
under contract with the province of
Alberta are responsible to please the
whole of the province some and not just
Coots right that's correct although
there are as I indicated earlier
Municipal forces in Lacombe for instance
in Left Bridge Medicine Hat et cetera
absolutely fair enough aside from the
Municipal Police Service yeah and the
First Nation Services that's correct if
we go to ALB go back to ALB five zeros
543 please
foreign
this will be the letter from Deputy
Commissioner
article nine yeah the um invocation of
9.1 okay yes please okay so we just
moved down the page um
uh and the end of the first paragraph do
you see um well you told us that you uh
greatly respect uh Deputy Commissioners
to block his judgment as a police
officer Fair that's correct sir and you
see that um uh uh Deputy commissioners
of block he indicates in the last
sentence of the first paragraph that
this situation does in my opinion
constitute an emergency in the province
of Alberta
I see that yes correct do you consider
that a reasonable assessment on his part
insofar as it's uh it's pertaining to
the Provincial Police Services agreement
yes and I guess there's some context
there sir in the sense that
the Provincial Police Services agreement
under article 9 uh envisions uh
situations which would require
um the movement of resources
to support major events uh emergencies
Etc as defined as
as they pertain to that act or that uh
that that uh that agreement that
contract if you will uh it's a little
different than say perhaps our
provincial emergency actor or perhaps
Federal I'm just not sure I just don't
want to conflate the two different
definitions no that's fair enough um if
you look at the second paragraph he
refers to
uh this urgent and critical situation
being what warrants him requesting the
extraordinary application of the
emergency Provisions in the agreements
correct that's correct yeah you betcha
and um that is going to involve bringing
in trans or transferring in more RCMP
officers from places other than Alberta
correct
not only that but also movement of
officers within Alberta from different
business lines to because there are
provincial policing business lines there
are also Municipal business lines and
federal lines and it would allow him to
to dip into those resources as well as
resources out external little province
to augment his Provincial Police Service
and give them the resources they need to
to manage the event could we go to ALB
four zeros 1177
um and if you bring them in from other
provinces particularly though what it
means is you've got less police
available in those provinces to please
those jurisdictions Fair
that's correct when we receive such uh
requests for our offices as well one of
the first questions we ask is of course
what is the impact on court policing and
it's up to the commanding officer of
that division that's sending them to
determine whether those can be sent in a
manner that's safe and here you're
reporting about the information you've
received from provincial colleague in
British Columbia about the planned
events there correct
those were the intelligence pieces that
they were hearing that's correct and
they were hearing aspirational
information as well around Saskatchewan
and Manitoba I believe in that
conversation I had with my colleague and
all three of those are provinces which
also rely upon the RCMP as a primary
place of jurisdiction outside of the
media those some municipalities large
enough to have their own service that's
that's correct
and so those protests could likewise
draw exceptionally on local resources in
order to maintain order if that had to
be done by the RCMP fair if they
materialized to certain levels
yeah I'm certainly could but I'm not
sure whether they did or not
um can we go to ALB
50528 please
the bottom of the
page please
I might have the wrong uh reference so
never mind um you are you became aware
that there were protests planned for
Edmonton the weekend of February uh
fourth and 5th
yeah that sounds right sir yeah it does
yeah a considerable number of vehicles I
think several thousands showed up
according to the institutional report
that's correct yeah there's a multiple
points of origin and they converged in
in Edmonton there in the Edmonton Police
the sheriff's uh working with assistance
from the RCP uh were tasked with
managing that event February 4th is the
Friday heading into this weekend I think
that's yeah from memory that sounds
right thank you now did you have an
opportunity to hear mayor will it
testify yesterday I did not surround
you've been kind of careful to avoid too
much because I didn't want to color my
own opportunity here and I'm sure you
have other things to do as well so let's
um go we heard from mayor Willett if we
could call up cou uh 6016
we heard mayor Willett testify yesterday
about his perspective on the ground
really from the ground level at Coots
okay okay thank you and this will be a
text exchange with Minister Sani that he
attended into evidence yesterday okay
commission Council can we go to page um
uh seven please
um here we see an indication of him on
February 4th that um
an Archer pawlowski had showed up and
fired everyone up at the Coots protest
site to convince them to stay aware of
that yeah I actually am aware of that
event yes
from the rcmp's reporting not from this
conversation
could we go to
pb.can.401835 it's the multimedia file
that we had yesterday
and I'm going to ask to play this from
the 207 207 Mark until 4 18.
thousands upon thousands of people are
coming
they don't have enough or CNP officers
to deal with doctors right they don't
have enough hiring to deal with that
right remember you have the power now
yes do not give it away just because it
feels right and yes some of you might be
arrested yes some of you might pay the
price I'm not going to teach you that is
pleasant and Beautiful on concrete in
jail facing the biggest guns in the
country it's not
they don't treat us well over there
especially when you're a pastor three
days on concrete and two nights every
half hour they banged on my door they
did not allow me to sleep for three days
and two nights they wrapped me up they
stripped naked me they put chain on my
leg and yet I'm still here with you yes
those people don't blame her
they're coming here with their Badges
and they're telling you that they
represent the law no they're
representing they're represent
lawlessness
they are gangsters for the biggest Mafia
that there is Kenny's Mafia
and it's up to you now for the first
time in two years
to rise up to stand up and to hold the
forks that's right and if this is our
Alamo
so be it and if you don't want to be
here
No One Is Stopping You
you can take your car or your truck and
you can go there is a huge rally in
Calgary there's a huge rally in Edmonton
you can join them no one will think of
you as a coward everyone has to face the
Giants of the lungs but I'm telling you
there is this huge opportunity right now
that we have been given
God has given us this moment in history
why because International media are
watching you right now that's power yes
during 1980
s
thank you have you seen that um that
speech before by uh by by Archer
palowski no I haven't actually thank you
um you hear that he is singling out
Premier Kenny is the source of the
problem and I believe he referred to
Kenny's Mafia
that's what I heard yes
um and he said this is our Alamo
referring I take it to a the standoff at
the Alamo in Texas that's I assume the
reference and he points to the
international attention that has been
gathered and says that's power right
that's correct
uh could we go to cou
um
six zeros one six this similarly we
heard from mayor Willett about and it is
uh uh the same series of text exchanges
and I just want to address one other
factual issue that was circulating oh
thank you page nine
foreign
message
um again with Minister Soni to um
a gentleman named Paul Brandt do you see
that
yeah I do sir thank you
and he's referring to the a rebel news
story and seeing that in my opinion Paul
Branch posed a clarification on the
rebel news story that he helicoptered
and ate you familiar with that I'm
familiar with the the story or the rumor
about that yeah yeah you better go down
go down the page
and you see that mayor
um well it indicates that that's not in
fact true that his photograph that was
circulating of Paul Brandt uh was five
years old right
correct that's what it says there
um
Paul branch is a uh just for for the
benefit of whoever doesn't know he's a
well-known internationally successful
country musician from Alberta correct
that's correct and there was a rumor
than fact that he was going to come and
perform a concert in support of the
Coots blockaders right that was one of
the two rumors that we heard involving
Mr Brad if we go to
um
uh
uh page 13.
you see Minister Sani still on the next
day February the 6th she's asking uh was
food dropped off to the protesters by
helicopter right
correct yeah and that's that that's the
character of the rumor that was going on
about Paul Brandt that he dropped off
food by helicopter right well I don't
see his name on this text but certainly
that was one of the rumors whether there
was other rumors that uh the minister
was hearing about other helicopter drops
uh there were and I'm not even sure I
think by this point the no time or the
notice Airmen restricting airspace might
have been in place as well so that might
have been I I don't want to put myself
on the mind of ministry as to what she
was concerned about sure according to
Mayor Willard at least he says Rebel who
entered a chopper and made a video which
is what circulated is that is that
according to your recollection of what
happened there I see I'm not familiar
with uh any information around Rebel
news renting a chopper but certainly
that's the uh that's the post from the
from the mayor if we could go to ALB
four zeros144
and I just want to suggest at any rate
that what this this notion about fall
Brandt renting a helicopter coming to
drop off food putting on a concert that
was disinformation right I believe it
was we actually
conveyed that to the RCMP and they had
conversations with Mr Brandt's Personnel
in the claim they they indicated that
they had no intention of providing a
concert there and and did not violate
the no town okay and if you go to the
bottom of this page this is a report to
you from uh from uh your psio director
yes
yeah that's correct sir on February 6th
and at that point um 3 27 in the
afternoon
uh he is saying that there's no credible
public information confirming this brand
helicopter story but it appears
plausible based on the aircraft itself
I'm sorry
so yeah yeah we share the same speed of
talking sorry uh yes I I do read that
there's uh that's based on the
photograph that was received uh what I
was hearing from from uh Mr McCauley was
that
there's nothing to state that this
actually happened uh the helicopter and
the picture appears consistent with that
used by Mr Brandt uh but there's nothing
to indicate
uh you know whether he did what was
being rumored to have been done without
his resupply and even if that was the
case it would appear that it would have
taken place prior to any noticed Airman
uh restrictions on the airspace being in
place yes okay and that's the no Tam
that's referred to there were notice to
Airmen yes that's correct sir
um can we go to uh
uh ALB four zeros one six two six
this is a report to you raised for your
attention I think again on February the
7th now so the Monday thank you Tuesday
February 7th okay thank you
Monday Monday it is
um if you go down to the bottom
indications being forwarded up to you a
regional stakeholder raised the
following concern there's the risk that
many of the protesters referring to
Coots are armed with Firearms kept in
their tractor trailers and Chucks
violence as possible right yes that's
what came to me from uh ultimately
through the through Mr buffin and that
if and that proved to be the case
ultimately did it not I'm not sure where
the Firearms were found if there were
any found in trucks and cabs but
certainly ultimately Firearms were found
uh and uh and seized there this was
early information that I of course
immediately passed along to the RCMP you
were managing the event okay we'll hear
from Deputy Commissioner zablocki about
that when he testified yeah absolutely
this visit any event if true as it
proved to be made it a very dangerous
situation and raised serious officer
safety and Public Safety risks oh if
yeah absolutely the presence of firearms
at any dispute if uh of this nature
could potentially be dangerous and as
any event that the police deal with on
February the 7th are you aware that
Archer Pulaski was arrested and charged
with offenses including Mischief over
five thousand dollars and interrupting
the operation of critical infrastructure
I am aware yes okay
uh could we go to um
alb401087 this is February the 9th
it's being reported up to you that a
sheriff's Alberta Sheriff sprayed two
protesters with that's pepper spray
that's great and that that's because two
protesters reportedly moved towards the
share of Sergeants and refused warnings
to stop correct
that's correct I do have a bit more
information that
was developed since that uh that initial
sort of uh heads up if you will
um it did appear that the
the the individuals
so I I better be careful because I don't
want to conflate two incidents okay well
so we'll leave it maybe not not then
it's really just the raw fact that this
is what's reporting to you is all about
that's correct yeah in terms of your
state of mind at the moment yeah I
apologize yeah that's probably the best
one thank you
and um
if you go to alb401307
if we go to the bottom email please this
is an email reporting in on protests
occurring that Friday night and over the
weekend at the Calgary remand Center
the very bottom police have paid for
okay scheduled protest at the Calgary
remand Center are you aware of those
protests in sympathy with Arthur
perlowski yeah it was that it was in
relation to Mr Pulaski and they ended up
continuing for seven straight days
that sounds right I don't have that
specific number in my could we go to the
institutional report alb.ir.701
and to page 18 please
okay this is indicating first of all um
if you go down the page we think we're
looking for um
uh the weekend of February 12 and 13.
maybe just keep keep going I may have
the page wrong
yeah please um please continue to go
there we go February 11 12 and 13.
um the city of Edmonton obtained an
injunction for the weekend of February
12 and 13 as a result of the prior
weekend's events yes
I'm not sure what their motivation was
but certainly in anticipation of the
events that they were seen being planned
from there they obtained an injunction
uh for for that weekend that's for sure
can you go to paragraph 80 on this page
you'll see there's reporting about 840
vehicles in Edmonton down from 3 000 the
weekend before but what I'm concerned
about here is at the end of the
paragraph 200 protesters from the
Liberty March moved towards the counter
protesters in an apparent attempt to
remove them right
yeah there was a counter protest that uh
evolved uh that was going to confront
the the protesters and stop them from
doing uh demonstrating and and doing
their their drive through uh there was
going to be a confrontation there in the
year I've been to Police Service reports
that they intervened and uh and
separated the parties and and allowed
for the uh the protest to carry on
and uh
um the risk of violence dramatically
escalates when you're dealing with a
counter protest situation if allowed to
come into physical contact with each
other it's much more difficult to keep
it peaceful
can we go to cou 702 this would be one
of the last exchange I want to go to
with respect to Mayor Willett who
testified yesterday and this is an
exchange with Bill graveland it'll be
page three please thank you and it is
dated as of February the 12th so two
weeks before the emergencies Act
I move down the page
all right you see there um mayor mayor
Willett says uh morning Bill and he
refers to uh you know you need to find
someone in a protected position to call
these guys what they are domestic
terrorists you see that
I do see that yes and Miss gravelin says
um uh honestly I had a number of run-ins
several years ago with the Freeman on
the land after an unpleasant exchange
with some of them at the saloon I
realize that's likely what they are
sorry you're going through this do you
see that I see that that's correct do
you know what Freeman on the land refers
to oh yeah I'm familiar with the term in
the movement it's been found I think by
associate chief justice rook and
described as a organized
a method of disrupting Court operations
and frustrating the legal rights of
governments corporations and individuals
yeah the the the tactic is organized
that's for sure yeah Justice Rooks uh
yeah deliberation is very accurate yeah
he is a very well-known decision that he
may be familiar with from 2012 on that
point that's correct needs and needs I
believe
uh I'll take your word for it that's
fine you can take my word for that yeah
could we go to pb.10.40 is one eight
three four
and sir I'll ask if we can go to um well
this is a decision issued one a week ago
today oh yes I associate chief justice
rook and if we could go to the last uh
uh page page 16 at paragraph 69 and 70.
thank you
I just want to point out to you for your
for your reaction that um uh the view of
associate chief justice Rook expressed
last week
in paragraph 70 is that
the litigation abuse he's describing
here is part of a broader pattern and
that the law in Alberta is not adequate
to control abusive litigants do you see
that
um paragraph 70 in the middle seven zero
okay yeah
yes I see that yes okay and that's a
well I won't ask you to comment on your
agreement with the court
um
could we go now to
um
February the 14th you understand that on
February 14th
the arrests occurred at Coots right
that's correct approximately uh
uh two o'clock P.M that day mountain
time I thought it was 2 A.M sir
okay so like into the evening of the
13th and then sorry
approximately seven o'clock A.M Mountain
Time Premier Kenny attended the first
ministers meeting which you referred to
earlier
okay
could we go to SAS five zeros120
these are the notes produced by the
government of Saskatchewan with respect
to the statements made at that meeting
of we've got only what is uh rehearsed
in the um institutional report from
Alberta so I just want to thank you if
we go down to the bottom of this page
where uh
um
there's notes with respect to Premier
Kenny's statements and you see the last
few lines there this is Jason Kenney
speaking from about uh that yeah his
name see that section yeah so just
looking at the the last comments that
are attributed I am here see it as a
very serious provocation could prove a
net negative
um
PJs can compel tow drivers please stop
the trucker vaccine mandate language
provocation don't quibble if necessary
okay do you have any awareness of what
was what what
um if I could just have one moment yes
you know kind of have a quickly uh read
through this
okay uh go ahead sir
and um if we can again go to
ssm.nsc.can 402941
and I'll um Mr commissioner I know I'm
right at the edge I'll probably be about
two or three minutes if that's
acceptable
yeah I don't think you're done oh so uh
on my account okay I I do appreciate
your honesty with the with uh this
I'll keep my mouth shut in the future
when I I guess run
apologies council could you please
repeat that doc ID
I have you having another five minutes
okay so you know all right
uh and so it's ssm.can another uh
let's just see another four minutes
sorry
uh ssm.nsc.ken.40-2941
and this is another set of notes
produced in from the um Mr Cloud they
testify in front of this commission yeah
thank you
um if you go to page 22
and I'm sorry these are sideways it's a
limitation of the it's okay
product I think you scroll down the page
there we go thank you you see on the
right hand side of Mr Cloud's notes
uh with respect to Mr Kenny statements
during the first ministers meeting let's
take a look at that for a moment
thank you oh yeah is that the luxury of
four minutes yeah no I understand yeah
please
go ahead
okay thank you so you see that others
have it here again this word quibble and
Mr Klaus written attributed to Mr Kenny
I don't quibble with the use of the ACT
but other ways to
reduce tensions do you see that
I see that yes and In fairness to you
you're not able to speak to whether or
not that's an accurate reflection of
what Premier Kenny said because you
weren't present Fair that's very fair
yeah
and um
this meeting occurs approximately well
some hours after the RCMP arrests are
made at Coots correct that's correct and
it occurs um
uh
in a context where and I'll just ask you
if you're aware there's approximately 2
000 Firearms uh we're missing having
been stolen in a trailer in Peterborough
Ontario which had not been recovered for
some days I'm not aware of that actually
fair enough wouldn't deal with another
evidence at any rate the ACT is invoked
at approximately 4 30 p.m Eastern
Standard Time
okay okay
um
you know just coming back briefly to
some of the content of the institutional
report if you could pull that up for
just a couple of last questions
alb.ir.701
to um page um
seven
paragraph 34.
I think there's a disjoint in the
numbering
uh you can't speak to and we're not
present for Premier Kennedy's calls with
Minister manuccino correct that's
correct in it we look at page eight
paragraph 38
you likewise I take it we're not present
for Minister mciver's call with Minister
Blair that's correct I'm relying on the
information that we provided with the
institutional report on both cases yes
and again that information is provided
is not provided under oath other than to
the extent that your affidavit says you
have heard it that's that's correct
and page nine then please um again it's
paragraph 43 and I take it I'll know the
same answer but
uh you were not present for
this further call between Premier Kenny
and Minister Mendocino
that's correct sir
and if we go to page three finally
paragraphs two and three
uh you see their um
it is it is stated or asserted that in
the end of paragraph two Alberta
received virtually no consultation from
Canada in its decision to invoke the
emergencies act as applicable to Alberta
and the entirety of the country fair
that's fair sir and that's really a
matter of um that's characterization I'm
sorry is that your characterization or
is that the the province's um position
that would be the provinces position and
certainly from my personal experience I
received no consultation or okay well
we've heard of areas where you were
engaged with Federal colleagues yeah uh
post that's correct sir uh paragraph
three um
uh
you uh say Canada at the end of the
paragraph Canada failed to provide any
assistance upon Alberta's request to
Simply borrow equipment from them and is
that how you would encapsulate that
dialogue that you're engaged in with
Transport Canada and others
yes sir I'm not sure that it would be
fair to say they didn't try I would
suggest though that we receive no
assistance
okay uh well we'll hear from others
about that thank you sir those are my
questions no thank you very much sir
hey thank you
um next I'd like to call on the Convoy
organizers
morning sir good morning good afternoon
how are you good afternoon all right I
had to check sorry sir my name is
Brendan Miller I'm counsel for Freedom
Corp which represents the protesters
that were in Ottawa only uh nobody at
Coots uh between January and February
pleased to meet you 2022. up so I just
want to Dive Right In so and I don't
want to ask for anything subject to
criminal code ceiling orders or things
and just based on what I know from the
public record about uh this group that
ended up being arrested at the Border in
Coots area with respect to the
conspiracy to commit murder and all of
that uh it's it's my understanding that
the RCMP undercover agents and this is
based on the public record uh were
involved uh with those that group from a
very early point is that fair
I think that I I wouldn't have that kind
of tactical level of information so I I
honestly don't have a knowledge of that
and you would probably be better ask
that of the Deputy Commissioner and I'm
not trying to avoid I just sincerely was
not briefed at that level of detail okay
was it your understanding that that
group their plot was to have two females
smuggle in in a hockey bag a whole bunch
of guns into the protest is that what
your understanding was I I have actually
no understanding of the undercover
operations or the intelligence gathering
operations of the RCMP the level of
detail that I was briefed at was really
of the existence of threats within
within the group that were potentially
more violent and that they had the
intelligence to indicate that they were
armed and planning to do violence in
relation to the police should the
enforcement action take place right but
are you after the fact aware that the
two females that they were intending to
have smuggle in these Firearms were
actually too Undercover RCMP officers I
I apologize I just have no detail in
terms of the actual criminal file or the
investigation itself to quite carefully
avoided uh that level of interaction
with the police and kept it at a higher
level to your knowledge before the
invocation of the emergencies Act
was this investigation and this
operation with respect to these
gentlemen who were arrested Coots for
conspiracy to commit murder was it ever
relayed to the Federal Executive
political branch that is cabinet are you
aware if that was before the invocation
was that information that there this
group was there relayed to the Federal
Executive yeah the Federal Executive
Branch in the sense of the political
branch of government with respect to
elected ministers yeah I wouldn't have
any knowledge of that that would be a
conversation probably at the federal
level of the RCMP and certainly not one
I was privy to or was briefed on thank
you and it's fair to say that uh with uh
Coots of course none of the provisions
under the emergencies act that were
invoked in the subsequent orders and
Council none of them were used in
respect to Coots were they that's
correct and to your knowledge none of
the protesters at Coots had any of their
accounts Frozen or anything like that
under the uh orders I I don't have any
knowledge of that I just I can't say
that it didn't happen I just don't know
that right now to your knowledge were
you uh aware of when the RCMP finally
mobilized their national uh public
enforcement units to go to Ottawa they
actually brought in other officers from
BC and other folks were you apprised of
when that happened there was a uh
similar to the article nine Provisions
that we spoke to earlier there was
another request for support to the
national uh response to the situation in
Ottawa and that came right after the
weekend so I want to say 15th 16th
somewhere in that range and I was aware
that the RCMP along with the Calgary
police in the oven to police were
providing officers to support the Ottawa
Police Service in their in in their
favorites and you agree with me that
that request it's it doesn't require the
emergencies act to be invoked this is a
thing that can be done and it could have
been done at any time between when the
protests started in Ottawa to when it
was asked right that's correct yeah and
for you at any time right and for
whatever reason the RCMP in Ottawa never
asked for all of these units which could
have easily been made available and sent
to Ottawa to assist with resources they
never asked for them before the 15th did
they
I was not aware of any requests at all
before that and you've watched some of
this hearing the biggest issue in Ottawa
was resources
and it was some of the evidence from uh
poor Chief slowly who had this Throne on
him that he was asking the RCMP for
resources and commissioner lucky said
that you've got what you've got
but at all times is it fair that
commissioner lucky could have asked made
a request like that was made on the 15th
and asked for these officers to come to
Ottawa to assist him the provisions of
the police services agreement remain in
place to this day and have been since
2012 when we signed the agreement so
they could have been asked for
I won't speculate as to what our
response would have been yeah thank you
thank you
foreign
jccf and
yes
all right
good morning sir my name is Alan honner
I am a lawyer from the Democracy fund
good morning and pleased to meet you and
pardon me it's good afternoon as uh oh
yes my friend just pointed out
can we please pull up
alb.40s 383
1.0001
just while we're waiting for that to
come up you were asked about a former
Premier Jason Kennedy or Kenny earlier
today
and when the document comes up I think
what it'll show is a letter dated
February 15 2022 from the prime minister
to then Premier Jason Kenney
have you seen this document before
if I could scroll through it a tiny bit
more or maybe reduce the
oh yes please just uh direct the
registrar yeah sorry if we could maybe
just
sorry uh
thank you just
yeah I believe I've
examined this document
thank you so if we can just look at the
I have
if we can just look at the first
paragraph on the second page it's before
us right now uh we see the Prime
Minister saying that we are facing
significant economic disruptions with a
breakdown of Supply chains this is
costing Canadians their jobs and
undermining our economic and National
Security with potential significant
impacts
on the health and safety of Canadians
did Premier uh former Premier Jason
Kenney or anyone else ever tell you
anyone else from the government ever
explained to you what the Prime Minister
meant by this reference to potential
significant impacts on the health and
safety of Canadians
I'm not familiar with any explanation of
the prime minister's thoughts behind
that from anyone
okay thank you can we please pull up ALB
four zeros one five one seven dot zero
zero zero one
and excuse me for just a moment please
my sincere apologies that I just had a
slight domestic I don't believe there we
go
can we have your audio announcers go
ahead
okay thank you so I earlier you told us
that Alberta had formally requested
assistance from the federal government
but did not receive any formal response
um and eventually this is in respect to
tow trucks and eventually Alberta just
obtained its own equipment
that's correct so we're we're looking at
an email here from Peter Lemieux you and
others about equipment Alberta a picture
to support the RCMP operation at Coots
okay
and who is Peter Lemieux Peter Lemieux
is the acting executive director of the
provincial security and intelligence
office and during this time he was the
individual who I tasked as the lead in
the procurement of the that equipment
okay and this equipment was procured on
February 13 2022. it was a it was
procured over a a couple of days uh and
I think ultimately all of it was in
place by the
14th or 15th I think 14th but
well if you if you just scroll down a
little bit
um it says here
um yeah on February 13 2022 government
developer to procured the following
equipment yeah I I saw that in the note
uh from uh from Peter earlier uh I think
a better term for on February 13th Would
have been by February 13th uh we had
actually acquired a small amount of that
equipment earlier uh than that and the
last of it was procured and then it was
all in place I believe on the 14th down
south in
Genesis is this list of equipment
reflective of the equipment that the
RCMP needed
save two specialty Vehicles this was the
exact uh equipment that we were told
that by the RCMP that they required if
they were to have to execute an
enforcement plan and Tow all of vehicles
at the at the border crossing and what
were those other two vehicles that are
not listed here sure there are some
other documents that speak to them but
one is a a tire service truck and a
number of tires and the other is a heavy
duty mechanics truck with tools
okay thank you and if we can just pull
up a pb.can.401514
we saw this uh document earlier today uh
just while we're waiting for it to be
pulled up it is uh an email to Rob
Stewart
thank you
recall seeing this email correct if we
can just scroll down a little bit
yeah I've seen this earlier today that's
correct okay and if we can just scroll
down a little bit more to to the to
where it says Alberta
so um under the heading Alberta it says
that the biggest operational challenge
to date is procuring Towing the wrecking
equipment and skilled workers to operate
the equipment
that's correct
um by this point uh you had most of that
equipment at least could we scroll to
the top again so I could confirm the
date yeah of course this if if I
remember correctly this is a review of a
conversation that we had take had uh
earlier on in the day on the 13th uh
that being the conversation with myself
uh
admob talal and uh the public
Works Government Services representative
I can't recall who was there on that
call and at that point in time we were
in the process of procuring
um
the equipment that we ultimately
later on by the 13th by the end of the
day we had actually procured so when you
see the reference from Peter Lemieux by
the 13th we had it
the information that Mr that talal in
this message was referencing came from a
a point in time prior to us having
finalized the uh the the purchase of the
last of the equipment so we were still
looking for trucks when he and I had a
conversation and his
his reference his reference to our
conversation it contained in this email
to uh Rob Stewart is based on that sort
of time dated information that we were
still looking for it
right so that explains why that uh the
information in in the document we're
looking at isn't completely Uh current
yeah they're temporal in terms of the
the course of the day uh yeah they're
relying on information that was provided
at the start of the day whereas the
Peter Lemieux document references what
we had by the end
of course and and by that that point on
February 13th you had no idea that the
federal government was about to invoke
the emergencies act that's correct sir
thank you if we can just pull up
document alb.40s
1376
.0001
and what we're looking at here is an
email from Daniel Levy or laville I'm
not sure how to pronounce his name I'm
sorry about that but it's to you and
some other people
yes thank you
um and I think it's actually uh it's
being forwarded to you and it's dated
February 15 2022. that's correct uh Dan
laville is uh was the communications
director for our ministry at the time
and uh was forwarding to me uh a copy of
an Alberta RCMP news release
okay and that RC our CMP news release
said that uh there were four people
charged with conspiracy to commit murder
and they're listed here right yeah
that's what it says yes and and I
appreciate you have limited information
about this and we appreciate that these
are allegations
um but can you tell us or do you have
any idea who these people were allegedly
conspiring to murder
I I I can't speak with certainty because
of course I wasn't
part of the investigation but it was my
understanding it was police
but that is uh
that would be third party or speculative
on my part and I would want that to come
out in evidence at court
okay thank you well I I I'm not going to
ask you to speculate if we look um a
little bit uh
if we look down this list we see that
there are nine other people they are
charged with um
mischief and possession of weapons for a
dangerous person
dangerous purpose that's correct okay so
13 people were charged in total at the
time can we yes and can we look at
um
alb.ir701 this is the Alberta
institutional report okay
thank you and if we just go to a page
eight paragraph 25
okay thank you very much
um so this paragraph describes how the
RCMP executed a warrant on three
trailers uh leading to the rest of uh 13
individuals that's correct and and those
are are clearly the same 13 individuals
we just discussed yeah that's that's the
reference yes that's correct sure and it
says here that the warrant was executed
Before Dawn
do you happen to know if it was executed
before the first Minister's meeting
which took place on February the 14th
now I have to be careful in caveat my
response in the sense of my
understanding of the first meters
meeting is that it was as articulated by
uh Council for government of Canada
somewhere around 7 or 7 30 in the
morning it was not party to that event
if the timing was a as indicated by uh
Council then it would have been before
because my conversation with the Deputy
Commissioner indicated was in the early
morning hours to 30 or so in the morning
that the the uh the rest took place
oh I see okay thank you and earlier in
in your evidence you mentioned at the
hour of 7 30 a.m that's when you found
out about the warrant being being
executed right yeah see that was me
having a conversation with the Deputy
Commissioner uh that's correct got it
right and then and 7 30 is a rough
estimate uh I I probably could go back
on my phone and try and find the the
call but it was before normal business
hours
it's okay I just want to make sure I
understood
um if we look down to paragraph 27 of
the institutional report
um It also says that the emergencies Act
was
um announced on the afternoon of
February 14th and uh based on your
evidence and and on the report that was
well after the RCMP successfully
completed the seizure and arrests of
these uh three uh 13 people and and the
defense related property that's correct
sir
okay
and uh you didn't have any other
information about threats at the time
just the intelligence I was receiving
from the Deputy Commissioner around the
fact that there was a a volatile
presence within the the group that they
were examining and they proved a threat
or a risk uh it was very generic or at
that high level the types of
conversations that I had with uh with
the Deputy Commissioner
the Deputy Commissioner of the RCMP of
course that's correct yeah Deputy
Commissioners are blocking so nothing
specific time just yes so if you could
wrap up pretty soon I think you're out
of time
if I can have a 30 more seconds
commissioner absolutely
thank you so
um
just one one last Point uh you were
shown on uh a video of Arthur pavlowski
and
um am I correct in understanding or can
you confirm that he was arrested for
giving that speech and he was arrested
on February 8 2022. he was arrested by
the RCMP and I know was tied to his
actions down at the blockade I would
probably want to defer to them as to the
rationale specifically around what uh
what led or whatever evidence they have
that led them to to cause them to arrest
them and charge him
okay fair enough but he was arrested on
February the 8th and he was held for
bail and he was denied for bail he was
denied bail on February 16 2022 uh by a
judge from the provincial court of
justice would you agree with that
I can't disagree with it sounds right I
just don't have the dates in front of me
so yeah it sounds right okay thank you
very much those are my questions
okay next I could call on the Ottawa
Coalition of thanks for residents and
businesses
no questions thank you
okay next on the Windsor uh Police
Service
so I apologize uh no questions for Tom
McRae for Windsor Police Service okay
next is the government of Saskatchewan
uh good morning sir it's Mike Morris
counsel for the government to
Saskatchewan I'm saying good morning
because it's still morning here and I
think your internal clocks probably
still set to Alberta time good morning
pleased to meet you
I just have a few questions for you
um sir I understand that in February of
this year you represented Alberta on the
fpt crime prevention and policing
committee is that correct at the ADM
level that's correct sir
okay and that would be a committee which
is composed of officials from the
federal provincial and territorial
governments correct that's correct sir
and as such that committee would include
representatives from the government of
Saskatchewan then correct that is
correct sir
my understanding is that the committee
met several times before the public
order emergency was proclaimed on
February 14th is that correct that's
correct sir
and my review of the material indicates
that the committee met on February 1st
February 7th and February 11th does that
Accord with your understanding that
sounds ex very correct sir thank you
and did you attend the meetings on the
first 7th and 11th I did although I
believe on the seventh it was Deputy
Minister presence as well in the
associate Deputy minister of Dennis
Cooley was there with me
at any of those meetings did federal
officials indicate that the government
was considering invoking the emergencies
Act
no
in your view would the committee have
been an appropriate Forum to discuss
whether it was advisable for the federal
emergencies act to be invoked
I I think it would have been a very good
initial Forum to have initial
conversations certainly consultation as
I understand it to be envisioned would
be required at a much higher level but
certainly that would have been a very
good starting point for that
but in the end you never had the
opportunity to have those consultations
then correct oh that that's correct sir
and just a couple more uh in your
experience with these fpt meetings can
they be convened on very short notice
uh yes they can
when required
and would that even include on weekends
point of fact it did later but yes
thank you very much sir those are my
questions for you
thank you
thank you next uh call on the government
of Alberta
good afternoon Mr Durand good afternoon
commissioner
um
my friends have covered quite a lot of
ground with you there's just a few areas
I want to cover off and one of those
areas deals with the timing of the
execution of search warrants and arrests
in Coots Alberta I'll ask if the clerk
can please turn to ALB
four
zeros1522 thank you
and this is an email dated early in the
morning 6 36 in the morning of February
14th from John Ferguson to Dwayne
Lacosta and to you do you know who John
Ferguson is
yes uh John Ferguson uh is and was at
that time the assistant commissioner in
charge of uh contract operations for the
province of Alberta with the RCMP and as
far as you're aware he was involved in
the law enforcement of the protesting
good very much so yeah okay and if we
look at this email we'll see some events
noted at approximately 23.50 hours
pursuant to the above activity which is
described in the paragraph above two
suspects who are part of the core
protesters group and have been
identified as part of the security cell
were arrested now I take this to be on
February 13th do you understand that to
be the case as well yeah I believe
the 2357 would have been on the 13th and
then subsequent arrests after that after
midnight were on the phone and so then
looking at the timing of those arrests
we go down to the next paragraph on
Monday February 14th at approximately
0100 hours other key protesters within
the security cell were also arrested
and then a search warrant was already
executed at the saloon the main beating
place for the security cell was negative
for weapons and then again a further
paragraph down at approximately oh 300
hours search warrants were executed at
the residence and Coots and the
associated trailer so all of these
events um involving the arrests and
execution of search warrants at Coots
were occurring late on February 13th and
very early on the morning of the 14th
basically right at midnight and then the
early morning hours of the 14th thank
you
foreign
ALB I believe it's four zeros one five
seven three
and this is the letter from Deputy
Commissioners blocking on February 3rd
to active Minister Sonia Savage for the
oh my apologies it's from um
Minister Savage to Deputy Commissioner
zablocki that's great
now the last sentence of that first
paragraph reads in my opinion this
constitutes an emergency in the province
of Alberta under the Provincial Police
service agreement
now the Provincial Police service
agreement is included as a document
referenced in Alberta's institutional
report before this commission I take it
you're quite familiar with that we could
try and slow down a bit for the
translators please for sure I'll take it
you're quite familiar with that
agreement I am yeah
is there a definition of the word
emergency in that agreement
actually have a copy of it with me but I
don't uh have it readily available and I
I can't recall you can't recall okay
yeah
it is in our institutional report as
well right yeah take it that you're
understanding is that the definition
um of the word emergency as contemplated
under the Provincial Police service
agreement yeah is different from the
word emergency under either the federal
emergencies act or provincial Emergency
Management act absolutely and the
contemplation under the Provincial
Police Services agreement is around uh
resources and and the ability to Marshal
sufficient resources to manage
uh
extraordinary situations uh whether they
be in this case protests but it could be
fires floods or major events such as a
G8 or a G20 and the security events that
come around that so it is very different
than uh an emergency is would be
entailed under say the Alberta emergency
act or the Federal Emergency act and you
use that word extraordinary which is a
word that was also used in the letter
from Deputy Commissioners a blocky to
minister Savage asking for the
deployment of RCMP officers under
Section 9.1
so the best of your knowledge was this
the first time article 9.1 had been used
in Alberta for the deployment of RCMP
officers no no not at all what other
types of circumstances has that occurred
before I believe we had that invoked
during the fire response in Fort
McMurray we brought in officers from
Newfoundland BC Saskatchewan to support
the provincial operations I believe it's
been used in the past for uh
jail strikes and other natural disasters
as well it's been used for uh
GH G20 deployments across the country
Olympics
Etc okay thank you
and also in Alberta's institutional
report there's a mention of other
protest activity that occurred in other
parts of Alberta during January and
February 2022 and you've discussed that
to stem length with with my friends
already what was Alberta's role with
respect to other protest activity that
was happening in the province
so with the exception of protests around
the legislature itself
operational response is solely with the
police services of jurisdiction and we
provide support through our uh Sheriff's
Branch when requested and as needed our
role is around coordination and
intelligence sharing and monitoring
providing advice to government and
ensuring that
to the best of our ability every law
enforcement agency is is connected with
each other and with ourselves and not
caught out unawares with any
intelligence that might exist
in any one of the law enforcement
entities in the province and you
mentioned with exception to protest
activity was taking the place around the
legislature why is that the sheriff's
branch of my division is a specific task
around Security on the legislative
Precinct in in the province and work
very closely with the uh Edmonton Police
Service on that but they're charged with
sort of the Direct Security on the ledge
itself and so any protests involving
activity whether they be dismounted or
foot activity on the on the legislature
and on the roadways within the precinct
uh are primarily managed through the
Sheriff's branch
until such point in time as it becomes
clear that the protest is going to be
non-peaceful or unlawful and then the
Edmonton Police comes in and assumes
responsibility while our officers
continue to work with them but we do
have a much more robust
participation in matters on the
legislative Precinct
did you become aware of any incident
involving these protests at the
legislature grounds in January and
February that the sheriff's Branch was
not able to handle
not that the sheriff's Branch with the
assistance of the EPS could not handle
they were all managed to quite uh I
think uh appropriately okay and one
final um record to to take you to
um that's ALB
sorry four zeros2402
is that a multimedia file Council I
don't believe so no no it shouldn't be
ALB
s in 2402
2042 ah thank you
this is an executive notification
developing situation the Alberta
legislature Freedom Convoy February 26
2022.
now February 26 2022 was after the
Declaration of a public order emergency
under the emergencies Act was revoked
were you aware that at this time there
were further further protests that were
occurring in and around Alberta oh
absolutely there were continued protests
in Calgary specifically in Edmonton did
any police agency Express to Alberta
that they required anything beyond their
standard policing powers to deal with
any of these protest post-emergencies
act revocation
no okay thank you Mr de Grant those are
all my questions today thank you
thank you uh any uh re-examination
to uh very brief points thank you Mr
commissioner jeans for the commission
um
first I just want to make sure the
record is clear on a point raised by my
friends for the the Convoy organizers if
we could pull up the institutional
report ALB
dot ir at Dot 70s1 and go to page 30.
at paragraph 138 you'll recall my friend
was asking you about the provision of
provincial RCMP resources to
um to the response in Ottawa you
remember that I I do sure thank you and
I think you mentioned it was on the 16th
you weren't terribly sure about the date
if you could the first sentence here of
paragraph 138 says on February 18th
commissioner Brenda Luckey of the rcnp
requests about Alberta provide 42
officers to support efforts in Ottawa is
that the request you were referring to
that's the request I think I might have
even said 15th in my earlier evidence
and I apologize it's the 18th thank you
um the only thing I other thing I wanted
to ask you my friend I believe for the
jccf
um
was talking to you about that list of of
resources
um that you had acquired on February
13th you remember that yes I do by the
end of February 13th and and the point I
want to make sure that we understood uh
I believe you had a meeting with the
federal officials on the 13th
um
at are you aware whether or not
the the fact that those Vehicles had
been obtained on the 13th uh was was
made known to Federal officials so and I
was probably clumsy in my earlier uh
explanation so I'll try to to clarify
that at the time of my earlier
conversation with the federal officials
to ADM Brasa and others Russo and others
we had not yet acquired the the bulk of
the equipment we had at a small number
that we had Acquired and already shipped
down we were in
Midstream of acquiring some and it fell
apart the day before and we were in
Midstream that day of acquiring some but
we still hadn't secured them yet so at
the time of my conversation with ediam
Brussel and the our ADM uh tell all
Bob and I apologize to all I know him
but I hope I'm not recognition but at
the time of that conversation
um we hadn't yet acquired them
the reference in Peter Lemieux document
was sometime down the road stating that
by the end by the 18th we had acquired
or the 13th Would acquired them because
later on that afternoon
are later on that day he his team was
able to secure the purchase of the
remainder of the vehicles so that's why
at the time of our conversation with the
federal officials we hadn't secured them
yet and we were still seeking them later
that day we acquired them and host that
date the indication from Mr lemuse by
the 13th we'd acquired them because by
the end of that day we had and and do
you know uh whether
and when the federal officials would
have been advised that that list
resources had been acquired yeah um
I don't know honestly from the from
memory I don't recall uh when we had
that conversation I apologize I should
have that off the top way and I don't
thank you those are all my questions
okay thank you uh just on that I have a
couple of questions just from on those
uh the equipment you acquired and I may
have missed it in my notes
did you had you uh arranged or secured
The Operators for all that equipment I I
didn't I didn't get to know that was a
concern yeah we'd actually uh sir we'd
actually acquired a number of operators
that could move vehicles around we'd
acquired a number of operators like a
small number that could actually operate
tow trucks and heavy lift equipment so
we had a small component of folks that
could do that we also had made
connection with a private sector
individual who is going to provide us
with not with limited operators but also
training for any staff that we might
have to operate those vehicles uh the
the lift part of the vehicles we've got
a number of operators that could drive
them and and and and work them but
actually operating the the tow capacity
itself was something we needed some
trading on so we had that started but we
were still looking for uh for more to
augment that to that would have
facilitated a much better operational
response rather than the limited number
that we had at the time
so that that was a bit still a work in
progress that you had you had
good plan you had started and working it
out
that's correct sir okay and another
question uh just going back to uh the uh
9.1 request that was made on February
3rd
uh for that's the request for to move
additional officers to Alberta and that
was granted we saw that letter this was
her
how when was that terminated or how does
it when did it end do you know uh the
officers in question that came from
British Columbia were 40 in number and
they as I recall uh returned to British
Columbia at the end of that weekend of
the 13th 14th uh they they were released
back to British Columbia there would
have still been officers within uh
Alberta probably primarily for municipal
and perhaps Federal Business lines that
would have still been augmenting and I
would actually have to defer to uh the
uh the Deputy Commissioner on when he
was able to release them back to their
business lines and just rely exclusively
on the provincial officers I just don't
know when that was but there's no formal
rescinding of of that letter so it it
was not formally rescinded but your
understanding as they went back about
13th or 14th would that be after the
operation in would that make sense to
you it would make sense to me but I
would want to defer to deputies zablocki
for the specifics around when they were
released and then you were taken to the
request by Ottawa uh or to to move uh
officers to Ottawa so would it be fair
to say that
when you were requesting
officers from British Columbia
you would hesitate to send officers to
Ottawa or as those two separate uh
totally distinct or would you weigh that
well at the time of that request on the
18th we actually did release uh sorry if
that's what you're asking no I'm asking
if before the fourth oh in other words
you were asked is there any reason you
wouldn't have sent officers earlier and
I'm just asking and if I may be wrong
but yeah it seems common sense to me
yeah no it's a it's a very very much a
common sense question and what what
happened is what did happen on the 18th
it would have happened on the 14th I
would have looked to deputies of Blocky
uh to ask him
what is the nature of the request in
this case it wasn't for just general
numbers it was for specialty officers on
the uh what they call a Specialists
still officers a special operation
officers certain special needs so I
would have asked the question could you
realistically release those given what
you're dealing with in the province and
I would be guided by his advice on that
I would have been surprised had he said
he could
but there are other provinces in the
maritimes ETC that he could have they
could have pulled from okay
um and then you talked about the
critical infrastructure Defense Act
um and I'm trying to understand a bit uh
that's a pretty gives a lot of broad
power as I understand it is that fair
yeah it's a broad application in the
sense that if a certain activity takes
place on any
piece of critical infrastructure is
defined under the act it allows for
enforcement by police with specific
penalties that are quite substantial and
it doesn't have to be invoked it just no
it's yeah it's just standing legislation
and then
this may be the last time just going
through my notes I apologize uh
that you mentioned something about and I
think it was maybe February 13th but I'm
not sure a request for reverse
reservists uh to be uh to be used I
think to operate equipment did you ever
get an answer on that yeah in the
February 13th reference was the
conversation I had with uh the ADM and
Public Safety Canada and other Federal
officials were I raised them
by surprise that we did have an answer
back that was indicating that and this
is an earlier request from earlier in
the week uh where the Canadian Forces
indicated that they would not allow
their reservists to participate in
support of our uh operations in the
manner that we'd asked so we'd already
had that answer and I was expressing to
the adm's uh my surprise uh that at
least that level of support couldn't be
approved and maybe I've got it wrong but
I I thought in that note
uh there was a suggestion that he would
look into it yeah um my question whether
after looking into it anything further
came
yeah he did indicate that he was not
aware of the request he would look into
it and I did not hear back from uh it
was a busy time for him though I
understand okay because it was the the
looking into it that I didn't know
whether we see no feedback after that
sir okay
okay well those are my
questions thank you very much for
attending and uh I understand you're
going back to the cold but
not much we can do about that I am
indeed thank you sir it's been a
pleasure thank you you're free to go
so uh we will have a long lunch today uh
an hour and three minutes
um so we'll be back at two o'clock
and uh continue with yesterday's Witness
thank you sorry the commission is in
races until two o'clock the commercials
are
order alert
the commission is very convenient
good afternoon commissioner Natalia
Rodriguez senior commission counsel and
the commissioner the commission would
like to call again Mr Di Tomaso
foreign
you've been sworn in so I don't believe
you'll have to do that again you're
under oath as you were yesterday thank
you and I'm Natalia Rodriguez as I said
I'm taking over from my colleague Mr
pollikan who is examining you yesterday
and I'm going to continue where he left
off
[Applause]
uh so uh
he took you to your notes and I will
take you to your notes as well ont405153
and it's at page two
and you'll recall these were your notes
from a call that you had with a deputy
minister of Public Safety Rob Stewart on
February 3rd do you recall that yes
and uh yesterday my colleague took you
to some text messages with uh
commissioner Creek in which you kind of
agreed that the tenor of those text
messages was essentially that things
seem to be under control do you recall
that I do okay so now looking at these
notes again this is a call with Deputy
Minister Rob Stewart and these are the
notes you took from your discussion you
wrote 300 500
oh 500 okay excuse me 500 CMV in Ottawa
and that is commercial Motor Vehicles
yes
3 000 people uh noise in all caps there
uh verbally assault
does that say RCMP or people people
people
uh no outbreaks of violence political
are very exposed stalemate
nobody really in charge some who claim
to be
far-right extremism
and if we go down not going to be able
to move once they are there
or they are here rather
how do they leave
change in policy or de-escalation
create incentives for them to leave
city has stated
to and has started to enforce bylaws
get right on it as soon as they get here
um
did that Accord with the tenor of the
types of information and the discussion
that you were having with commissioner
Creek in terms of the
um public safety issues or what was
happening on the ground it did okay
and so did you feel that you were
getting similar messaging from both
commissioner Creek and from the deputy
minister in this case I did
after speaking to Deputy Minister Stuart
did you have any public safety concerns
about the situation in Ottawa
and not at that time I was getting
consistent messaging from commissioner
Creek and from Deputy Minister Stewart
that there were not any overriding
public safety concerns in other words
from my perspective what we did not see
as any uh serious violence taking place
at that point in time so no murders
shootings robbery stabbings
aggravated assaults nothing of that sort
so from my perspective no overriding
public safety concerns at that point in
time right in terms of physical violence
right so Public Safety can mean more
than physical violence you would agree
with exactly right yes so were there
other public safety concerns aside from
as you say criminal code violations
murders assaults that type of thing yes
absolutely this um this protest was
having significant impact on
um Ottawa residents and we've heard it
described before by various uh
witnesses that it was having a
significant impact on the mental health
and well-being of the community and
completely accept that
uh did it rise to the level of a public
safety concern
no okay
and
um did the tenor of your briefings from
commissioner Creek change over the
course of the protest did at some point
did it become different in tone in terms
of the public safety risk and the the
issues that were that were arising
uh not so much in terms of Public Safety
risks but the longer that this protest
went on the greater the concern was it
needed to be brought to an end and so
everybody certainly recognized the
urgency of the situation right
um now on February 2nd I understand from
Chief slowly's witness summary that you
spoke to him
um and he then requested to speak to the
solicitor general do you recall that I
do okay and now in his witness statement
he said that you were looking for
verification on a report that ambulances
were being denied access to Ottawa
hospitals do you recall that I do um
there was a concern with regards to
um emergency routes that provided access
to various hospitals and that was
communicated to me and I just wanted to
confirm with um
achieve slowly whether or not that was
true and if it was what was being done
about it right and he told you that that
was not the case right correct and would
that have been a public safety concern
if if in fact ambulances were not able
to get to hospitals yes
and why were you looking specifically
for that information why was that
important to you
um I had had a meeting earlier on in the
morning I believe
with the secretary of cabinet and other
Deputy ministers unrelated to this issue
and the matter came up from the deputy
minister of health and so I committed to
looking into the matter
and so uh independent from that would
that have been a concern for you in
terms of your role with respect to
Public Safety in Ontario if that had not
been raised to you by the minister of
Deputy minister of Health yes okay
um
in his summary Chief slowly also said
that in that call with you he asked you
if you were aware of the public safety
implications at the freedom Convoy
situation in Ottawa posed to the rest of
Ontario
do you recall him saying that
I'd have to check my notes I'm sorry
okay
um do you recall him
telling you that there were some Public
Safety implications uh to the rest of
Ontario with respect to what was
happening in Ottawa
once again I'd have to check my my notes
but I was certainly alive to the issue
okay
and was this the only call you had with
former Chief slowly during these events
like a one-on-one discussion with him
you know there were other calls okay
now it looks like during this call he
indicated that he wanted to speak to the
solicitor general and it looks like he
did
um manage to speak with her on February
2nd were you on that call
I was not but I arranged that call okay
and did you prepare the solicitor
general for that call did you brief her
ahead of time
uh the only um the only information I
provided to minister Jones was that
Chief slowly was interested in speaking
to her with regards to the freedom
Convoy okay and are you aware of what
was discussed on this call
I was not debriefed no okay
now on February 2nd former Chief slowly
said that there may not be a policing
solution to this demonstration do you
recall hearing that at the time I do
and uh what was the reaction within the
government of Ontario to this statement
if any was there any concerns or
questions raised as a result of of this
statement
I I did not have um conversations about
this issue with um any of my superiors
with Minister Jones or the secretary or
the premier but I certainly felt that
there was in fact a policing solution to
the problem it was a policing matter and
I thought that the the police services
within this province would be in a
position to address the uh the Convoy
did this statement affect the provincial
response in any way
no I was very confident that
commissioner Creek was providing all
resources that were requested by Ottawa
on an ongoing basis
okay thank you so I want to take you now
to your notes again ont405153
and if we can go to page five this is a
call you had with commissioner Creek on
February 3rd
and it's at 1710. there it is
um
so
commissioner Creek says no Pou what did
you take that to mean
um that there were insufficient Pou
resources available
and then if we look down it says Chiefs
very concerned about slowly as is our
CMP
still haven't pulled together his plan
federal government expressing his
concerns
about his ability to lead
so you're hearing at this in this call
that there are some concerns with
respect to Chief slowly's ability to
lead as as indicated in these notes
correct this is what was being
communicated to me yes and who and who
was and commissioner Creek was was
communicating that to you yes and was
this the first time you were hearing
that there were concerns at the RCMP
level and with respect to commissioner
Creek about Chief slowly yes
did you relay uh this discussion to the
solicitor general let her know that
the opp and the RCMP have concerns
to the best of my knowledge I did yes
and do you know what her response to
that was
I do not
now
what is available to you what can you do
if uh you know the two commissioners of
Ontario and the opp and the RCMP have
lost confidence as is what it seems like
in in one of their uh when a local chief
of police is there anything in your
toolbox to be able to respond to that
um no not really
um and what I mean by that is that the
entity that is best placed
to deal with
um the performance of a chief of police
is the Police Service Board of
jurisdiction that is the best entity if
for example
um there was a concern that a police
Service Board was not providing adequate
and effective Police Services there is a
provision in the act for the solicitor
general to act and ask ocpc the Ontario
civilian police commission to start an
investigation under section 25 of the
police services Act and to your
knowledge was that ever considered in
this case
it was not a viable option
why
from my experience
um the solicitor general would have to
write to ocpc at a point in time where
she is satisfied that adequate and
effective Police Services were not being
provided by the board
um and then the ocpc would have
um discretion to either accept
or not the request of the solicitor
general
and from my experience ocpc would take
an extraordinarily long period of time
to act and I say that because Minister
Jones has written to ocpc in the past on
three separate occasions during my
tenure to ask ocpc to step in
and in each of those cases ocpc
took a long time in my view to act
because of their legislative obligations
and duties
and so this was an urgent situation and
from my perspective The Entity that was
best placed to
deal with the performance of Chief
slowly was the local police Service
Board of jurisdiction
and if the local police Service Board of
jurisdiction does not take steps and it
appears that perhaps adequate policing
is not being effectively carried out in
in an area why wouldn't the solicitor
general then exercise whatever Authority
he or she can in this case she to to do
something when it looks like other
entities are not acting
but something was being done
the Ottawa Police Service was supporting
was being supported by the very capable
leadership of the RCMP and the opp and
the provision of policing resources I
certainly had not lost confidence in the
Ottawa Police Service they were being
supported ably and capably by that
leadership they were being given the
resources that they requested
and so if the the commissioner of the
opp and the commissioner of the RCMP
have lost confidence uh in in the chief
are they not best positioned to make
that determination commissioner
Rebecca Jones for chief slowly that that
was not the evidence of the commissioner
the commissioner very clearly indicated
he had not lost confidence in the chief
of police and that is not what the note
says as well so we do object to the line
of questioning involving an
interpretation of a note which is not
consistent with the evidence
so to rephrase the question
if it were the case that the opp and the
RCMP had lost confidence in a chief of
police would it be appropriate then for
the solicitor general to recommend to
the ocpc to uh to step in
the entire issue is the provision of
adequate and effective Police Services
not a loss of confidence that's the
issue
and and from my perspective The Entity
best placed
to deal with that issue is the local
police Service uh Board of jurisdiction
within the police services act there are
only two two entities that are tasked
and required to provide adequate and
effective Police Services the first one
is the municipality with regards to
funding the second entity is the local
police Service Board of jurisdiction
so there was no so so if I understand
what you're saying there's no role here
for the solicitor general if adequate
and effective policing is not uh being
carried out
there is a rule but only after it's been
proven that adequate and effective
police services are not being provided
and from my perspective
Ottawa Police Service
with the support of the RCMP with the
support of the opp with the provision of
all resources that were being given to
it with all that support I had
confidence in the Ottawa Police Service
okay and if we go a little bit down in
the notes
where the star is
Windsor in Ambassador Bridge
is this with respect to a possible
blockade at The Ambassador Bridge in
Windsor yes and was this the first time
you were hearing that there was a
possible issue at The Ambassador Bridge
I I believe so yes
and if we go to page six
at the bottom of the page
keep going down
yeah where it says containment
negotiation preserve life slash Public
Safety protect critical infrastructure
were these now I'm trying to understand
whether this was still within the
context of your discussion with
commissioner Creek and whether these
were priorities of the opp that were
communicated to you or whether this was
your notes to yourself indicating what
you thought the priorities were
priorities of the opp has communicated
to me by commissioner Creek thank you
and then at the bottom it says
Flashpoint can you explain that notation
there
I I can't I'm sorry I don't remember
what that reference was all about
okay so I'll take you now to uh
ont404063
and I understand on February 3rd the
Ottawa Police Service requested
assistance from the ministry of the
solicitor general regarding the Urgent
appointment of members of the rcmps
special constables were you aware of
this at the time yes and under
um section 53 of the police services act
the only role that the solicitor general
has is to Simply approve the request of
a local police service board or the opp
commissioner depending on the situation
that Authority has been delegated down
to the Public Safety Division and in
particular to the director at the
external relations Branch I was aware of
the request and I certainly communicated
to my people in that section that we
would move Heaven and Earth to make sure
that Ottawa got all of the resources
they needed with regards to Expediting
the approval and is this um is this
approval kind of administrative done on
paper type thing yes okay so is it fair
to say it's a bit of a formality you
sign a paper and then it's done correct
and if I can take you now to ont405252
and these are text messages uh you
exchange with commissioner Creek
and this is uh February 4th
I believe
and
um it says there I and I believe
um
commissioner Creek is in the white and
you're in the green is that correct yes
and so in the white there it says I
spoke with commissioner lucky Chief
slowly and chief Ramer last night and
and that's the former Chief of uh the
Toronto uh police service is that right
he's still the chief okay oh I thought
somebody else had been appointed my
mistake
um Okay so
it says there all have access to the
necessary OPP resources so what did you
understand to be the status of the
provincial resources in Ottawa on
February 4th that all requests for
resources were being maintained and
addressed by the OPP
and so
the implication here is that the Ops has
all of the opp officers that it needs or
that it has requested right
correct
okay
um thank you we can take that down
now on February 4th there were also
protests in Toronto
specifically around Queens Park you are
aware of those crash
and my understanding is that those
protests wrapped up fairly quickly is
that your understanding as well
um yes
and so maybe you can shed sunlight at
least from your perspective of what was
done what was what worked in Toronto
what was done right in Toronto uh that
wasn't done in Ottawa what was the
difference here
so I think I think Toronto certainly
learned some valuable lessons from the
experience that the Ottawa Police
Service had just gone through the
previous weekend and so what from my
understanding what Toronto did was they
set up a hard perimeter around the
critical infrastructure that the
protesters were most interested in can
you try and slow down a bit again I'm
sorry to interrupt but it's the
interpreters I apologize sir
so what Toronto did was they set up a
hard perimeter around the critical
infrastructure that the protesters were
most interested in namely Queen's Park
and they they requested um
resources from other police services to
help them do that at the end of the day
they denied access to Queen's Park
Queens Park Circle
Hospital access roads um University
Avenue down to hospital role so all of
that was denied to
um
to the the convoys that were coming to
Toronto so the trucks Vehicles were not
permitted into that area they certainly
facilitated the ability to exercise
one's fundamental rights to lawful
protest those truckers were available to
come to Queen's Park and protest on foot
because as we know the right to protest
belongs to people and not to trucks
and so
um
do you know who who is uh who you would
you credit with the
the the the appropriate response here in
the Toronto protest was it the police
was it was it the politicians the mayor
um
how did this how did this end up um
getting wrapped up well I I would give
credit to the Toronto Police Service
being supported by other services and
that provided those resources so credit
goes to all of the police services that
participated uh in that protest but I
have to say Toronto learned lessons from
the Ottawa experience the previous
weekend
and what was your understanding uh of
the purpose of the protests in Toronto
what were the protesters protesting
so my recollection was that that
particular protest was in support of the
main protest happening in Ottawa and my
recollection of what was happening in
Ottawa was that there was a major
element of that protest that was
protesting in regards to the January
15th imposition of vaccine mandates on
International truckers by the federal
government
and um was there an element as well or
at least from the province's perspective
that this was about provincial measures
in addition to Federal measures
I I don't recall uh turning my mind to
that
um
my understanding was that this was a
protest in regards to
um
the federal mandate to impose
vaccination criteria on International
truckers but having said that I think
that there were many other elements that
attended both Toronto and Windsor that
had other agendas okay but in your view
it didn't include uh protesting
provincial mandates I I don't know that
okay
I want to take you to opp404580
and this is I'll take you to page 56.
these are more text messages between you
and commissioner Creek
and if we go to page 56
this is now February 5th Saturday
if we go down
some more
so there uh and and just maybe you can
clarify the green uh I believe
is you and the blue I believe is
commissioner Creek do you know if that's
are you able to clarify that
if we go down that might help
keep going to the next page
not helpful
well if we can go up maybe I'll just ask
the question and um
it may not make it much of a difference
so it says there uh at
11 30 or 10 11 info on Ops PSB is clear
to share and that would be the Ottawa
Police Service Board is that correct yes
and if we go down there's a link shared
um the Ottawa Police Service Board calls
special meeting and if we go down to
page 57 live link PSB meeting
so I just wanted to ask um there seems
to be some texts exchanged about the
opsb meeting on February 5th and my
question is were you monitoring what the
board was doing or were you did you take
an interest in the board's meetings I
did take an interest um
um to make the best of my recollection
there was both a public board meeting
and an in-camera meeting
and why were you taking an interest in
the board's meetings
because at the end of the day it's the
board that has accountability and
oversight over the Ottawa Police Service
and so there was a major issue happening
in Ottawa and I was interested in what
steps Ottawa Police Service Board would
be taking
the ministry of the solicitor general
has a representative that goes to the
meetings and advises the boards on
various issues is that right yes
and you may or may not know this but I
understand that in Ottawa it was Lindsey
Gray
do you know that
after reviewing some material yes okay
and what is that representative's role
so under section three of the police
services act the solicitor general has
uh responsibility to advise police
services and boards and the way in which
that duty is discharged is by way of
having Police Service Board advisors and
so that advisor is there to provide
advice on the police service act upon
request
and does that representative report back
the activities of the board to the
solicitor General's office no
and there's a report to the
um to the Inspector General of policing
okay but the but the solicitor General's
office does not receive any information
back from that representative
no okay and is there a reason for that
so well it's a reporting tree if you
will so that that information goes to
the assistant Deputy Minister the uh the
acting Inspector General of policing
that individual Ken weatherhill reports
to me and then it's my job to advise the
solicitor general okay
and to what extent were you briefed on
the uh ongoings at the board
I wouldn't say that I was briefed in any
great detail but I was aware of the
general
um discussions that were happening
okay and that was through whom
just from watching the the board
meetings that were public or was there
another source of information a
combination of watching the public board
meeting on TV and the advisor that was
present in the in camera session as well
okay and this would be Lindsey gray yes
okay so you had discussions with her
about
I did not have discussions with Lindsey
gray was being reported through Ken
weatherheld to me understood thank you
I want to take you now to
um we're moving on to February 6th to a
summary of a call it's ont 50311
and this is a call with the city of
Ottawa there are representatives from
the federal government that were there
as well you were present
I believe on behalf of the Ontario
government it was you and the deputy
minister of Transportation Lori LeBlanc
who were the two attendees for the
province is that correct
um I believe that's the case and there
were other Deputy ministers from Ontario
there as well if I my recollection is
correct including um
Deputy Minister Kate Manson Smith from
the Ministry of Municipal Affairs and
Housing I believe she was there as well
okay
um you know who took these notes
I do not okay
and you've but you've seen them before I
have and you saw them at the time they
were sent to you
um these notes the first time I saw them
I believe was
um sometime after the uh Convoy in
Ottawa was resolved I see okay thank you
um
my understanding is that Deputy Minister
Rob Stewart convened this meeting is
that right I would agree
and before attending this meeting did
you have any instructions from the
solicitor general from the premier on
what your role was to be or what you
were to contribute to this meeting
no but I certainly prepared for this
meeting
how did you prepare for this meeting
well one one of the things that I did
and I'd have to check my notes for this
date but one of the things I did was I
quickly reviewed the emergency the
Emergency Management and civil
protection act
and its provisions
and what was the purpose of doing that
well in the event that this discussion
turned to the emcpa I would be prepared
and
um
what did you see as your role in this
meeting
my role was to receive a situational
update and then discuss what the art of
the possible is with regards to
resolving the Convoy in Ottawa
and what did you see as the province's
role in trying to bring these uh
protests to a peaceful resolution at
this time
so the province's role was certainly
through the opp a division of the
ministry of the solicitor general to
provide all the resources that were
being requested
was there anything else
certainly trying to come up with
strategies to encourage the truckers to
leave coming up with potential
negotiation mediation Solutions
exploring um various other incentives
to
compel the truckers to leave
and if we go down on this page
the second bullet point Steve kanalaka
city manager from Ottawa provided an
update from the city's perspective
Steve Cadillac is concerned about the
posture of local counselors who are
pointing the finger at the Province and
federal government to provide assistance
to resolve the matter
so were you aware at this point then
that some leaders within the municipal
Community were pointing fingers uh well
both at Ontario and the federal
government
this was the first time I heard that
and then it says in bold Ottawa mayor
Jim Watson is going to declare a local
emergency in the city of Ottawa at 4 30
pm
the expressed intent of this declaration
is to put pressure on the premier to
exercise powers to resolve this
uh were you aware that the mayor
intended to put pressure on the Ontario
government
by by declaring a state a municipal
state of emergency this was the first
I've heard of it and I thought that that
was rather an odd statement as well okay
and why is that because when you look at
section four of the emcpa the intent to
put pressure on the premier to exercise
Powers is not one of the authorized
reasons for declaring a municipal
emergency
right and so what did you understand
um
the exercise of provincial powers to
resolve this to be in this case what
what did you understand the municipality
to be looking to the province to do
additional resources okay so you you
understood this to be additional
resources yes
and that's articulated in the next
bullet point
um because city of Ottawa will also be
looking for what the province and
federal governments can do to provide
additional assistance
right
um
although it says we'll also be looking
so it seems like this is something
separate from the bullet point above
you could agree with that interpretation
I would
and
um
did you see the Declaration of the state
of emergency at the time that it was
declared
no um I've seen it in the disclosure
material that I've reviewed
okay so you were not aware then at the
time that the Declaration stated that
the demonstrations were a threat to the
security of the residents I did not see
that declaration no okay and that was
not reported to you through your your
chain of reporting I did not see the
Declaration okay
at this point given the local emergency
that's about to be declared and some of
the other information that you've
received did you have public safety
concerns about the situation in Ottawa
by February 6th
no um I was still not seeing any
significant serious violent crime
concerns at all
um
at no time did
um
Chief slowly or commissioner Creek
communicate to me that there were
significant Public Safety concern from a
violence perspective and I knew that the
Ottawa Police Service was being well
supported by the RCMP and by the OPP as
well
right but I I think you can agree that
Public Safety encompasses more than just
violent crime correct yes okay so were
you aware at the time that there were
open fires and barrels on the streets
and
fireworks going off and open fuel that
wasn't properly stored and Diesel fumes
that were entering people's homes were
you aware of all of those circumstances
on the ground yes
but in your view that did not pose a
public safety concern
from a violent crime perspective with
regards to the criminal code yes right
but from another perspective it did
right
yes
um
so in your interview summary you
indicated that you were of the view that
the protest in Ottawa was a significant
inconvenience and that's a quote but
that it did not present an overriding
public safety risk
um now commissioner Creek was asked
about this and in his evidence I'm not
sure if you if you watched his evidence
but he indicated that it wasn't really
about
one being a safety risk and the other
one not being a safety risk but it was
about prioritizing resources and that
the Hendon reports made clear that there
was a security risk in Ottawa you would
agree with me that he was closer to the
ground in order to assess the situation
in Ottawa than you were correct I agree
and um do you still stand by that
statement today that it was an
inconvenience but not a public safety
risk
well it was much more than an
inconvenience and I accept that there
was a significant impact on the
residents of Ottawa I can't imagine what
they were going through I'm very
sympathetic and empathetic to all that
they went through and all the suffering
that they went to it was more than an
inconvenience much more
okay
now
after this meeting did you did you brief
the solicitor general on the fact that
the that the city was going to declare a
municipal emergency
um and that the stated intent was to put
pressure on the province
um I don't have any notes that I briefed
the solicitor general but my practice
would be something this important I
likely did
and do you know if the premier was aware
of that stated intent as well I did not
speak to the premier okay did you speak
to the premier at all throughout the
course of these events no
and uh did the Declaration in fact put
pressure on the province to act
The Province was acting well for example
the provincial state of emergency came
on the 11th was there any pressure from
this local state of emergency to do that
I'm not sure that pressure is the right
word I think the province was actively
um surveilling and looking at the
environment in terms of what was going
on province-wide and when the concern
was such that the protest was spreading
to other parts of the province as we saw
in Windsor in Toronto in Cornwall in
Sarnia at the Peace Bridge that's when
the premier decided to act
so is it fair to say though that this
may have provided a signal to the
province that the that the city of
Ottawa was in need of more assistance
uh I would agree with that but we were
also hearing loud and clear that the
city of Ottawa was requesting additional
resources
quest in a second
um so with respect to the stated intent
mayor Watson when he testified stated
that the city did not consider that the
province was engaged enough at this time
February 6th in finding a solution to
the situation in Ottawa so just wanted
to give you a chance to respond to that
I'm sorry where is that in this that
wasn't his testimony I can bring up the
transcript but he he did say in his
evidence when he testified here at the
commission that by February 6 he did not
feel that the province was engaged
enough in finding a solution I don't
accept that at all I think that the
province was very engaged in providing
support to the city of Ottawa through a
variety of means including support for
injunctions including providing advice
to the Police Service Board including
the provision of policing resources
including the provision of MTO resources
so I don't accept that at all okay and
when you mentioned the injunction what
was the what was the province's role
with respect to the city's injunction
I might be conflating the two
injunctions the one in Windsor and the
one in Ottawa but my understanding is
that the Attorney General supported one
of the two injunctions I can't recall
which one of the two I'm sorry I believe
that was Windsor yeah
um
so I'll take you to page
two
or the bottom of page one rather
thank you city Ottawa city council is
likely going to ask the premier and
prime minister to intervene directly the
mayor of Ottawa Jim Watson is feeling
the pressure and want this issue to be
pivoted back to Ontario and Canada
so it's fair to say that in this meeting
it was communicated or it was expressed
that Ontario or that Ottawa felt that it
needed it needed additional help both
from The Province and from the federal
government correct yes
and on page two
if we go to the third bullet point Mario
Di Tomaso that's you Deputy solicitor
general noted that the province
expedited the approval of 249 special
constables from the RCMP to assist
Ottawa Police Service
so this is what we had looked at earlier
where there was an approval of our CMP
officers to be sworn in as special
constables yes
and so at this point what else had
Ontario done at this point by February
6th other than what you've indicated
there
provided significant resources to the
Ottawa Police Service from the opp
significant number of resources
okay so that was so the opp provided
resources and was there anything else
yes I believe MTO was involved
um
in providing their resources
okay and if we go to page and I believe
I believe there was continuing advice to
the the auto Police Service Board from
the advisors
and then I'd have to check my notes but
the province was heavily engaged at this
point in time okay but you can agree
that Ottawa doesn't seem to think so
they're they're expressing that they
don't think there is enough engagement
right whether or not that's accurate
that's their their sense that they're
conveying yes
and at page five
um if we go to the first Black Bullet at
the bottom
keep going yes question from Mario Di
Tomaso Deputy solicitor general has
Ottawa Police Service been working with
the ministry of the Attorney General to
explore your options and in relation to
position of the crown for summary
offenses what were you suggesting here
so I'm not sure that summary offenses is
is accurate what I was suggesting was is
there anything else that the ministry of
the Attorney General can do with regards
to any offenses that are that are
charged so what I was thinking about was
is there an ability to increase set
fines is there an opportunity to explore
um bail Provisions for those people that
are arrested is there anything that the
Attorney General can do to better
support uh the Ottawa Police Service
and if we go to page nine
uh Jody Thomas National Security advisor
in the subpoint the black sub point
would the province be looking to the
federal government if this protest was
happening outside of the city of Ottawa
for example happening in other places
like Kingston what did you understand
this comment uh to be in reference to
so this comment was certainly not
aligned with the comment that Deputy
Minister Stewart made previous where he
was suggesting that the federal
government did have a role in particular
with regards to uh finding interlocutors
so from my perspective this question was
all about
um
from my perception the federal
government wanting to wash its hands of
this entire thing I didn't think that
was appropriate at all I thought that
the federal government did have a role
at the end of the day these protesters
were in Ottawa
to protest
mainly the imposition of a vaccine
mandate on January 15 on International
truckers they were on parliament's
doorstep they were in the national
capital region the federal government
public safety Canada does have a
memorandum of understanding with Ottawa
Police Service with regards to the
provision of policing resources in and
around Capitol Hill the opp is not a
signatory to that mou so from my
perspective the federal government did
have a role to play just like Ontario
had a role to play in the provision of
resources and so I made that known to to
Jody Thomas I felt that some of the
options that were available to the
federal government included the
possibility of meeting with and
listening to the protesters the
possibility of amending their uh their
vaccine mandate
the possibility
of providing additional resources to the
Ottawa Police Service so there was a
range of options available to the
federal government and it was my
position that the federal government
certainly had a role to play in this
okay and as you said the the provincial
government did as well so it was really
the responsibility of both levels of
government to come together and work
together to find a solution yes yes
that's that's absolutely correct but I
would also like to add at the end of the
day this was a policing matter and my
view was that both the federal
government and the provincial government
had a role to play in terms of
supporting the police response
and you mentioned finding an
interlocutor can you maybe expand on
what the what the idea was there and
what steps if any were taken
um so there were some some names that
were provided by uh Chief slowly at that
meeting
um don't remember the the name Murray
Sinclair
um
Bob Ray and others and and the idea was
to get a very high profile individual to
um meet with the interested parties to
see if there's a resolution that could
be that could be had
and what steps were taken beyond that uh
the discussion of the names was was
anything done
now with regards to those names that
were provided but at the end of the day
um there was a request later on uh from
the provincial liaison team that was
communicated to me through commissioner
Creek with regards to
um the potential to have Ministers of
the of the federal government and
Ministers of the provincial government
um
to intervene to provide a form to listen
to the protesters to see if those
protests could be de-escalated but that
happened later on not certainly not at
this meeting I see okay and that was
through commissioner karik you said
right he made a direct request to me
which I communicated to to minister
Jones okay and what was Minister Jones
response to that
well at the end of the day she did write
a letter
um directed to commissioner karik where
she would certainly make herself herself
available
um
two and this was in relation to Windsor
to make herself available to meet with
the protesters if they left the protest
and if they denounced this protest
activity so I'd have to refer to the
actual letter but the the intent was to
give the protesters an ear
of the provincial and federal ministers
so that they could be heard in an
attempt to de-escalate I remember
communicating with Deputy Minister
Stewart that that was the request of the
PLT and I I asked him to see what he
could do to make Federal ministers
available as well and through various
phone calls and discussions Deputy
Minister Stewart was not able to obtain
the services of federal ministers I was
able to to get the service of Minister
Jones to do that in Windsor she was also
willing to do that with regards to
Ottawa and
do you know why that didn't happen with
respect to Ottawa if she was willing she
was willing so why didn't it happen I
guess is my question why wasn't there a
similar letter because from my
understanding the letter did not have
the desired effect in Ottawa and from my
understanding was that the protesters
were interested in listening to or being
heard by federal ministers so Minister
Jones was certainly interested in making
herself available to the Ottawa
protesters but the federal government
needed to be there as well because that
would give the best chance of success
and when you say the PLT brought this
forward was that the opp PLT or the Ops
PLT
do you know the best of my recollection
it was the opp PLT okay and that was
from what I understand with respect to
Windsor
um was there ever an approach from Ops
in Ottawa or the opp in Ottawa to say
um the the demonstrators in Ottawa would
like to meet or would like to have
communication with the provincial
government
so two things I continued to urge Rob
Stewart to bring Federal ministers to
the table and I did that on my own
knowing that there was a potential
resolution that could possibly be
achieved because if there was a an
interest in Windsor to do that certainly
there would be an interest in in Ottawa
so I did that on my own and the second
thing I wanted to raise about that was
that Deputy Minister Stuart certainly
had Direct conversations with inspector
Marcel bodoin of the opp PLT to see what
the art of the possible was so that was
something that I was continuing to
explore with Deputy Minister Stewart
right and um we asked mayor Watson
whether he was aware of any such
overtures from the solicitor general
were made to Ottawa and he said no
um and and there was a time when the the
Ottawa protesters approached
um the city of Ottawa because they
wanted to have a meeting with the mayor
so I'm just wondering why that wouldn't
have signaled to the province that if
they're willing to meet with the with
the mayor and they're willing to
um
to negotiate something in return why
they wouldn't be willing to do that with
the province
so my communications were not with the
with the local city or the mayor my
communications were with Deputy Minister
Stewart and we were just trying to find
um whatever options were available to
try to de-escalate this thing okay and
so did you ever
um specifically indicate that uh the
province would be willing to meet with
Ottawa protesters
to Deputy Minister Stewart yes okay and
what was his response to that that he
would Endeavor to make that happen but
it did not come to fruition okay and you
don't know why
I don't that would be a question for
Deputy Minister Stewart okay thank you
now you mentioned that
uh from your perspective you thought the
federal government had a role to play
for various reasons one of them being
that the protesters were protesting
Federal vaccine mandates correct yes and
so I'm just wondering why does the
substance matter of the protest affect
who should be the entity that responds
to that or the the level of government
that responds to that
protest it shouldn't be I think I think
both governments had a role to play and
certainly Ontario had a role to play and
I'm certainly aware that the protest was
not exclusively about the the federal
mandate there were other groups that had
other agendas and I recognized that okay
and in terms of the Parliamentary
Precinct Wellington Street is a
Municipal Road it is the jurisdiction of
the Ottawa Police Service so in terms of
any kind of federal jurisdiction over
that street you agree there is no
federal jurisdiction over Wellington
Street
in terms of policing Wellington Street I
agree but but there is to my
understanding an mou between Public
Safety Canada and the Ottawa Police
Service with regards to provision of
policing resources in and around
Parliament Hill which includes
Wellington Street
and was it ever communicated to you that
um the local police service in this case
the Ottawa Police Service or through the
mayor because some the request did come
through the mayor and the the chair of
the board that it had to be done through
the province and couldn't go directly to
the RCMP in terms of requesting
resources was that ever something that
was communicated to you by any uh anyone
in the federal government
what are you talking about the concept
that all requests need to go to the
province first and then to the uh
federal government yes uh yeah that's
that's from my understanding that's more
of a policy
um through the emergency management
process
um and and um I think there's a section
in the Federal Emergency Management act
that speaks to that
um basically the the idea is when there
is uh a declared emergency
um that um The Province needs to exhaust
its resources first before it can go to
the federal government for an ask and
likewise that the municipal authorities
need to exhaust their resources first
before they can go to the provincial
government
and so in this case the letter from the
mayor and the chair of the board
requesting 1800 officers went to both
the solicitor general and Premier Ford
and also to the minister of Public
Safety and the Prime Minister and so
um my question is whether you are aware
if the fact that there was a request
made to the provincial government
directly from the mayor and the chair of
the board and not through the province
whether that delayed RCMP resources are
you aware of that
I'm not aware that it delayed RCMP
resources no and are you aware of
whether it was an issue in terms of the
federal government being able to deploy
those resources
um
given that it it it could have been seen
as circumventing so it's it's not a
matter for the provincial government or
the federal government to deploy
policing resources that is the exclusive
jurisdiction from my understanding of
both Commissioners they are the ones
that have exclusive jurisdiction in
employing their resources not the
governments
so my question is whether anyone within
the federal government communicated to
you that the request being made directly
to the federal government was a problem
because it wasn't being made through the
province no nobody communicated that to
me okay thank you
um
now at the end of this call this was a
lengthy call among various people at
different levels did you have any
concerns at the end of this call
were you satisfied
um that Ops and the chief were taking
the right approach
what was what were your takeaways from
this call
my takeaways were that Ottawa Police
Service needed additional resources and
those resources were in fact being
provided to my understanding by
commissioner Creek and commissioner
lucky
the main obstacle at this point in time
was that there was not
a plan by the Ottawa Police Service to
dismantle
the actual occupation that was the the
critical problem
and uh was that something that was
discussed uh in this meeting
I'd have to check the entire note but by
this time February 6 you were aware of
that that there was a lack of a plan
so um I want to be very careful about
that because there was a plan with
regards to the deployment of officers in
Ottawa for maintenance purposes to deal
with the influx of officers to deal with
Radio Calls public safety issues that
may or may not have been occurring there
was a plan to do that
what was not in place was a plan to
dismantle the entire occupation that was
the barrier and that plan for my
perspective included a plan to deploy
public order units A Towing plan an exit
plan a traffic plan all of that so when
we say that Ottawa did not have a plan I
am specifically referring to what I was
told was a plan to dismantle the entire
occupation that was the issue right so
there was a plan for maintenance of the
status quo but not to end the the
situation essentially correct and you
were getting this information from
commissioner Creek and commissioner
lucky I did not speak to commissioner
lucky okay
so it was exclusively from commissioner
Creek in terms of the Readiness of this
plan that that we're speaking about
right but I also received information
from Chief framer I believe earlier on
um and and his view that Ottawa did not
have that plan as well
and do you know how he formed that
opinion
I do not that would be a question for
him okay
uh so I'll take you to ont401912
and
um if we go down to the bottom five
bullets from the bottom
let's see there it is uh so
the um this is a
some public remarks that were made uh
and I believe this was made by the
solicitor general
um to be clear since the beginning of
the protest more than 1500 Ontario
Provincial police Personnel have been
deployed to the city of Ottawa providing
a range of support to the Ottawa Police
Service
this was a press release I believe are
you able to confirm that uh yes and uh
did you or your office participate in
drafting this press release no
um and I'll take you now to ont405345
so if we go down
uh right it's uh Ford
to you subject line OPP deployment
number Ottawa and it looks like uh he is
providing you with some OPP Ottawa
deployment numbers my understanding is
that these numbers were requested by the
solicitor General's office from the opp
is that right yes okay and why was this
request made from the opp in terms of
the number of officers
while the opp has an obligation to keep
track of the number of resources
deployed to Ottawa in the event that
there is a charge back to the to the
municipality
um so that's why those numbers were
being tracked
okay
says
um at the end of that paragraph
I have noted for the opp we will not
and only bottom line numbers being used
to confirm support being provided to
Ottawa and having a sense of what the
feds need to bring to the table
um so a few questions
with respect to that in particular
um was this chart
um being used to confirm the number of
Opp officers that have been provided
to be able to then say well now this is
what the federal government needs to
contribute
no I don't believe the case um I think
there was a request from The Minister's
Office of the opp wanting to know what
resources have been provided to date and
that was provided okay so in terms of
the the the comment that having a sense
of what the feds need to bring to the
table are you aware of what that's
referencing
I'm not okay
okay I understand from commissioner
Creek's evidence uh that the 1500
um officers OPP officers was an
administrative number and that in fact
referred to shifts and not to actual
1500 individual OPP officers is that
your understanding as well no that's not
my understanding my understanding is
that that 1500 number referred to a
period of time 10 days I believe total
officers being provided to the Ottawa
Police Service
um but were these 1500 uh
different individuals if I can put it
that way or were these you know 100
officers on one shift and then
potentially similar number of officers
on another shift yes and you're reusing
some of the same officers at different
times correct
it's not 1500 officers at any one time
no right
and were you aware that there was
confusion
at the municipal and the federal level
with respect to the number of individual
OPP officers deployed
I do understand that there was confusion
was there ever a discussion with Chief
slowly uh to to clarify that yes I
received a call from Chief slowly okay
and when was that do you recall
um I believe it was uh shortly after
shortly after uh these numbers were
released by The Minister's office
and so what was explained to him in that
call then
Chief slowly was uh very concerned about
the release of these numbers uh he asked
me to correct
um The Narrative that had gone out to
correct the the press release
I informed Chief slowly that these
numbers were a compilation of numbers
over a 10-day period and that they were
cumulative in nature and not intended to
represent 1500 officers on any given day
and he accepted that
that would be a question for him
did you get the sense that he accepted
that
he was not happy
okay why wasn't he happy
uh from well
he wasn't happy that these numbers were
released and was that because there
wasn't there was a sense that giving
numbers of officers was an issue in
terms of uh giving away police tactics
or it could have some sort of
detrimental effect on Police Operations
or was it because he felt that the
number was not being accurately
portrayed
I believe that
um
he was not happy because it put more
pressure on him and that these numbers
would be misinterpreted I see so if the
public thinks he has 1500 officers to
work with they're saying why isn't he
doing anything with them correct and
these officers were mainly as you said
being used for maintenance to rotate
tired police officers out and bring
other police officers in well no not
just that not just that there were front
line police officers there were
intelligence officer PLT officers
dispatchers there's a whole range of
officers that were being provided over
that period right but what I mean is
they were not being used to
um dismantle dismantle the programs
correct okay
was there any concern that revealing the
number of officers deployed could be
harmful to operations
from who front Chief slowly
I don't remember him
talking to me about that did you have
that concern yes
if so why were the numbers made public
then in the press release I did not make
those numbers public okay so you would
have been against doing that is that
what I'm understanding if you had been
asked you would have said no
I think it's not wise for anyone to make
numbers of deployed officers publicly
available okay so you weren't consulted
on it and so you weren't able to to give
that advice right correct
if I can turn to ont 403843
this is now February 7th
and if we there it is so you have a call
you say briefing this am and then it
says call with
opccc that should be OPP I'm sorry
okay so that's op okay so this would be
commissioner Creek yes okay
um
briefing this am would be asking for
twice the number of officers he requires
uh can you explain this notation
um yes my understanding was that
commissioner Creek was communicating to
me
um that at a briefing that had occurred
that day uh Chief slowly would be asking
for twice the resources that he required
did he give you any more context other
than that why or what the purpose of
that would be whether he agreed with it
whether he had concerns about that
whether commissioner karik had concerns
yes well both he and I had concerns I
had concerns about why that would be
done but I was not privy to to that
briefing or that conversation
but as explained to me
by commissioner Creek at the end of the
day
that issue was irrelevant because there
would be a planning team that would test
whatever numbers
were being asked for by the Ottawa
Police Service and that planning team
would be staffed with subject matter
experts so they would test whatever plan
so given that commissioner Creek had
communicated that very fact to me I had
a sense of comfort in knowing that this
is just
looking for the right word this is just
noise I was comforted in knowing that
whatever the Ottawa Police Service would
ask for would be tested by the by the
planning team
you put a star there though and
underline the twice it seems like
perhaps you were expressing in your
notes some concern yes I I was concerned
that uh if accurate that uh Chief slowly
would take that approach but I was also
comforted by the comments of
commissioner karik that whatever numbers
were asked for would be validated and
tested and at this point
um the chief slowly had made known the
number of officers he required were you
made known by this time February 7th
I believe the request was for 1700
uniformed police officers and 100
civilians
and if I can take you to uh 1715 a
little bit further down on this same
document
and can you just for the record indicate
uh who the individuals in this meeting
are
um so premier's office cabinet office
Soul gen Ministry of Transportation
Ministry of Municipal Affairs and
Housing Ministry of intergovernmental
Affairs and there was a meeting with
regards to Otto and this was because
mayor Watson and the chair of the board
had written that letter formalizing the
request to the premier and the minister
and given the fact that the letter had
gone to the premier there was a meeting
called to discuss okay what do we do
with it and my advice was that we give
it to the opp commissioner because it's
his exclusive jurisdiction to determine
whether or not to deploy resources for
how long and uh and what numbers and so
um
so the discussion was that we would
refer this letter to the opp
commissioner for his assessment we were
not in a position to direct the
commissioner to say you know we've got a
request for 1700 and 100 please Supply
these resources we don't have the
ability to direct the commissioner
that's his exclusive jurisdiction and so
we referred it to the opp commissioner
for assessment only
okay and um
if I can take you now to ont40-1141
uh so these I believe are the solicitor
General's notes
I don't know that
okay so
um that's fine we'll go to oottt four
zeros
or three zeros rather two nine four
eight eight
foreign
council could you repeat that document
Heidi please
ott30-29488
is there anything further down
okay
okay if we can keep going down
uh yeah keep going down I believe it's
uh coming up you know keep going
yeah we'll keep going down
uh yeah keep going down
uh okay yes so there it is
if we can just go up a little bit more
so it's dated February 10 and if we go
down just to the signature line
so this is a letter that was sent by the
solicitor general to the mayor and to
the chair of the Ottawa Police Services
Board this is a response to the request
that was made for those officers were
you involved in drafting that response
no
and um
have you did you read this letter at the
time were you aware of this response at
the time
I'm not entirely sure I was aware of
this letter at the time I knew that the
request was uh for additional resources
was going to be referred to the opp
commissioner
okay
content of this letter is that the
solicitor general is saying that she
will forward the request to the opp
commissioner as we saw in those in those
notes
in the meeting that was held earlier yes
and she's also highlighting
um that that an operational plan
proposed by the Ottawa Police Service so
it's both the resources that are being
asked and also highlighting that an
operational plan would be a good idea
okay and so is your understanding that
the resources were contingent on a plan
in some respects the resources to
dismantle yes
were contingent on a plan yes okay and
at this time there was not one correct
yeah
yeah
um
mayor Watson tested and when I say that
I'm sorry and once again the exclusive
responsibility to deploy those resources
were not of the government we're not of
the minister they rested with the opp
commissioner right but the but the
government can help to to bring that
request forward and to encourage the opp
commissioner to to deploy those
resources no the opp are not to be
directed they are independent they have
discretion and Independence and
discretion is not to be trifled with so
the government cannot direct cannot
influence it is his jurisdiction to see
um the way in which he deploys his
resources
so you did not believe that you had the
ability or the authority to recommend or
to talk about the needs in in Ottawa and
to make any suggestions to the opp
commissioner we were not in a position
to make any suggestions I was comforted
in knowing that the opp commissioner was
alive to this request and that he was
more than willing to provide the
requested resources contingent on
the plan for the dismantling and removal
of the protests being being there being
validated by the subject matter experts
that was the impediment
um now
on February 9 at 3 30 there was a call
between mayor Watson Premier Ford and
Minister Jones were you on that call
I'm sure there was a call on February 9
with the mayor of Ottawa the city
manager Mr kenilakis and solicitor
general Jones
were you aware of that call or were you
on that call not aware and not on it
okay
um
so in that meeting um
kaded about that meeting when he when he
testified
that Minister Jones expressed The View
that the request was a Law Enforcement
issue that needed to be dealt with
between the chief and commissioner Creek
and that Accords with what you just said
right now right correct okay
um so fair to say that she did not see a
role in helping to pass on that request
to commissioner Creek other than
saying you know here's the request right
that would be a question for her but
it's certainly consistent with what
happened there is not an ability to
influence the opp there's not an ability
to guide the opp with regards to the
deployment of resources that is under
the police services act the exclusive
jurisdiction of the commissioner
and Mr kind of like has testified that
on this call the city asked what other
actions The Province could take in terms
of Regulation or legislation to put
pressure on the protesters to leave and
he reported that Minister Jones said
that this was a Law Enforcement issue
and so therefore it should be dealt with
law enforcement did you share that view
that that there was not a regulatory or
legislative action that could have been
taken by the province
there was a legislative action that was
taken that was with regards to the
um the Declaration of a provincial
emergency and emergency orders were
issued as a result of that declaration
right so aside from the Declaration of
the emergency was there anything else
that the province could have done at
this point
are you referring to legislation
resources to legislation no I'm not
aware of any other legislation
um that that could have been invoked I
think it's also important to understand
that at this period in time
the existing authorities available to
police were perceived to be sufficient
by both Chief Slowly by commissioner
Creek and certainly by me
and if I can take you to OPP
four zeros4580
and these are some text messages with
commissioner Creek and I'll take you to
page 70 the bottom of page page 70.
foreign
and if we go up a little bit
so it looks like you're in blue because
at the there it says thanks Deputy much
appreciated that would be you right when
the green when he when he when the
person says thanks Deputy they're
referring to you correct I'm blue
Commissioners green that's right okay
perfect that's what I meant okay so if
we go up
um
if we can go up a little bit more
Deputy on the call with Ops and cacp any
word of the request for operational
resources to the premier and soul gen
will be referred to OPP so that would be
commissioner karik saying that yes
uh and then if we go down in response to
that question you say confident it will
be referred not certain
um
why would it not be certain that the
referral anyway would would be made
because the letter was addressed to the
premier and to the minister and I'm not
in a position to to speak for them but
we did have a meeting subsequently after
that with and I've already uh testified
to that with the premier's office
cabinet office Secretary of cabinet Etc
and it was that determined at that
meeting that absolutely would be
referred to the commissioner for
assessment okay so this was because you
hadn't had that discussion yet to make
the determination correct and would
there be a scenario in which that
referral wouldn't happen no okay
I can take you to ont405154
and we're moving ahead to February 8th
uh when it says call with OPP is that is
that likely commissioner Creek yes okay
and if we go to page four
um now a noon meeting with FEDS and city
of Ottawa
yes
if we go down we see all of the
participants of that meeting
if we go down
and this is a staff level meeting is my
understanding with provincial
representation Federal representation
also Municipal representation is that
right yes okay so if we go to the bottom
of the page
so it says Blair and Mendicino both want
three-way with mayor and soul gen and
this is desire
can you explain that notation
yes it was communicated to me
um that the federal government
ministers Blair and Mendocino wanted to
to meet with the solicitor general and
the mayor of Windsor
and um
did that meeting take place
I know that there were either two or
three meetings that occurred
at the minister level
right so these would be that what we've
been calling the tripartite meetings are
you aware of that terminology that we've
been using in the hearings here yes but
there were two level of meetings yes and
I attended either three or four at the
officials level this notation is with
respect to the ministerial level or the
political level okay and
um
at the at this time at this meeting
um did you have a sense of whether this
was something that was possible and that
could happen did you give a response to
that request
yes my response was that I would
communicate the request to minister
Jones and you did that I did
and and did you recommend that she
attend or did you give any
recommendation with respect to
attendance I passed on the request to
minister Jones did you make any
recommendation about attendance I did
not okay
and ultimately she did not attend is my
understanding is that your understanding
as well
there were to the best of my
recollection three meetings
um
I don't know whether she attended one or
not
but certainly two of the three she did
not attend
okay and
um
was that they were looking for some
provincial representation if not the
sister General then the premier and he
also did not attend were you aware of
that
yes okay
and um
I'll turn now to
document SSM
.nsc.can
four zeros3019
.
so if we these are some text messages
um this is involving
um
Mike Jones who's the chief of staff of
Minister medicino
and if we go down
if we go down a little bit more
okay and so essentially if we go
up a little bit
so it looks like Mike Jones is saying on
Ontario we haven't had much from Jones
so we've asked the premier's office if
there's someone else they'd like us to
play with
and then if we go down
how is that fine
he didn't say no and promised an answer
by end of day so my understanding is
that
um they were looking for some
representation but ultimately there was
no provincial representation do you know
why that was the case I do not
if we go to ssm.nsc.can
four zeros2052
and this is a readout from the February
8 tripartite
and if we go down to where Minister
Blair is speaking we go down
on Ontario involvement I know Marco's
been having good conversations with
Ontario they're worried about being
visible and then being asked about what
the province is doing
uh do you understand what this is in
reference to nope
when he says they are worried about
being visible do you know who he would
be having discussions with at the
provincial level to to make that
assessment I was not part of this
meeting and perhaps that question can be
asked of Minister Mendocino
okay
um
accurate that that Province was
concerned about being visible
and that was why it was not attending
the meetings
I don't understand
The Province was concerned about being
visible we were visible The Province was
providing all sorts of support and
resources to Ottawa so I don't
understand the substance of the question
well it wasn't visible in those meetings
because it wasn't attending so
um was that a concern that if it came to
the meeting it would be asked about what
it was doing
I don't have any information on that I'm
sorry
I'll take you to SSM c a n dot NSC
four zeros2837
and this is a readout of a call between
mayor Watson and the Prime Minister on
February 8.
and if we go down
keep going
keep going
yeah we'll keep going down
all right so
so we see the prime minister at the
bottom says I know we are looking very
carefully at what we can do more Brenda
lucky is looking at that one of the
challenges is that it goes in steps the
first step is to go to the opp then RCMP
it's difficult for us to say what we
need to do directly until we have a
better idea of what the province is
doing that's why this table is so
important but we are there to give more
support as needed
so were you aware that the purpose of
these ministerial meetings was to
um kind of sort out who's providing what
resources and in what order essentially
that was being done at the officials
level that was being done between
Commissioners and Chiefs of police as
well I was not aware of this call I was
not aware of the contents of this call
right but in terms of the notion that
um having the three levels of government
present at a meeting where resources can
be discussed
official numbers can be clarified
the the prime minister is indicating
that that would be helpful and I'm
asking whether you would agree that that
would be helpful
no it would not be helpful because
politicians
ought
not
to interfere with the deployment of
policing resources
so here it looks like the um the
politicians are in fact discussing
resources how many have been deployed
how many are required we saw the mayor
of Ottawa send a letter for resources is
that your position that that those
actions were improper
it is my position that the only people
that are authorized in law to deploy
resources are the commissioner of the
RCMP and the commissioner of the opp
they have sold jurisdiction it's
enshrined in legislation I don't know
what the Prime Minister was thinking
with regards to influencing
um
and and having either the RCMP and the
opp provide additional resources that is
not their role so short of deployment I
don't think anybody's arguing that the
Prime Minister should be deploying uh
resources uh but in terms of of passing
along uh resource requests in terms of
sorting out the numbers that have been
provided and what's needed
um and what the order of operations
should be should the province be
providing all OPP officers first and
then the the federal government and then
the RCMP it's it's unclear and so my
question is whether there is a role
short of deployment
um that the politicians can play
the resource requests were made they
were made public
they were made to the opp commissioner
for assessment they were given to the
RCMP commissioner so those resources
were being acted upon
so is there a role for politicians in in
assisting with these uh with the
resource matters
how
well my question is to you sir
I don't see a role for politicians to be
involved with regards to deploying
resources and those resource requests
were quite clear the RCMP and the opp
understood what those resource requests
were and they were best placed in law to
provide those resources
so that said
um you would not have considered it
important for uh a provincial
representative to be at this these
meetings if I take what you're saying
then
I didn't say that I just said that
politicians do not have a role in asking
Police Services to deploy resources that
is not an appropriate role
and is there a role in helping to
coordinate
the opp commissioner the RCMP
commissioner the chief slowly were in
fact coordinating
and that's where the coordination
belongs this was a policing matter it
was a police response
so then if the if beatings are in order
to
a solution and to and to come up with
solutions would you agree then aside
from the resource request which I
understand your position I take your
position on that
um was there there is a role though
outside of the resources that
politicians can play and these meetings
could be a helpful venue for all three
levels of government to be speaking to
each other about those other uh measures
that can be about the other measures the
other Solutions with the art of the
possible is absolutely okay
um the mayor testified that had the
province participated in the trilateral
meetings there likely would have been
less of a delay in receiving resources
do you agree with that completely
disagree okay
um if we go to the bottom of page two
yeah and the prime minister in the
middle of that paragraph says but Doug
Ford has been hiding from his
responsibility on it for political
reasons as you highlighted and important
that we don't let him get away from that
and we intend to support you on that
what is your response to those comments
I don't have a response those are the
comments of the Prime Minister and any
questions about those comments ought to
be referred to him are you aware of any
political reasons uh the premier four
would have had or the Ontario government
would have had for avoiding
um these meetings no
now my understanding is that
um
there was a commitment by the solicitor
general to participate in these tripart
type meetings and in fact in a call with
Premier Ford and Minister Mendocino Ford
appears have committed to asking Jones
to participate but then later kind of
withdrew that do you know what caused
this change
I have no knowledge
now mayor Watson also testified that
when he spoke to Premier Ford about
attending these meetings that Ford was
adamant that he did not feel it would be
useful to have three levels of
politicians sitting around the table
and from the mayor's view he he thought
the premier felt that it would be a
waste of time and he indicated that it
wouldn't accomplish anything
do you agree that it would have been
helpful to have three levels of
government at these tripart type
meetings
Perhaps
Perhaps it would have been helpful to
have discussions to see what the art of
the possible is with regards to other
Solutions
and
what about to help
information and align positions would it
help for that as well
potentially
now the commission may hear evidence
that the perception was that Ontario did
not want to participate
because they wanted the city of Ottawa
to lead the response and basically that
it was a municipal response and that it
should be limited to the city
and because Ontario viewed this as a
federal problem are either of these
reasons accurate to your knowledge are
you aware of these there's a lot to
unpack there
um
Ottawa Police Service is the Police
Service of jurisdiction
not the opp
not the RCMP
and so
we did not have the ability to impose
the opp on Ottawa without a direct
request without an invitation
so given the fact that they are the
Police Service of jurisdiction
the opp was in a position to provide the
requested resources to deal with the
problem
was there more to unpack there yes could
you I'm sorry um can you repeat the
question yes the question was um whether
these two reasons whether to your
knowledge those were reasons for not
participating one that the city of
Ottawa should lead the response to these
protests and two because this was a
federal problem
I'm sorry I I just don't know how to
answer that
take you to SSM
nsc.can
four zeros3104
and again my understanding is this is
Chief of Staff
um to minister Mendocino and somebody
from the prime minister's office
if we go down Samantha halil I believe
keep going
down
okay so
um
from Chief of Staff mayor about the
mayor Minister Jones call it did not go
well she told him she had no interest in
being part of a political Roundtable
were you aware that that was Minister
Jones position
no
but but I have to say Minister Jones was
in fact engaging in conversations at the
political level with Minister Blair with
Minister Mendocino with mayor Watson
those calls were in fact taking place
and did you have discussions with her
about participating uh in these in these
calls no
uh were you ever present on calls
between Minister manuccino and Minister
Jones no
if I can take you to ssm.can
four zeros6068
and this is a readout of a call between
Premier Ford and the Prime Minister on
February 9.
and if we go down
keep going okay keep going
um so they exchanged some pleasantry
there and then
um PDF is a premier Doug Ford
and he says
I understand and we all agree with
peaceful protests but I'll start off
with Ottawa versus Toronto I'll say that
the police chief and Ottawa mayor
totally mismanaged this the Toronto
police department and Toronto mayor did
a great job they've entrenched
themselves in Ottawa
um
you had you said you did not have
discussions with the premier
during this time is that right correct
and that includes phone calls but also
uh correspondence correct okay
and
um he would be getting his uh kind of
briefing from solicitor general correct
I'm assuming okay
um
do you have an understanding for the the
basis of the premier's view that the
Ottawa Police Chief and the mayor
totally mismanaged it
no
did you share that view
which view the view that the Ottawa
Police Chief and the mayor totally
mismanaged it I had no conversations
with Premier Ford no I'm asking whether
you uh shared the view not with him but
in your own mind whether you had that
same view as he is expressing here
um
no I did not share that view with anyone
at all
hold the same view
um I I wouldn't say that Ottawa Police
Service mismanaged I think that they
this was uh an unprecedented
protest of significant magnitude and and
scope
and I think
um that
um
the Ottawa Police Service did its best
based on the information that it had
it was incredibly trying circumstances
and I certainly didn't Envy the position
that the Ottawa Police Service was put
in
and what about with respect to his
comments regarding the mayor did you
have any view about the mayor's actions
no
and then Premier Ford says the bigger
one for us and the country is the
Ambassador Bridge and the state ground
there
um
would you agree that the provincial
government's priority
at this time was the Ambassador Bridge
blockade in Windsor
I think that commissioner Krieg
prioritized the deployment of resources
to the Ambassador Bridge he communicated
that to me for a whole host of reasons
with which I agree
and are you aware whether politically
the Ontario government also viewed
Windsor as a political priority
I'm not aware of that but I have to say
that the issue of the Ambassador Bridge
was being well reported by mainstream
media everybody that had a TV was
certainly aware of how important that
Crossing was to Canada and to the
province
um and if we
keep going on his comments keep going
down the next page
so
um
he says I've asked a second line I've
asked her AG to look at legal ways to
give police more tools and exhaust legal
remedies because the police are a little
shy and I can't direct them so that's
one area we can focus on
we can take their
polar licenses we checked that we can
shut down their fuel consumption and
cordon off highways that's where we're
at
um what was your understanding at this
time and this is February 9 of the the
tools that the police needed aside from
boots on the ground as they say just
resources
so I was not made aware by Chief Slowly
by commissioner lucky or the opp
Commissioner of any additional tools at
this point in time and you said this is
9 February that's correct I was not made
aware of any additional tools that law
enforcement required to and either the
occupation in in Windsor the blockade in
Windsor or the the occupation in Ottawa
and did you ever have a discussion with
the solicitor general about what tools
or legal remedies The Province could
provide to the police
no
do you have any sense for what the
premier is suggesting here
refer me to a specific sentence please
uh sure the last two sentences of the
first paragraph
with regards to I don't know what polar
licenses are quite frankly
could be a typo
we can shut down their fuel consumption
and curtain off highways I don't know
what he is referring to when he's
talking about fuel consumption with
regards to curtain off highways that's
quite evident the ability to block and
close highways using existing
authorities in the highway traffic Act
thank you
um
and then on we're now on the second page
the Prime Minister says
on the second line you shouldn't need
more tools legal tools
they are barricading the Ontario economy
and doing millions of damage a day and
harming people's lives
were you of the view at this time that
there were no other legal tools that
were required that the tools required
were available to the police at this
time
not resources but legal tools
I was I was not in receipt of any
requests from our policing leaders for
any additional resources whether that
was Windsor
Ottawa commissioner lucky commissioner
Creek Chief framer at no time did anyone
ask me for any additional legislative
authorities okay so you you felt that
the police had the authority that they
needed in order to bring these protests
to an end at that point in time yes okay
um and in that same paragraph
in the middle of the paragraph the Prime
Minister says the bridges and tunnels
act means the federal government has
responsibility over the bridge and
border so there is a rule for us to play
and we're happy to play it
but nobody can get on the bridge because
they're on Municipal land being blocked
and then
um
further down
so just stick a pin in that I'll ask you
something about that in a second
further down
um he says
has Windsor asked anything of the opp
I think we have to keep going down for
that
okay there it is has Windsor asked
anything of the opp have they made a
formal request to make a request to
support them
and uh the premier says they've put that
request in through the solicitor general
I spoke to the mayor and that was the
plan solicitor general was in touch as
well and I unders understand the request
is going forward
um
so at this time
it sounds like the The Windsor request
has gone through
um had the Ottawa request gone through
at this time
yes okay
and on page three
we keep going down yeah the Prime
Minister says what are the next steps
you said the opp are going in
are they keeping you apprised and do
they understand the urgency they can't
talk this out for three weeks they need
to act immediately
and then
the premier says they'll act but without
directing them it's hard to describe
their game plan
they'll have a plan on like Ottawa where
they didn't have a plan I'll get brief
tomorrow from the solicitor general and
we'll keep you updated this is critical
I hear you I'll be up their ass with a
wire brush
um
and
then the Prime Minister says we're there
with resources Bill Blair work will
coordinate on our side but you can reach
out to LeBlanc or me
you and I need to work together on this
people will be assured by the two of us
working together and we need to
demonstrate this is not a place of
lawlessness
and the premier says agreed you'll get
an update tomorrow
and then the Prime Minister says on
Ottawa it'll go through stages of Opp to
RCMP and we'll have a plan city of
Ottawa has been struggling but as soon
as OPP leans in a bit more we'll have
more clarity on things the federal
government has no jurisdiction over
Wellington Street so it's an area we
need to go through work through together
if the Ottawa residents have to go
through another weekend like the past
few weeks it won't go well
so in in this discussion
um there's been some jurisdictional
issues that have been identified uh for
example the federal uh the the federal
government doesn't have jurisdiction
over Wellington Street the RCMP doesn't
have jurisdiction over Wellington Street
um the federal government has some
responsibility over Bridges and tunnels
but policing is a provincial matter
under the police services Act
um so I just wanted to get your views on
uh some of the jurisdictional challenges
or issues that um that have been brought
to light as we can see in this
discussion and how you see the different
levels of government working together to
uh to come to a resolution to to uh
specifically the events in Ottawa which
brought together many of those
jurisdictional issues
so from my perspective both the
municipal road that leads to the
Ambassador Bridge provincial I'm sorry
Municipal jurisdiction and so the Police
Service jurisdiction there is the
Windsor Police Service and in Ottawa on
Wellington Street and the surrounding
area obviously
Ottawa Police Service is the Police
Service of jurisdiction and they are the
two entities that are responsible for
resolving both those issues do they need
support absolutely is there a role for
the federal and the provincial
government to play with perhaps
identifying interlocutors with providing
opportunities for mediation
for sitting down with protesters to
negotiate absolutely
but it's it's ultimately a policing
matter to resolve and the police
services of jurisdiction have that
responsibility and once it becomes
beyond the abilities of the local police
service
how then do the love the the other two
levels of government work together to
try to come to a solution uh
specifically with respect to Ottawa
which has those issues that we've
identified
well those discussions were were in fact
happening uh they were perhaps not
happening on a political level at a
tripartite table but they were happening
between Minister Jones the premier the
mayors of both Windsor and uh in Ottawa
and certainly ministers Mendocino and
Blair so those discussions were in fact
happening
and so do you see the provincial
government's role uh in a city like
Ottawa to be different than uh for
example as somebody raised in one of the
meetings a city like Kingston that is
not the national uh Capital Region and
that is not the uh the capital city
so both Kingston and Ottawa have their
own Police Services both police services
or the Police Service of jurisdiction
the province is there to provide the
necessary support upon request okay so
those would be treated the same from the
provincial standpoint yes okay
um
now when the local police service is uh
has gone beyond its capacity
um
is do you agree that the province has
primary responsibility to respond to
those requests for services through the
opp
are you talking about generally or
specifically with regards to Ottawa
I thought you just told me it was my
understanding what you said is that it
didn't matter whether it was Ottawa
Kingston so in any City in Ontario
unless there's a distinction so
certainly the The Province does have a
role to provide additional resources and
that's done through the commissioner of
the opp
and so um
to the extent that the opp has exhausted
its resources it would then uh turn to
the RCMP to require additional resources
from the RCMP is that the kind of
logical not not necessarily we still
have other Municipal Police Services as
well that are able to assist the
policing meters in this province work
collaboratively they are all members of
the Ontario Association of chiefs of
police those calls were in fact
happening on a regular basis and so it
is not just the opp going to the RCMP
for assistance the opp would have the
ability to ask for resources from
Municipal Police Chiefs a municipal
police chief has the ability to reach
out to other police Chiefs to ask for
resources as well so certainly the
province has a role to play through the
opp but so do Municipal Police Chiefs as
well right and in your view the RCMP has
a role to play as well is that is that
fair yes okay
so it's really a coordinated response
among all three levels of government yes
depending on the situation and and we
heard that Ottawa was an unprecedented
situation requiring uh all three orders
of government uh to to participate
Creek
and was mainly who was
breathe throughout this process
um
make any suggestion or ask about a
provincial state of emergency no
um did you have any discussions did you
ask him whether he he thought any of the
measures under a provincial state of
emergency would be helpful for him
I did not but I was certainly thinking
about the emcpa
um on her about that point in time uh
what we saw was an escalation in terms
of protests we saw protests in both
Sarnia I'm sorry in Sarnia Windsor the
Peace Bridge in Toronto and Cornwall so
I had a growing concern about the
escalation of protests specifically
designed to thin out police lines
to prevent police from responding in in
Ottawa so did there come a point where
where you considered that a provincial
state of emergency would be helpful as
you see these resources being spread out
thin I was certainly thinking about it
yes
and in terms of declaring a provincial
state of emergency that's within the
purview of the Premier is that right and
cabinet and cabinet and um
does the solicitor general have a role
in briefing or advising the premier with
respect to that
yes and what's what's that role
the solicitor general is certainly free
to provide that advice okay but it's not
at the solicitor General's
recommendation that the premier would
would do that is that right
assert the solicitor general certainly
has the ability to provide a
recommendation to the premier okay and
are you aware whether that
recommendation was made by the solicitor
general I'm I'm not aware of any
discussions between the minister and the
premier okay and um
do you have the ability to also make a
recommendation to the solicitor general
with respect to declaring a state of
emergency yes and did you do that in
this case
no quite frankly the the premier beat me
to it um he signaled on the 10th of
February that it was his intention to
declare a provincial emergency and given
that that signal that intent on the 10th
several Ministries started working
together to
to permit the Declaration to happen and
the essence of emergency declarations
are for emergency orders to flow from
that so we were examining what emergency
orders were required to support the
emergency declaration and one of the key
people that we relied upon was
commissioner Creek
so communicating to commissioner Creek
there will be a provincial emergency
declaration what tools do you need to
more effectively resolve the situation
in both
Ottawa and at The Ambassador Bridge and
so that communication was ongoing
between various legal departments
between my Ministry the ministry of the
Attorney General cabinet office
premier's office and commissioner Creek
so is it your understanding of the
decision to declare a state of emergency
was made before the measures uh were
determined what the measures would be
that would that would fall under that
I know that the the signal for an
emergency Declaration was made and then
we started Consulting with commissioner
karik with regards to what tools he he
required and do you have any
um knowledge of what was the turning
point or the Tipping Point for declaring
an uh for for wanting to declare an
emergency as of the 10th of February
um I I I I don't know what the premier
was thinking but I was certainly
um in a position to have made that
decision on around or that
recommendation on or around the 10th
simply because the matter was escalating
the number of protests were escalating
we saw repeated uh blockades and
attempts in in Sarnia the Blue Water
Bridge Highway 402 uh Nipigon Cornwall
the Peace Bridge Windsor
Toronto certainly things were escalating
and I was certainly in a position to
make that recommendation and I would
have had the premier not beat me to the
punch okay thank you
um and I'll take you to ont405149
and this is the briefing note that the
solicitor general sent to Cabinet
regarding the Declaration of the
emergency on February 12th
did you advise the solicitor general on
this briefing note
um so it's it's cabinet office that
prepares this briefing note okay
um and it's not my Ministry okay
and so you saw it when it came out
essentially you didn't have any input
into it my Ministry certainly had input
into developing this note okay and um
are you aware of whether the drafting of
the emergency measures had started uh by
the time that the Declaration was made
on the 11th
yes okay
okay
and
what was your understanding of the
objective of the Declaration and the
emergency orders that accompanied it
uh the objective was to well there were
a number of objectives
um objectives were to provide law
enforcement with the tools that they
needed to effectively deal with
the Ambassador Bridge
Ottawa and any other
protests that could develop in the
future so the emergency orders were
designed in my view to both deal with
the existing occupations and protests
but also to prevent and reduce and
mitigate the harm in the future so it
was both reactionary
and and future looking as well okay
thank you and if we can go down on this
document
and so I I just want to look a little
bit about look a little bit at the at
the measures uh and and what it um what
they prohibit
um and so the first a sub I says
preventing someone from traveling to or
from critical infrastructure as defined
in 2f so if we can go down to 2f
uh yes there it is and so we see there
uh from I to X
um or one to ten uh the different
um
elements under what what is defined as
critical infrastructure
it's interesting to note that the
Parliamentary Precinct is not included
under critical infrastructure do you do
you know why that was excluded from the
definition of critical infrastructure
yes and why was that
the Emergency Management civil
protection act has a limitation in it
and that limitation is that all
emergency orders need to be as minimally
intrusive as possible
given the fact that lawful protest is a
charter right there was a concern that
if we included the Parliamentary
Precinct that people that are protect
protesting some other issue would be
impacted by that and so we did not want
to be over broad
with regards to including the
Parliamentary Precinct
okay and if we can go back up to the
beginning of that those measures keep
going up
uh so
if we go then to so so as as you
mentioned then the Parliamentary
Precinct would not be part of uh the
definition of critical infrastructure
however as we if we see one uh in number
five a sub five
um that the measures also prevent
individuals
from uh preventing someone
um traveling
to or from walkways Bridges and highways
other than 400 series highways which are
already captured as critical
infrastructure if doing so would and
there's three conditions can you explain
that particular measure and and maybe
explain what the purpose of that was
so that particular measure was
specifically designed to deal with the
situation in Ottawa we see that it
refers and references highways the
definition of Highways is taken from the
highway traffic act and according to
that definition that certainly includes
all the residential streets including
Wellington in Ottawa so this measure was
specifically designed for Ottawa and
when we look at number three
um
if doing so would seriously interfere
with the safety the health of or
well-being of members of the public so
specifically designed for Ottawa and as
you mentioned Highway in this case means
essentially any road correct and was
there any uh concern that this might be
overbroad if it captures any road
anywhere in Ontario no because there's a
there's a caveat to it that the
interference would have to either one
two or three seriously interfere with
the safety health or well-being of
members of the public as an example so
this was not overbought and conversely
given that there are three requirements
or three possible requirements one of
the three would have to be triggered was
there a concern that potentially it
wouldn't be able to apply to Wellington
unless one of those three was was met
no there was not that concern
so you were confident that these
measures were targeted to the situation
in Ottawa but would not be overbroad so
as to impede peaceful protests in the
Parliamentary Precinct is that
a fair assessment yes
um if I can take you to
ont405152 can I just interrupt for a
moment I just want to check on the
witness or do you want to break it this
is going to be I'm afraid long so the
question is do you want a break you
could have two breaks or we can keep
going until you signal
uh we could keep going commissioner okay
you've got endurance that's good
um
so it was ont405152
and
um this is now February 14.
and these were amendments that were
proposed to the emergencies orders uh
were you aware of these at the time yes
and where you consulted on the
Amendments yes
um and did the solicitor general consult
with you
uh did did she consult with me was the
consultation with the solicitor general
yes okay and what can you tell us about
the purpose of the additional measures
can you scroll up for me please sure
so it's articulated right here confirmed
that provincial offenses officers can in
fact remove uh objects including
Vehicles themselves
as well as causing others to remove them
in B give provincial offenses officers
to remove objects or cause them to be
removed the power to detain and store
sure sorry maybe maybe I'll just clarify
sure what what was the intended purpose
of of these uh amendments so what are
they targeting so with regards to be I'm
sorry we were receiving additional
information from commissioner karik with
regards to
what additional Powers he required so
when you look at B for example there was
a concern that if a vehicle was seized
sent to the pound a person could
certainly pay the fine or the storage
fee get the car back and then certainly
join up again with a protest so this
particular emergency order gave the
police the ability to store that vehicle
for as long as the emergency order was
in effect
also there was the issue as articulated
by ADM Freeman yesterday with regards to
cvors and and ensuring that the police
made reasonable efforts to notify those
individuals that had cvors and and where
the vehicles were being detained and
stored
there was also the requirement
to ensure that tow truck operators story
storage yards were effectively
compensated and so there was a provision
here that referenced the story The
the the storage liens act I believe it
was that made it clear that
um any uh monies owing could be enforced
through that particular Act
and if you go to the second page
um in the first
paragraph under why does Ontario need
these changes we'll keep going
right
there we are
it says following the Declaration of
Emergency on February 11 2022 action by
police services have addressed the
blockade of the Ambassador Bridge in
Windsor however as the bridge has just
begun to reopen to regular traffic there
remains a threat of impeded access to or
egress from the use of it and other
critical Transportation infrastructure
including essential trade corridors
uh what was your understanding of the
continued threat of impeded access to or
egress from the Ambassador Bridge at
this time this is February 14th
so there was uh there was information of
uh various convoys coming to uh the
Ambassador Bridge from potentially from
Ottawa potentially from other parts of
Ontario I know that the commissioner
informed me that there was a a call by
protesters to come to Ontario to to
assist and so that concern was real and
so that's one of the reasons why this
emergency order was was declared and put
into Force there was a concern that
there would be continued attempts to
block Highway 402 the Blue Water Bridge
the Ambassador Bridge the Peace Bridge
Toronto Nipigon Cornwall Etc
and um was there any uh coordination
with the federal government on the tools
that might be needed uh in in the
measures and the provincial measures to
end the situation in Ottawa
was there ever a discussion with uh
Federal
um counterparts about the measures
not to my knowledge I didn't I did not
discuss this with Deputy Minister Stuart
I don't know whether commissioner karik
had that discussion with commissioner
lucky
okay so to your understanding and and to
your knowledge neither did the solicitor
general and neither did the premier
correct I don't know that right
um
in your view was the provincial
Declaration of emergency helpful in
resolving the situation in Ottawa
yes
and uh in Windsor
yes
and how so
uh well it it certainly uh provided the
ability to tow vehicles and other
objects that were blocking uh the
roadway
um and it certainly provided the ability
to immediately suspend driver's license
licenses permits and cvor registrations
and gave the police the ability to
remove vehicles themselves and
provincial offenses officers themselves
if necessary it certainly gave police
the ability to store seized vehicles for
a long term so that they could not be
reused in a protest
um
and it certainly imposed significant
fines on individuals as an example
violating one of these emergency orders
to my knowledge the maximum penalty for
an individual was one hundred thousand
dollars for a director of a corporation
five hundred thousand dollars and for a
corporation I believe it was 10 million
dollars
so these measures were significant yes
and to your knowledge was any other
level of government consulted on on this
provincial uh declaration or any of the
emergency measures under it
I certainly had discussions with Deputy
Minister Stewart after uh the
Declaration of the emergency and we just
did discuss some of these Provisions
Deputy Minister Stewart informed me that
at one point in time after the federal
government
I'm sorry or while the federal
government was discussing the
emergencies act that the provincial
Declaration of emergency certainly had
more teeth
um then the provisions in the
emergencies act and you mentioned that
you also spoke to commissioner karik
about what measures would be helpful
correct did you have any similar
discussions with commissioner lucky I
did not
was did anyone ask the province anyone
meaning within the federal government
that the municipal government OPP or
RCMP was anybody requesting that the uh
that the province declare a state of
emergency to your knowledge
no
were the elements uh there prior to
February 10 for declaring a provincial
state of emergency could it have been
declared sooner
there's a two-part test in the emcpa
that has to be met so I think an
analysis would have to be done to see
when that two-part test could have been
met
and were you doing that analysis in your
mind as time went on
I was thinking about it yes and when at
what point did you conclude that that
was that that had been met
honor about the 10th when the premier
signaled that he had the intention to
declare okay so prior to that it was
your assessment that the conditions were
not there is that right and that was
primarily based well I I wouldn't say
that the conditions were not there that
was primarily based on not receiving any
direct requests from any of our law
enforcement leaders
for the Declaration correct okay so had
that request been made you would have
considered it sooner yes
now it's my understanding that the um
provincial state of emergency closely
coincided with uh Ontario relieving some
of those provincial mandates
is that your understanding as well
um I'm not clear on provincial mandates
um
commissioner I'm about to move on this
might be an appropriate time for a break
I'm sure my friends would appreciate
that as well
okay well certainly the interpreters do
um so I will uh we'll take a 15-minute
break and then we can come back
it's in recess for 15 minutes
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
okay we'll give the commissioner a
minute
okay thank you
uh Mr D Tomaso um I want to take you to
ont405157
and this is now
um
a call you had with Deputy Minister
Stewart on February 13.
do you recall speaking with him about
the emergencies the federal emergencies
act at that time you can go to page 10.
yes
and the third point also Federal
emergencies Act is being discussed
is on the table but great reluctance to
invoke primarily because provincial
penalties under EOS are much greater
than what is available under Federal
emergencies act advised both Minister
Jones and SOC of above
so what did you understand Deputy
Minister Stewart to be telling you about
um the relationship between the
provincial and the federal measures
well we didn't discuss the difference
between the two measures in any great
detail
the discussion was about the fact that
the federal government was considering
the invocation of the federal
emergencies Act
it was this the first time you were
informed of that yes
and did you understand him to be saying
that the provincial emergency measures
were greater than the Federal Emergency
measures based on those notes that you
made there the penalties yes the
penalties and
um did he give you a sense for why it
was being considered if that was the
case
no
um
I'll take you to ont403847
and these again are your notes this is
now February 14.
and this is uh you make some notes in
relation with the to a call with uh
Deputy Minister Stewart at 8 55 I
inquire as to whether Federal
emergencies act will be invoked today
silence
um
what was your interest in inquiring
about the federal emergencies act well
he had signaled to me the day before
that the federal government was
considering the invocation of the ACT
um and this call here um
I wanted to know whether or not that was
in fact happening he did not he did not
answer my question okay and did you take
that to mean that and that was the
affirmative and not wanting to to answer
one way or the other yes
uh was the province expecting this to
happen or was this just you asking or
were you asking on behalf of others this
was me asking you okay do you know
whether the solicitor general or the
premier were expecting the government to
invoke the emergencies act no
and when Deputy Minister Stewart
indicated that to you that it was being
considered is that something you passed
on to the solicitor general
um I believe so um
yes I believe so okay
now the Federal Emergency act measures
were put in place to help solve what
you've indicated was a policing matter
so a Law Enforcement issue did you see
any concern about using Federal measures
to deal with uh what is substantially a
provincial matter which is policing
uh no because the emergencies act
invocation from my view was
um National in scope and so not knowing
what the federal government concerns
were canada-wide I wasn't really in a
position to have those concerns
and there was a first Minister's meeting
on the morning of February 14 were you
aware of it at the time
found out later
um do you know whether Premier Ford was
given advanced notice of this meeting
and what the topic of the meeting was no
idea
um are you aware of whether he was
briefed on the emergencies act prior to
that meeting
I don't know
um
did the solicitor general seek your
input or advice on the emergencies act
prior to that meeting
no
uh was it your view that the federal
emergencies act could help the police
resolve the situation in Ottawa
yes
and so if that's the case then were you
of the view that the Ontario measures
were not enough to bring those protests
to an end no
no it was not your view
correct I thought that the provincial
emergency declaration and the orders
that flowed from them were sufficient to
assist the police in
resolving both Ottawa and Windsor having
said that
the emergency orders that flowed from
the Federal Emergency declaration were
certainly helpful and I know that they
were used by law enforcement
so if it was your view that the
provincial measures were enough to bring
these protests at least in Ottawa and
Windsor to an end why did the government
support then the invocation of the
emergencies act by the federal
government
that would be a question for Premier
Ford and Minister Jones and in your view
uh did you support the use of the
emergencies Act
I never turned my mind as to whether I
supported the ACT I can tell you that
the
authorities granted by the federal
emergencies act were helpful and they
were used by by law enforcement and just
to clarify your views were not canvassed
with respect to whether or not the
province should be supportive of the use
of the emergencies Act was it correct
foreign
now we've heard
um testimony earlier this week about the
blockade at The Ambassador Bridge we've
spoken a bit about that briefly as well
um
is it your understanding that the
request for resources that came from
Windsor were in some way prioritized
um by the OPP
commissioner Creek informed me that he
was prioritizing the resources for
deployment to the Windsor bridge for a
number of reasons
and
um do you understand uh or do you have
any knowledge of whether the solicitor
general directed commissioner Creek to
prioritize Windsor resources
following both the minister and
commissioner Creek the minister would
absolutely not direct the commissioner
nor would the commissioner
receive that direction well he would
refuse it
okay and why why would that be because
there is um that's an operational matter
um and um
and government ministers myself are
simply not permitted to direct the opp
with regards to an operational matter
and deployment of officers is considered
to be an operational matter okay so the
uh prioritization of resources you would
say is an operational matter
Provincial Police resources yes okay and
but you would agree with me that this
solicitor general can issue directions
to the opp commissioner that are not uh
related to operational matters
with regards to policy matters yes okay
and what is your understanding of the
scope of that Authority that the
solicitor general has to direct the opp
commissioner on non-operational matters
well that Authority is contained within
the police services act that the opp
commissioner is subject to the solicitor
General's
Direction but my understanding from
Ministry legal and case law is that
direction is only to apply with regards
to Human Resources budget
policy and certainly nothing in regards
to operations and certainly nothing in
regards to any emergency provisions
right but as you mentioned Human
Resources would fall under that so
prioritizing human resources in one area
over another would that fall into no
okay and are you aware of whether the
solicitor general did in fact issue any
directions to the opp commissioner
throughout these events
I'm not aware and I believe had she done
that the commissioner would have
informed me
um
now
um
we see in the institutional report that
was filed on behalf of the government of
Ontario that the business sector became
quite activated with respect to the The
Windsor blockade and I think you
mentioned something along those lines as
well right yes
um did that play a role in the decision
to prioritize Windsor as an issue that
had to be resolved
so it was commissioner Creek
that prioritized the deployment of
resources to the Windsor blockade over
Ottawa
and as he communicated to me one of his
considerations for doing so one of many
considerations was the economic impact
now Witnesses have testified before the
commission that the city of Ottawa
attempted to make a deal or did make a
deal with protesters to move trucks out
of residential areas you're aware of
that
um I was informed by Deputy Minister
Stuart at one point in time on a phone
call
the person representing or negotiating
on behalf of the protesters Deputy
Minister Stewart informed me of that
okay
um
and
uh
you didn't you weren't aware of that
prior to his telling you no okay
do you know how Mr French got involved
and became the representative of some of
the organizers in this no
did you have any contact with Mr French
during any of the time of these protests
no
are you aware of whether Premier Ford or
his staff had any contact with Mr French
no
are you aware of whether Mr French was
acting under the instructions of the
government the Ontario government to
broker this deal to find a resolution no
um now we know the Emergency Management
Ontario and the provincial Emergency
Operations Center were both engaged in
the Windsor situation they were not
engaged with respect to Ottawa do you
have a sense for why that is they were
engaged in Ottawa there was a field
officer from Emergency Management
Ontario that was embedded in the
um
the Ottawa Emergency Operations Center
and what about the provincial Emergency
Operations Center
the provincial Emergency Operations
Center was in full activation mode on
the 11th of February
in Ottawa
the provincial Emergency
Operations Center is located in Toronto
yes but I mean it was activated with
respect to the events in Ottawa on
February 11. is that what your evidence
is okay
but not prior to that
so there are three levels of activation
with regards to the provincial
Emergency Operations Center there is
routine monitoring there's enhanced
monitoring and then there is full
activation and the PO the peoc went into
full activation on the 11th of February
before that it was in enhanced
monitoring mode are you able to tell us
when it went into enhanced mode 11 oh
I'm sorry um
I am not
um can I take you to pb.nsc.can
four zeros
7378
this is a letter from commissioner Creek
on February 22nd
to you
and if we go to the second page
you recall receiving this uh this letter
yes
if we go to page two the last paragraph
uh commissioner Creek says while this
situation is unprecedented the opp
worked with legal and determined that
because we are engaging companies under
the provisions of the emergencies act
not as procurement contract or agreement
that we should work within the
reasonable compreh compensation
Provisions consistent with the terms of
the regulations
um
now my understanding is that
the um
tow truck operators were indemnified uh
under the emergencies act are you aware
of that yes
and were you involved in discussion
discussions around what indemnification
could be provided to tow truck operators
no
and
um
my understanding is that the opp was
delegated power under the emergencies
act to compel tow truck operators is
that right yes
and
um was that was that done were tow truck
operators compelled under the
emergencies Act
that would be a question for
commissioner karik okay
um
in the evidence we received from
commissioner Creek it seems that the
trucks had been lined up and ready to go
before the letters were sent out but
that he had concerns about them backing
out at the last minute
do you recall this were you aware of
this at the time
yes commissioner Curry did make me aware
of that concern okay
um
now
just to go back to a point regarding the
day-to-day enforcement operations which
as you have uh testified the solicitor
general can't direct
um
in your view was the Ops providing
adequate and effective police services
at the time when the Convoy became an
entrenched
I would say yes with the support of the
opp yes
and so then uh you understood that to
mean that there was public order
in Ottawa
yes
now the police services act provides
that if the Ontario civilian police
commission finds that a municipal force
is not providing adequate and fully
effective Police Services it can
communicate that finding to the board of
the municipality and direct the board to
take the measures that the commission
considers necessary
um
do you have any views on whether the
solicitor General's office should be
able to recommend to the commission to
take such a step I understand that right
now that's not contemplated in the ACT
I'm asking whether something like that
would be helpful
so the solicitor general does have the
ability to write the ocpc to ask
it to investigate the provision of
adequate and effective Police Services
and um
right so that's that's a different
provision is my understanding that the
commission may at the request of the
solicitor general investigate inquire
into and report on the conduct or the
performance of duties of a municipal
police chief
um did the solicitor general uh to your
knowledge consider making such a request
from the commission
I I don't know
foreign
are there any other mechanisms that can
be used
for the solicitor general or the
Commission in this case the oversight
commission to remove a chief of police
or have a chief of police step aside if
it has concerns about its performance
so the ocpc has the ability to suspend
and or remove a chief of police
a Police Service Board of jurisdiction
has the ability to suspend a chief of
police
and in my view in this particular
circumstance The Entity that was best
placed to deal with any performance
issues that it perceived would be the
Police Service Board of jurisdiction
so my question is should there be a
mechanism doesn't exist in the police
services act but should there be a
mechanism by which the solicitor general
can
take steps to ensure adequate and
effective Police Services
if it is of the view that there are
circumstances that warrant it where
perhaps the board is not able to act or
is not acting is receiving inadequate
information uh whether there's where
there's a deficiency of some kind which
which then does not allow for the board
who as you say would be the entity that
would normally be the one to do that
um
would it be helpful to have some that
kind of a mechanism in place
I I think that that is a discussion that
needs to take place with legal services
we are currently in the process of
drafting regulations with regards to the
community safety and policing act which
we hope with cabinet approval and
legislative approval to be brought into
Force sometime in late 2023 or early
2024. so discussions certainly need to
happen but you're asking me a question
about whether it's appropriate for the
solicitor general to have that Authority
Perhaps Perhaps it would be appropriate
for the commissioner of the opp to have
that Authority given the fact that he
has responsibilities across the entire
Province and perhaps that Authority
would be better suited for the
commissioner to have the ability to step
in and take over a particular operation
if there was
reasonable grounds to believe that
adequate and effective Services were not
being delivered but in this situation
once again
I believe that the Police Services Board
was best placed
to deal with that issue
okay and on that point if I can take you
to OPB four zeros one six four seven
uh so these are the um
meeting minutes of a meeting of the
Ottawa Police Services Board on February
5th and this is the one I believe uh you
and and commissioner Creek had been
texting about on February 5th about a
meeting at the board this is the
in-camera portion of that meeting
and if I can take you down
to I believe it's page two or three if
we can just go to the second page
okay if we keep going down
scroll down
okay so in the middle of that paragraph
it says the chief reassured the board
that there was a comprehensive plan
however he could not provide all the
details of what the service was doing
operationally
so here's an example where the board has
been told by the chief that on February
5th there's a comprehensive plan
my understanding from your testimony is
that there was not a comprehensive plan
to end the demonstration on February 5th
uh were you aware that the board was
being given the information that there
was a comprehensive plan on February 5th
no um and with regards to this
particular section here
um I think that the police Service Board
is entitled to receive operational
information in camera the Morton report
states that now the Morton report does
not have the force of law
but one of the recommendations certainly
says that a board is entitled to receive
that operational information now had the
board not been satisfied with either the
performance of the chief or the
provision of that operational plan it
had options
okay and what were the options
I certainly could have invited the opp
and the RCMP to come in and brief it as
to whether or not there was an
operational plan to dismantle it could
have informed itself better the board
had the ability according to the Morton
report to make recommendations to the
chief of police
and the chief of police certainly had
the ability to either accept those
recommendations or not the board could
not infringe on on operations could not
direct the chief on operations but it
certainly had the ability to make those
recommendations had the chief
declined to accept those recommendations
that would have informed the board as to
what its next steps ought to have been
and one of the options was for the uh
the board to make a request under
section 9 of the PSA to the commissioner
of the opp to step in and take over that
particular operation that was an option
that was available to the board
okay so were you aware that the board
was informed on February 5th that there
was a comprehensive plan no
um if I can take you to OPP and I'm
almost done commissioner I just need a
couple more minutes if you will
opp404580
and um
if I can take you to these are text
messages again if I can take you to page
128.
and this is between you and commissioner
karique
and at 3 59 if we can find that
uh
so we hear so so again we said the blue
is you and the green is commissioner
Creek correct
yes
and so you say to commissioner Creek in
a confidential board meeting I'm hearing
slowly tendered his resignation an
external Chief will be hired still
confidential as a meeting is going on
and he says interesting this will be
very important to con to confirm
um how did you learn about what was
happening in the confidential board
meeting as it was happening
so there was a Police Service Board
advisor from the ministry in that
confidential meeting Lindsey gray I
believe so and how were you receiving
information about what was happening at
the board meeting through Ken
weatherhill
and was that through text messages
I don't remember may have been phone
calls text messages don't remember
and three what was the name of the
person you indicated Ken weather Hill
and who's Ken weatherhill he is the
current acting assistant Deputy minister
in charge of the inspectorate of
policing division
and how was Ken weatherhill aware of
what was happening at the board meeting
was he in attendance at the board
meeting at the time he was communicating
with his Police Service Board advisor
and that would be Lindsey gray yes okay
so if I understand it Lindsey gray is in
the meeting she's communicating with Ken
weatherhill and he's communicating to
you yes is that normal protocol in a in
a confidential board meeting
yes okay
um
now
in his evidence commissioner karik
indicated he was concerned about the
higher of an external Chief in Ottawa
were you aware of commissioner Creek's
concerns
I might have to check the text messages
and my notes I'm not aware of him
communicating his concern with regards
to an external Chief I stand to be
corrected I just don't remember did you
have any concerns about an external
Chief being hard
um
no what I was most concerned about was
that the impending decision for positive
action not be interfered with that was
my main concern we were going into the
third weekend there was a decision for
positive action the resources were in
place and my main concern was that if
there was a a new chief that that Chief
would have to be briefed up would have
to review whatever plan there was and
that would slow things down
okay and if I can take you to my last
document opp404583
and I'll take you to page 52.
now these are text messages between
commissioner Creek and commissioner
lucky so you are not on these messages
um
the second uh
second blue bubble on page 52.
uh let's keep going down
okay so
um sorry in the green and
um I understand that green is
commissioner lucky and
um blue is commissioner Creek
uh with respect to your comments
yesterday I agree we need to ensure Ops
leaves Steve in play until we have done
what we need to do introducing a new
external player in the short term will
set us back and again this is February
16 at looks like 12 36 or so
uh were you aware that commissioner
karik was passing on the information
that you had relayed to him to
commissioner lucky
I was not aware of these discussions
between the two Commissioners okay and
were you aware that commissioner lucky
asked Deputy Minister Stewart to reach
out to Steve kanilakis about about this
no okay
um and if we can go down
so um
for a context we'll we'll keep reading
so
commissioner Creek says I will see what
I can do to get them to delay bringing
in an interim Chief if you think that
will help
and commissioner like he says if you
have some influence I think it would be
helpful our ministry policing advisor is
going to suggest the same
I'm sorry to interrupt uh commissioner
and commission Council I I think it's
the inverse that the green is
commissioner karik and the blue is
commissioner lucky okay thank you just
makes sense now that we've read yes
thank you very much so
uh so then with the new uh color coding
uh commissioner Leckie says I will see
what I can do to get them to delay
bringing in an interim Chief if you
think that will help and commissioner
Krieg says if you have some influence I
think it would be helpful our ministry
policing advisor is going to suggest the
same and then if we keep going down
10-4
and again this is commissioner lucky
said had DM Stewart Reach into Steve K
Ottawa city manager he assures that they
are very sensitive to this Keen for the
ICC plan to proceed and don't want Bell
to be displaced Rob got the sense that
there's a lot of political infighting
going on
um to what extent were you aware of
these discussions that were being had uh
with respect to the uh the chief of
police in in Ottawa not aware at all and
what my position was
with regards to this selection of the
next chief that that was the exclusive
jurisdiction of the Police Services
Board and I certainly didn't want my
advisor to interfere with that at all
okay and um the discussions that are
being had here would you agree that this
is impermissible kind of political
interference in in something that is in
the exclusive purview of the board
I don't know whether anyone followed up
with these actions at all but I made it
clear to both Ken weatherhill and uh and
the advisor that they were not to
interfere with the exclusive
jurisdiction of the board it was the
board's sole responsibility to select
the next chief full stop
so if these actions had been taken is it
your view that this would have been
improper yes
are you aware of any Communications
between the province and the city with
respect to this issue no
um was the response to the of this the
Ontario government's response to the
events in Ottawa and winds are adequate
in your view
I'm sorry could you repeat that question
the Ontario government's response to
this situation in Ottawa and Windsor is
it your view that that was an adequate
response yes
and was there more The Province could
have done
I think that the province did all it
could have done
I think it did
um in your view was the Federal response
adequate in this case to Ottawa and
Windsor
from your Vantage Point of course my
vantage point the uh the emergency
orders that flowed from the Federal
Emergency declaration were helpful as an
example it provided indemnification to
tow truck drivers that is something that
the provincial emcpa does not permit
for example the emergency federal
emergency orders permitted the tow truck
drivers as an example to be compelled
that is not something that the
provincial emcpa permits the only thing
that the provincial emcpa PA permits is
protection from liability whereas the
provincial or the federal orders
certainly go for further so they were
very helpful in resolving the
Ottawa situation and from your Vantage
Point was there more that the federal
government could or should have done
or done earlier
no
and same question with respect to the
municipal response again from your
Vantage Point
in terms of the emergency declaration in
terms of what could or should have been
done differently in order to respond to
the events in Ottawa
from a municipal perspective yes so yes
I think one of the things that the
municipal emergency declaration you know
when you look at section four of the
emcpa it is exceptionally Broad and so
in addition to declaring the municipal
emergency declaration it was open to the
head of council to issue emergency
orders
um and that did not happen options
available at the municipal level
included increasing maximum fines for
bylaw offenses now I know that they
requested the regional senior judge to
increase the out-of-court settlements
that was done great but certainly not
the maximum offenses permitted they
could have done that they could have
permitted they could have issued an
order
preventing all sorts of activities they
could have leveraged section 444 of the
municipal act they could have issued
orders to stay out of a certain area
they could have issued order prohibiting
all sorts of activities within a defined
area
so there were all sorts of tools that
could have been provided by the
municipality whether or not those
additional authorities could have been
enforced by The Police Service of
jurisdiction was up to the discretion of
local police and we've heard Chief
slowly talk about some of the
impediments and challenges about
enforcement that they would be swarmed
that there was an aggressiveness to to
the protesters but I think that
equipping police in the earlier stages
with additional tools could have
potentially been helpful right it's just
more tools in the toolbox correct and um
would you agree with me that the
situation that went on for 25 days in
Ottawa was unacceptable that it lasted
that long would you agree with that
foreign
had there been a possibility to resolve
that situation earlier I would be
completely in favor of that I have been
around through a number of other
situations where block AIDS lasted that
long and I referenced the 2020 blockade
of the CN rail
in tie into Nega
that took about three weeks to resolve I
referenced the Caledonia
issue and and that took several weeks to
resolve three to four weeks and so from
my perspective the operation in Ottawa
to dismantle the blockade from a
policing perspective was in fact a
success let's not forget there was no
loss of life nobody got hurt tear gas
was not used we did not have those uh
ugly scenes of people with bloodied
heads and so from that perspective
the police operation to dismantle was a
success I'd rather be here testifying at
this commission before this commissioner
then at several inquests in regards to
Deaths I much prefer to be here today
than at an inquest so I think the
operation to dismantle was a success and
full compliments and kudos to the police
officers that served so ably and and
many compliments to the policing
leadership that was present then it was
a difficult task for all concerned
including the residents but including
the police officers that served and the
policing leaders as well
thank you Mr D Tomaso those are my
questions for you thank you commissioner
okay thank you
um first uh we'd like to call on the
government of Canada please
thank you commissioner uh good evening
Mr D Tomaso
I'm Andrea Gonzalez one of the lawyers
for the government of Canada in this
inquiry
um now as I understand uh your evidence
one of your roles in connection with
these events and more generally is to
brief the solicitor general yes yes
um and in particular on information
received from the opp commissioner
um uh that is of Interest or concern to
the political level yes
um and uh either directly or or through
the solicitor general or the Secretary
of cabinet you would also be involved in
briefing cabinet itself
I did not brief cabinet I'm speaking
more generally outside of these matters
is that something you do from time to
time either through the solicitor
general or through the secretary if
called upon to brief cabinet I would be
there to brief Captain so is it fair to
say that your role is
um as a conduit from the police to the
political level
that's one of my rules okay
um and commissioner karik gave you
regular updates on the picture across
the province throughout these events yes
yes
uh he's a highly experienced and highly
respected Police Commissioner yes
um he's an advisor to you and the
government of Ontario in respect of
these matters yes
uh and you would accept his advice and
his guidance on
um matters uh pertaining to his mandate
his field of responsibility right it
depends on what that advice is it
depends on what that the circumstances
are okay and in respect of the
circumstances that we're talking about
here today these events
um you trusted the advice that he was
giving to you in the government yes yes
now
um there were a number of protest
activities across a vast geographic area
in Ontario uh correct yes
um and uh you you've listed a few it was
not only Ottawa Windsor but also Sarnia
Toronto the Cornwall area nipagan out in
um the Niagara region
correct yes
um and uh I gather you shared a concern
with commissioner karika about spreading
police resources then across these many
areas so vastly spread out yes yes
um and um
was it one of your concerns that there
may have been a deliberate plan on the
part of protest organizers to stretch
police resources beyond their capacity
yes
um it appeared that the protest
activities were coordinated
yes
um and I gather you were aware that
among the organizers were former
military and police officers yes I
learned that at some point in time not
in surely not entirely sure when at what
stage okay
um and police officer former police
officers and um perhaps also former
military would have a unique
understanding of the logistical and
resource challenges that police would
face especially the opp because of the
large geographic area it covers
um in responding to simultaneous
protests and blockades yes they would
have better understanding than most
right
um and I want to let's go to
ont405153 this is one of your notes at
stated February 3rd
laughs
yeah and we'll scroll down to below the
uh black keep going okay if you could
just uh sorry next page going
okay and stop there and this is the call
with Toronto police chief uh Raymer that
you had that day yes
um and down at the bottom of the page
there there's three lines coordinated
tactically trained dispersed Pou assets
you recall uh Chief Raymer talking to
you about that yes fair to say that one
of his observations as well is that
these protests
um were being influenced or part of the
Tactical planning
um uh were those with training in
tactical operations that was my
understanding yes
um and there's another note o n t four
zeros five one five five
we'll start at page 14 please
uh this is the 10th of February
if we could keep scrolling down
I can't tell if it's my reading of your
handwriting or um my page number is
wrong uh apologies it's page three
yeah and just under the line that says
Intel Intel there if we keep scrolling
um you see the third bullet point
uh speaks of former police officers as
well as one Intel officer and so at
least by February 10th you had that
information yes
um
and with former military and police
embedded with this group
um
you would expect they know that police
are not necessarily built for a long
lasting occupation right I would agree
um and I understand Mr Di Tomaso that
you were a Toronto Police Service
Officer for many years yes
um and so given your own policing
background this would have been front
and center in your mind yes
um
if we go down I'm I think it's page 20
. I got my reference right
okay I'm not saying it I'm going to come
back to that
um
now because these protest activities
were connected
um I take it another concern you had is
that activities at one location could
have effects in other areas across the
province yes yes
uh and if the police and government
authorities didn't get it right in their
response at one location
uh that could have an impact
throughout Ontario yes
yes
um and uh indeed in other parts of
Canada yes
um and are you aware sir that
um the opp had in fact identified the
potential that there was a deliberate
plan
um to stretch law enforcement among the
protest organizers
that was a discussion I had with
commissioner karik and that was a
concern of his that he communicated to
me yes is that information that you
passed on to the political level
I don't remember okay
um now you've given
uh some evidence of a call
um that you attended between officials
from Ontario from Ottawa in Canada on
February 6. you recall that yes and
we're gonna pull up the notes ont 50311
foreign
participating in this call
um
you understood that both Ottawa and the
federal government
um
we're eager to have the province come to
the table to talk about the protests in
Ottawa right yes
um
you were provided with important updates
about the situation in Ottawa on this
call yes
and you would agree that things were
volatile and evolving rather quickly
they were volatile
and I take it you you briefed it I
apologize if you said this um in
response to questions from commission
Council but you briefed uh Minister
Jones on the information that was
conveyed to you in this call
I did talk to her about this call to
what extent I I don't remember okay
and so I wouldn't I would not want you
to think that I briefed her completely
on the contents of this six page report
okay
um but you likely would have passed on
to her at least the information that
stood out to you as being important for
her to know yes okay
um and uh
commission Council took you to the
comments of nsia Jody Thomas at the end
of the document I'd like to go there as
well it's on the very last page
um
and again she had put to you or she
asked you would the province be looking
to the federal government if this
protest was happening
outside of the city of Ottawa for
example in Kingston
um
you took from this question that
certainly nsia
Thomas thought that the province was
looking to the federal government to
respond to what was going on in Ottawa
um my response was that the federal
government had a role to play in this
yeah sorry but before we get to your
response I'm asking about what you
understood from her question did you
understand from her question that she
thought the province was looking to the
federal government
to respond I understood from her
question that the federal government was
trying to wash its hands of this entire
thing that's what I took from it
and yet you understood that the federal
government was trying to get Ontario to
a tripartite table with Ottawa as well
as itself federal government right
Ontario was at a tripartite table at the
official's level right but Canada was
trying to get that done at The
Minister's level you understood that yes
yes
um you've also told us that Canada in
particular through the RCMP was
providing appropriate support and
resources to Ops right yes
um and uh when you testified about this
statement
um in response to questions from
commission Council uh you also you said
that um you felt it was not aligned with
Deputy Minister Stewart's comments about
the federal government having a role in
finding
interlocutors you remember giving that
yes evidence yes Deputy Minister Stewart
certainly acknowledged that the federal
government had a role and that's why I
said that the comments of Jody Thomas
were not aligned with that I felt that
she was communicating to me that she
thought the federal government did not
have a role
and do they take your evidence
um correctly that you understood that um
Deputy Minister Stewart had made that
contact that comment in the context of
the the names that we see higher up on
the page there Murray Sinclair Bob Ray
and Louise Arbor
well it's I I know for a fact that it's
in this document where he talks about
the role of the Federal Government with
regards to mediation and interlocutors
okay so and could we just scroll down a
little bit more please
uh yeah just to and so you're not
talking about the comment there that
came from Chief Peter slowly no keep on
going
now the other way
right here
um question from Rob Stewart can there
be a core group of negotiators from
Ontario Canada Ops to support the
diffusion of this protest in order to
satisfy the political objectives of the
federal government I took that to mean
that he believed that the federal
government had a role to play with
regards to developing a core group of
negotiators
so there's confirmation from my
understanding there's confirmation by
Rob Stewart that the federal government
had a role to play and he also
call celerio there correct yes yes he
does
um and in your response to the nsia if
we could go back to the end on page nine
please
um your your response
um was to refer to the protest and
encampment being a movement against the
federal mandate on trucks and that they
came to Ottawa from across the country
for that purpose in making that comment
Mr Di Tomaso
um were you speaking on your own behalf
or was that Ontario's position at the
time I was speaking on my own behalf so
that was not Ontario's position I was
speaking on my own behalf I did not
consult with the premier or the minister
this was a free-flowing open discussion
and so I did not have an opportunity to
discuss what Ontario's position was
um and you referred in both your
interview summary and your evidence
earlier today to an mou
um between the city of Ottawa and the
federal government with respect to
policing the streets adjacent to the
Parliamentary Precinct yes
um I'm somewhat confused as to what that
mou is you've also testified to your you
know your clear understanding that Ops
is the police of jurisdiction on
Wellington Street and other city streets
around the Parliamentary Precinct right
yes
are you by any chance thinking of the
nation's capital extraordinary policing
costs program
I don't know what it's called I have
been informed that there is an mou
between Public Safety Canada and the
Ottawa Police Service with regards to
provision of policing resources in and
around Parliament Hill that is the
extent of my knowledge I don't know what
the name of the document is and I don't
know what the contents are so if this
memorandum is in existence it's not
something you've ever seen before
correct
um
now you also gave a few reasons why um
and this is in your
interview summary but I believe they
were echoed in your evidence earlier
today
um you say that there were it was open
to the federal government to take a
number of possible uh responses to the
protests you recall that yes
um so one of the
um uh possible responses you raised
there was meeting with protesters yes
yes
um and you
um
uh referred to not only
Deputy Minister Stewart's um interest in
that but also uh OPP inspector Marcel
beauden yes yep
um have you seen Have you listened to a
red inspector bowden's testimony at this
inquiry no
um
well he he certainly has given evidence
that
um there were a variety of challenges to
PLT engagement in the Ottawa protest and
I take it that wouldn't surprise you
given everything you know in your own
policing background it would not
surprise me right for instance extremely
fractured and disorganized leadership
I accept that
um
objectives that were unrealistic
undemocratic
unconstitutional
yes I accept that
the crowd was constantly shifting with
uh new convoys coming and going uh over
the course of the weeks I accept that
you accept those would all be challenges
to
um engaging in a meaningful in a way
that would meaningfully reduce the size
of the of the protests right they would
be challenges yes
if we go to
um
your notes at ont4051
55
page 10 please
down towards the bottom half of the page
keep going
how's there so the second bullet point
as I read it what can feds do from
federal government perspective and then
below that recommend to identify people
to sit down with protesters
six groups
PLT to go to Six groups conditioned to
leave and what does it say after that
denounce
then meeting
so that you understood there were at
least six distinct groups that would
need to be negotiated with in Ottawa
right yes
now
um
we understand from your evidence and
others that on February 11th the
solicitor general provided a letter to
commissioner
karik that was intended to be
distributed to the protesters in Windsor
yes
and that letter
offered a meeting with protest leaders
if
the protest was dispersed they went home
and denounced the protest right yes
um
and you understood that that letter was
unsuccessful it had no impact on the
protest in Windsor right
that was uh my understanding um I did
try to get Deputy Minister Stewart to
sign on to the very same letter I
thought that having ministers from the
two orders of government could have
potentially been more successful I tried
to get Deputy Minister Stewart to
provide the services of federal
ministers he was unsuccessful you're
aware that the protest us group in Auto
in Windsor also had
fractured disorganized leadership
I don't know to what extent okay you
would defer to the critical incident
commander and her evidence on that point
I would
um aware that they similarly had
um
unrealistic or at times different and
confusing demands
I would defer to inspector Bodwin a
leader of the PLT I would defer to the
critical incident Commander I did not
have a direct line of sight on those
protesters
um
and certainly on February 11th when the
provinces offer was rejected
um the critical incident commander in
Windsor considered that any further
efforts at negotiation
um were no longer an option I'm not
aware of what her testimony was and I
did not have any direct contact with her
okay but again you would certainly defer
to her assessment of the situation if
that was her assessment yes
um and then there was the February 13th
exchange of letters between mayor Watson
and um Miss Tamara Leach where there was
an offer by the mayor to meet with
protesters provided that uh
trucks removed out of the residential
streets in Ottawa to Wellington Street
or elsewhere you're aware of that I'm
generally aware I'm not aware I have not
read the letter I'm not aware of the
details but generally aware
and you're aware that that exchange of
letters did not bring any sort of an end
to the protest in Ottawa correct
um
and are you aware that as of February
14th the OPP's own assessment
um was that uh there was
um really no longer
um any path to clearing the protest in
Ottawa through negotiation or any way to
do it with the protesters leaving
voluntarily if you could show me that
assessment I'd appreciate it sure and
it's OPP
four zeros3732
foreign
14th operational intelligence report
have you seen these kinds of reports Mr
di tomesso no okay go down to page 38
please
keep scrolling
there's the assessment heading there
um
and uh if you start to read I will start
to read from the third line down owing
to the scope
nature of the conflict and duration of
the Ottawa Freedom Convoy occupation
there is no clear pathway toward
reaching a satisfactory resolution that
would see the protest group voluntarily
end their action and depart the Ottawa
area
see that yes you would accept that
assessment by the OPP
foreign
yes
so the second reason
that you gave or the second
um response that you suggested that the
federal government could have taken to
deal with the protests
um is to modify the federal vaccine
mandates remember saying that yes
um
and you also understand that at least
some of the protesters were demanding
that all vaccine mandates be dropped
right yes
uh and that would include mandates
um outside the jurisdiction of the
federal government the the veteran
provincial areas of jurisdiction right
yes there was nothing the federal
government could do about those correct
um
and
the government of Ontario would not find
it acceptable to capitulate and change
its policies because a group of
protesters chose to occupy
a city right
I did not have that discussion with the
minister or the
Premier and I'm not in a position to
Define what Ontario's position is on
that issue I would put to to you sir
that Ontario would find that sort of
thing undemocratic and unacceptable
that is the likely position I can't
speak for the Ontario government on that
particular issue
Bolden this kind of behavior whenever
groups disagree with government policy
likely yes right
the third reason reason you gave is that
or the third sorry proposed response
that you suggested the federal
government could have taken was to
provide the necessary resources for a
police response right yes
um and I think we can agree that
um based on your earlier testimony you
accept that the RCMP did that it
provided the resources that were
requested and required right yes
now I understand those all of those
replies were in reference to Jody Thomas
in my interpretation of her comments
that the federal government did not have
a role
and those are those are the things that
we're going through my mind in terms of
the possible options
that the federal government could have
uh considered
understood sir
um
uh so I'd like to go please to um
ont 405152
I understand
okay I got the wrong notes
um let me try that again
uh sorry it's five one five four
um
you attended a meeting uh at the
officials level with the city of Ottawa
and the federal government
um on February 8th remember I believe so
yes these are your notes uh of that
meeting if we scroll down
starting on page two
sorry keep going
it's page four
um
and I I take it sir you understood
um from this meeting in particular that
ministers Blair and Mendocino wanted a
three-way discussion with
Ottawa and the solicitor general yes
yeah if we go to the top of the next
page please
you were advised that the federal
ministers were very focused on three
levels of government coming together
yes I was also aware that the federal
ministers were not focused on
negotiation just a show of collaboration
that show or share
okay thank you
and if we move down to the next
page please
this is an update being provided to the
attendees at the meeting by Peter slowly
and Under The Heading media in next hour
uh
minor children embedded in Red Zone
ability to attack is predicated on
safety of women and children right yes
and so and that would be information
that's troubling to you from a public
safety perspective there were children
yes yes
the federal government did convene
tripartite calls among Ottawa Ontario
and Canada on February 7th 8th and 10th
you're aware yes
um and you've testified that
um Ontario and specifically Minister
Jones was invited to attend
um and didn't do so right
Minister Jones was invited she did not
attend but she was having bilateral
discussions on a frequent basis with
mayor Watson
Minister Mendocino minister bibler
if we could pull up ssm.can .6086
scroll down please
um
and the uh
fourth the fourth bullet there
commitment by Ontario to have Minister
Jones participate in the tripartite
meetings starting today you'll wear
that such a commitment was given
no
and from my perspective evidence we've
seen in some of the uh some of the
evidence here Premier Ford was in
contact with the Prime Minister Minister
Jones was in contact with various
Federal ministers as well
are you aware sir that Premier Ford
himself told Minister Mendocino on
February 9th that he Premier Ford would
tell Minister Jones to participate in
the tripartite table I had no
discussions with Premier Ford
we don't need to pull it up but my
document reference for that is
ssm.nsc.can402832
now you referred to the discussion uh
between the Prime Minister and Mr sorry
Premier Ford on February 9th you said
you did not participate in that call you
did not listen in correct
um but you understand that in that call
both leaders agreed
um uh to that there was a need to work
together uh in resolving these protests
right yes
and you testified about the state of
emergency
um that was declared by Ontario on
February 11th yes
um
and the Ontario definition or the
definition of emergency in
um the Emergency Management and uh civil
protection act in Ontario
um an emergency means a situation or an
impending situation that constitutes a
danger of major proportions that could
result in serious harm to persons or
substantial damage
property
and it goes on from there and it was
your assessment that that definition was
met by February 10th right yes
um let's pull up when
four zeros two two four nine
are you familiar with this report on
Ontario's declared provincial emergency
yes
and if we scroll down to the bottom
please
I think it's all the way on page four
yeah there's a section there on why the
emergency order was necessary and
essential and I take it you agree with
and endorse what's written there right
may I read it please yes sure
yes I agree
um in Ontario's um state of emergency
continued all the way through until
February 23rd right
yes
but but the emergency orders continued
for some period of time
some period of time beyond the 23rd yes
okay
um and do I have it right that this um
the the continued operation of the
orders and the continued state of
emergency
um were because of that continued threat
that you testified that blockades would
reappear the bridge would be blocked
again Etc so to be clear the emergency
ended on the 23rd of February in Ontario
the provincial one the emergency orders
continued because there was a fear yes
okay
um
the um on let's go to OPP four zeros
four five eight zero
these are commissioner karik's texts to
you and again we've established that
commissioner karik is on the right and
you are on the uh
left yes
it would appear from this that
commissioner Creek is green right he's
green because these are his
um texts and I was primarily by text
that he was providing you with these
regular updates on the situation right
yeah with regards to regular update
situational updates primarily by text
but many frequent phone calls as well
okay and if we go to page 98 please how
are you doing for time how am I doing
for time another five minutes if you
don't mind commissioner uh not more yeah
[Applause]
um and this is the end of day status
report that he's giving to you on
February the 12th right this is after
Ontario declared its state of emergency
I'm sorry is it the 12th of February
yeah let's scroll down just so we can
see the date
yes
um in these time stamps um as has been
covered earlier
um are are five hours ahead of Eastern
time because of the UTC you understand
that so it would actually be the 11th
oh am that's right that's late night on
the 11th yes thank you commissioner
um and so this is the day that Ontario
declares its state of emergency and if
we scroll up
um there's protest activity in
um Windsor Blue Water Bridge on the
highway 402 obviously
Ottawa
Toronto Niagara there's activity in
Northwest region if we scroll down
and there's other and
that's among the information that you
were considering when you said things
are escalating State emergencies
appropriate right yes and then if we go
to page 121
we have the update
um again scrolling down
this is uh 2 39 a.m UTC so late night on
the 13th
and I don't won't go through it all but
you understood from this very detailed
report that there was widespread protest
activity not only in Ontario but also
nationally which we see if we scroll
down
correct
yes
and
Mr dichomasso
um you testified that you did not attend
the first ministers meeting that the
prime minister convened with the
provincial and territorial uh leaders on
February 14th right yes
um but uh
we have notes indicating that at that
meeting
Ford stated that he supported the prime
minister with respect to invocation of
the federal emergencies act 100 percent
okay
I'm sure your question my question is
um that wouldn't surprise you that the
premier expressed his full and complete
support for the invocation of the
emergencies act on that meeting it would
not
okay
um
I think I'll
step down there thank you commissioner
for the extra time thank you Mr Di
Tomaso thank you okay next is the
Ottawa Coalition of residents
good day Mr uh
Tomaso my name is Paul champ I'm the
lawyer for the Ottawa Coalition of
residence and businesses
I just want to start by asking some
questions about civilian direction of
police now I gather it's fair to say
that you're very familiar with the
police services act yes
and um
getting into you've told us a number of
times that you thought the entity that
was most responsible for managing or
dealing with the chief of Ottawa Police
would have been the Police Services
Board is that right yes
and um we'd also heard evidence and I
believe you've given this evidence as
well that
um part of the challenge or one of the
problems in uh the Ottawa Police
response to the protest was the absence
of an operational plan that that was a
barrier to deployment of addition
resources is that right well I I just
want to clarify that the operational
plan to dismantle the entire operation
right yes yeah and commissioner Creek
testified the same thing that that was
that they weren't sending all the
resources that Chief souley was was
asking for demanding because they didn't
feel that he had a full operational plan
to dismantle yes and so
um
if you had that information and you
reported that up to the solicitor
general correct
yes that there were concerns there's
number concerns being raised by other
Chiefs of police that there wasn't a
proper operational plan that in the
chief place of Ottawa wasn't doing a
great job yes
now
the chair of the Ottawa Police Services
Board Miss Dean's testified that this
information
that that there was not a proper plan
and that this was leading to a delay in
the deployment of resources was never
communicated to her or the board
uh would you agree that it would have
been important to have that information
conveyed to the Police Services Board
yes
who should have communicated that
Chief slowly
well no but the issue here as I
understand that Mr D tommaso is that
Chief slowly wasn't doing a good job
that he didn't have a proper operational
plan in place and based on all the
evidence we understand he will say or
has been he did testify he thought they
did have a plan but everyone else
thought that he didn't so if there's a
concern about the performance of the
police chief he's not going to say a vet
to the board whose responsibility would
it be to communicate that to the Police
Services Board so they could take the
effective action under section 9 of the
police services Act
so with regards to the performance of
the chief that is the exclusive
jurisdiction of the Police Services
Board and from what I remember of chair
Dean's testifying to was that she was
not getting the information that she
required from Chief slowly it was all
high level and she used other adjectives
to to describe it I think that would
have been an opportunity for her and the
board to further inform themselves
because she had a concern that she was
not getting the information that she
required with regards to operations I'm
glad to hear you're following the
testimony sir because if you were
following the testimony what was going
on was that the chair of the board and
the board was trying to find out
information the chair of the board
testified that she even spoke to deputy
chief Bell to say is there any problems
here that I need to know about would you
be doing anything differently and deputy
chief Bell you know perhaps because he's
reporting Chief Sally says no I wouldn't
have been doing anything differently
that was his testimony that was his
testimony but that was um after uh she
slowly I think there's a context here so
don't mix the timelines so I I don't
think I am I'm not sure if I understand
the objection the objection was
um that is not the timeline that
statement was made uh to
um deputy chief Bell on the eve of um of
uh Chief slowly's departure uh no that's
contrary to the evidence the evidence
was that it was one week before his
resignation not asked for extra time for
that that's an accurate both Miss Dean's
and deputy chief Bell testified it was
one week before the resignation
in any event uh sir
um we'd also heard evidence from the
mayor of Ottawa that he was hearing this
from the solicitor general Jones
presumably you briefed the solicitor
general and she was saying this to the
mayor that there were concerns that the
chief of Ottawa didn't have a good plan
and because of whatever Municipal
politics interpersonal conflicts the
mayor did not communicate that to the
chair of the Police Services Board so
I'd ask you again sir is there any other
meaningful way to try to get that
information to a Police Services Board I
think the mayor has a duty to provide
that information to the chair simply
because
let this go
um Charities testified that she didn't
have the information about the lack of
the plan on the cross-examination
sorry I put Charities initially
testified that she was unaware that
there was no operational plan on
cross-examination I put her witness
summary to her she states in the witness
summary that and it was her that
suggested that one of the reasons that
the resources weren't coming is because
the chief lacked an operational plan so
I think this whole discussion about
Municipal Municipal politics and the
mayor locks foundation and the evidence
and I don't want to mislead the witness
I don't have the transcripts in front of
me so I'll move on
um you would agree with me the Police
Services Board acts independently from
the solicitor general correct yes an
interference or direction from the
solicitor general to a police Service
Board would generally be inappropriate
the solicitor general would have to go
through the Ontario civilian police
commission if they had concerns about
Police Service Support yes but
um
section three also
gives the solicitor general the ability
to
provide advice to Police Service boards
writ large
foreign
from time just for time I'm going to
leave that issue
um I want to ask you some questions sir
about what uh the Convoy protesters and
Ottawa we're protesting about now you've
testified that
you understood that they were testifying
just about the uh the mandates for
truckers having vaccine to cross the
border that's what it was all about and
is to your understanding is that right
that was one of many issues yes
what was my understanding from your your
testimony here today that that it I
think you said something I didn't know
that protests involved provincial
mandates correct okay but there were
many but there were many other issues as
communicated to me by commissioner karik
there were many other groups that had
infiltrated the uh the truckers Convoy
and there were many other agendas at
play there's many other agendas but
let's stick to the ones that have to do
with covid-19 and public health measures
related to covert 19. now does the
federal government have responsibility
over Mass mandates in uh shops and
stores and restaurants and cities
no not uh not in that from that
perspective no that's right those are
provincial mandates our Mass the masks
and stores and so forth that was the
province now we've heard from a few
Convoy organizers who are very upset
about Mass mandates that they planned
and organized protests in Ottawa once
they arrived here by sending large
numbers of unmasked people into Stores
um now that wouldn't have to do with a
federal government mandate would it sir
you know that would be a provincial
mandate and I I presume are you familiar
with the Rideau Center in Ottawa sir not
very well so it's the largest uh Mall in
Ottawa it has we've heard evidence
approximately three million dollars a
day in sales and revenues
um and it was shut down on the first day
of the protest because large numbers of
the Convoy protesters were going in
there unmasked and there was unfortunate
interactions with staff and so forth
were you aware of that
at some point in time I was
so but is it fair to say that um you're
hearing a bit more now and you're
learning a little bit more now that
individuals protesting not were
protesting about more than just the
truck of mandates they're protesting
about provincial government mandates as
well is that fair to say that's fair to
say and is it also fair to say however
that during the time of the process in
February
your understanding was a little bit more
limited you thought the protests in
Ottawa were all about the federal
government mandates not just all about
as I testified to there were other
concerns that the protesters were trying
to communicate so there were other
agendas at Play
but not provincial government mandates
that wasn't what your understanding was
at the time at the very beginning no
very early in the protest one very
well-known Ottawa Resident was trying to
inform the protesters that they were
protesting the wrong thing that uh quote
these mandates are provincial not
federal the mandates if you're mad about
wearing a mask or getting a vaccine go
talk to Premier go talk to Doug Ford the
Prime Minister has nothing to do with
that don't you know anything about
Civics would you agree that if the
protesters were angry about Mass
mandates they should have been
protesting in Queens Park
in provincial mask mandates were one of
the issues that the protesters were
angry about but they were also angry
about the federal vaccine mandate
imposed on January 15 for international
Truckers
now I want to ask you some questions
about uh what you understood about the
the situation on the ground in Ottawa um
you've told us that you understood
um that the protests in Ottawa were an
inconvenience to the people of Ottawa
but it was not a public safety risk is
that right
so I clarified that and I testified that
it was much more than an inconvenience
and
Chief slowly concurred with that
assessment in his conversations with
mayor Watson and ministers Blair and
Mendicino there's a document out there
that I read and he confirmed concurred
with that assessment that it was just an
inconvenience
that it was a nice war and that there
was not any public safety concern
I think you're talking about your
meeting with him uh no not my meeting
he's having a meeting with Minister
Claire he's having a meeting with
Minister Blair Minister Mendicino and
mayor Watson and that is his assessment
now sir uh you were aware that uh Ottawa
was having difficulty enforcing bylaw
bylaws because when bylaw officers went
out to try to give tickets they would be
sworn by hundreds of protesters were you
aware of that yes that that's a public
safety issue is it not yes you were also
aware I gather sir that um
commission council's already asked you a
bit about this about fireworks going off
but did you understand that fireworks
were banging off residential buildings
downtown I did not understand that yeah
around uh where we had propane tanks and
and Jerry cans
I accept that that's not my
understanding that's that's a a
serious public safety risk would you
agree yes
now we've also heard uh that
by the Monday January 31st
right after the first weekend the
position of the Ottawa Police was that
this was an occupation and they did not
have the capacity or resources to bring
that protest to an end would you
understand that that it was that early
that the Ottawa Police felt they didn't
have full control of the situation all
they could do is maintain the peace at
best that was their position yes okay
that was their position but you didn't
agree that was the case
so what was needed to end the occupation
was a fully developed operational plan
to dismantle that was the obstacle
but they
I take your point earlier sir and I
fully agree that we're all very
fortunate that there was no serious
incidents no Bloodshed and the police uh
all police who were responding deserve a
great deal of credit for that
um but you would agree with me that in
that first uh week or two weeks when the
Ottawa Police did not simply have the
numbers there if that situation for some
reason had become uh uh had had uh led
to violence or they'd been riots or
something like that the Ottawa Police
simply did not have the the public order
units to to control that situation that
had occurred would you agree with me had
that occurred uh yes correct but the
Ottawa Police Service was also asking
for resources from the opp and the RCMP
and it is my understanding that the opp
provided each and every or provided
resources to address each and every ask
that Ottawa Police Service made okay
well let's let's get into that now the
the mayor of Ottawa put out a
declaration of State of Emergency on
February 6th you recall that yes and uh
but you didn't review it at the time my
understanding is you just reviewed it in
preparation for this inquiry is that
right the actual declaration yeah
correct you didn't because you didn't
view the situation as that serious at
the time is that fair to say
uh no that is not fair to say it was an
exceptionally serious uh situation uh
when I talked about public safety risk
as I testified to earlier I was talking
about serious violent crime in
accordance with the criminal code that's
what I was referring to but it was
exceptionally serious
well sir is is that perhaps why I didn't
review the the Declaration of
emergencies at the time you thought
Ottawa officials were exaggerating the
problem that they had
you know I didn't think that at all
now uh we know on February the 6th the
solicitor general put out a statement
about Ottawa saying that we're done
everything we can we've given 1500 OPP
officers you're aware of that right
over a period of time from the beginning
yes wow
we've seen the chart and we know how
that number was arrived at but that's
not what the solicitor general put out
on the day she put out we've provided
them with 1500 officers correct no sir
she put out from the very beginning
and I'd like to highlight that phrase
from the very beginning
you did not agree with that number being
put out there is that right
correct uh commissioner Creek also
testified he didn't think it was a good
idea for that number to be put out there
correct uh he communicated that to you I
gather
yes you and he both thought it was a bad
idea for operational numbers of officers
to be communicated publicly yes
um
did uh but neither you nor commissioner
Creek were consulted on that information
being made public is that right correct
did you tell that to the solicitor
general afterwards
I don't believe I did so I guess but
after after chief slowly contacted me I
did have a discussion uh with The
Minister's office about clarifying what
that 1500 number was what it actually
meant right because you're emphasizing
to us about from the very beginning
but uh Chief slowly and quite frankly
the people of Ottawa were
misinterpreting that that it was being
suggested there was 1500 officers on the
ground yes people were misinterpreting
what was said by the minister right
um getting back to my previous question
so have you communicated that you've
never communicated the Social Security
General that you thought it was a bad
idea and perhaps operationally to
communicate that kind of information
I did not
I guess she's learning about your views
on that issue now from your testimony
I don't know and if it wasn't for
operational reasons that that number is
made public is it fair to say that that
number is made public by the solicitor
general for for political considerations
I don't know a Tit for Tat for the mayor
putting out a declaration of emergency I
don't know
let's take a look at uh those letters
now you know about the letter on
February 7th of the mayor and the uh
chair of the Police Services Board
asking the province for 1800 OPP
officers correct 1700 plus 100 civilians
yes yes and
um
incidentally in that letter they say
that the protest is against public
health policies that democratically
elected governments at the provincial
and the federal levels have enacted to
protect us from the deadly covid-19
pandemic so the mayor in case some of
you in Toronto weren't aware the mayor
and the chair were trying to flag to
Toronto that this this protest were
about provincial mandates as well yes
okay did you review that letter when it
came in
um I don't remember I was aware that the
chair and the mayor had made a specific
request for 1700 plus 100 I don't
remember if I reviewed that letter or
not
but I have reviewed it for Testimony
today right and in that letter on
February the 7th the mayor and the chair
were saying that the protest was
threatening the safety of the Ottawa
Community right I accept that they said
uh quote people are living in fear and
are terrified and they've now been
subjected to the non-stop honking of
large trucks for nine days which is town
to mount tantamount to psychological
warfare I accept that uh were you aware
that that's how serious it was at the
time the honking of the horns yes
and they say we need a dramatic and
immediate injunction injection of
additional officers and then they get
into the following resources required on
an urgent basis so that was sent on the
seventh I gathered the solicitor general
would have consulted you on that letter
um I don't remember Consulting with her
or her and I having a discussion about
that suffice to say that that request
went directly to the commissioner of the
opp to make an assessment on the
appropriateness of that number and
whether or not to deploy the resources
so I'll get into that issue in a moment
but I'm just wanting to understand first
about whether you were consulted by the
solicitor general on that issue in the
letter
um I was not my recollection is that her
position was that the request for
resources
um were with the commissioner of the opp
right
um and she wrote to the mayor and the
chair about that on uh February the 10th
three days later do you know why there
was such a delay
I don't and um
there's nothing in the letter about you
know the the honking or the the risk to
safety of Ottawa residents just saying
please note that I have shared your
correspondence with Ontario Provincial
Police Commissioner Thomas Creek uh
thank you again uh for taking the time
to write why did it take the solicitor
general three days just to say she's
passed on the letter to the commissioner
do you know I don't know but I also
wanted to flag what's in that letter is
her Focus that the request was passed on
to the commissioner and she references
the operational plan as well right so
okay well let's turn to that then now
you've told us that in your view it's
the exclusive jurisdiction of the opp
commissioner on how to uh deploy
resources is that right yes
and you're going to have to wrap up your
time is is up so you uh I I with all the
respect commissioner I I don't think so
I think I have 20 minutes unless I'm
mistaken uh you have 20 minutes yep and
you started uh 20 minutes ago
uh may I request five more minutes given
that we don't have the premiere or the
solicitor general here to answer
questions so I'm not sure the absence of
people but I will give you a couple of a
couple of minutes go ahead
foreign
ER I
I just know that was like anyways okay
go ahead I just know that was right on
the dot perhaps of uh 20 minutes it was
and I'm giving you a little more time so
that
it's just there are a lot of people so
I'm trying to
trying to make it uh work I'm sorry but
that's the way it goes
thank you commissioner
now sir you've said it was exclusive
jurisdiction you're familiar with the
Morton report correct yes now in the
Morton report it tells us that
um
policing
and operational decisions about the what
of how they you know or pardon me the
how they execute an operation is
responsibility of the police but the
what of the operation is the
responsibility of Civilian oversight
correct yes and so would you agree with
me or wouldn't you agree with me that
the decision about whether to deploy
resources as a priority to Windsor
versus on versus
Ottawa that's a higher level type of
what decision would you not agree
no
I believe that the deployment of Opp
officers resides exclusively with the
commissioner of the opp
so sir in the Morton report one of the
examples that they use that if there's a
major event and in the planning for it
the the deplete the civilian Police
Services Board which in this case I
gather would be the equivalent of the
solicitor general uh could direct a
police service for example the Toronto
Police Service to prioritize certain
policing
and ask for other resources for other
issues so they could direct the police
about how they prioritize their
resources isn't that the same sort of
thing what's what's the difference
between the how versus the what in this
contest well first of all the Morton
report was with regards to a lot large
planned events this was certainly an
urgent situation it was an emergent
situation and the ability for the opp to
prioritize where to deploy his resources
resides with him that is an operational
decision
you've told us that commissioner Creek
communicated his decision to you based
on his view of the economic impact is
that right one one of the many factors
was the economic impact okay I didn't
hear you say about the other factors and
we'll get leave that to moment because I
don't have time but do you know how the
commissioner assessed the economic
impact I don't because but it was all
over the media at the time media was
reporting on the significant impact on
the economy and the security of both
Ontario and Canada that was all over the
news at the time so uh you're assuming
that the commissioner would have drawn
that from the media
yes that would be one of the sources yes
like we've heard evidence in this
commission about the economic impact of
Ottawa that was approximately uh 200
million dollars at least uh for the just
the first couple of weeks do you have a
sense of what the economic impact was of
the Ambassador Bridge being closed
I've heard uh all sorts of numbers uh
anywhere between 350 million dollars a
day up to 700 million dollars a day but
I think the commissioner also testified
that one of the main considerations
um that that he took into account for
prioritizing the deployment of his
resources to Windsor was the fact that
Ottawa was not yet ready for positive
um action because there was not a fully
developed operational plan to dismantle
Windsor was ready
Ottawa was not that was a key
consideration so I'll just close uh Sir
with this as you're telling us then that
it's uh solely up to the commissioner of
the Ontario Provincial Police to
prioritize the economic impact at The
Ambassador Bridge versus the public
safety of the residents of downtown
Ottawa is that what you're telling us no
sir
what I'm testifying to is that the
deployment of Opp officers reside with
the opp commissioner right so he's the
one that makes the decision whether he
protects the bridge or protects downtown
residents in Ottawa well I think that
he's answered that and that's not a fair
representation of what he said so uh
next I call on uh Council for former
Chief slowly
good evening Deputy good evening
um you worked with uh Chief slowly at
the Toronto police service for many
years right yes and uh in fact you
reported to him for a couple of years
while you were the staff superintendent
and he was Deputy Chief of field command
correct and you enjoyed a relationship
of trust and confidence with him yes
and you knew him to be both a proponent
and expert in community policing
initiatives and also a National Police
leader yes
and when he became Chief in Ottawa you
celebrated him assuming this role saying
you were glad to see his return to
policing correct okay
um and you've also testified that you
were satisfied that the Ops was under
able leadership yes okay
um and I think you've testified that you
watched commissioner karik's evidence
before this inquiry
some of it Summit okay and I just want
to confirm your agreement with
commissioner karik on a couple of things
the commissioner testified that the Ops
did not have the resources they needed
to end the events in their City on their
own right correct and he also testified
that ultimately they needed over 2 000
officers to successfully dismantle the
occupation right yes
and you're aware that the Ops didn't get
those resources at that level until
February 17th
um honor about I I knew that there was a
significant buildup of resources into
Ottawa Police Service right after the
Ambassador Bridge issue was resolved and
so those resources I can't say whether
it was the 17th of February or not but
there was a significant increase leading
up to the positive action on
February the 18th that and I agree with
you on that after the Ambassador Bridge
was cleared uh resources were diverted
back over to Ottawa correct
yes okay and over the next few days the
resources accumulated in Ottawa
yes the the positive action actually
started on the 18th yes that's right
okay
um now
you've testified that commissioner Creek
was your main source of information
about the convoys yes
um and just one thing you testified
um that you're understanding from him
was that the ops's plan uh going into
the first weekend involved keeping the
trucks out of the city
that's what commissioner Creek told me
yes okay
evidence that's now been before the
inquiry
tendon Abrams of the opp
U as of at the very latest January 27th
that the plan was going to be to Stage
trucks within the city
I'm not entirely aware of superintendent
Abram's testimony okay
um fair enough and you were relying
though on the evidence or the not the
evidence but the information of
commissioner Creek yes okay and I take
it you can't assist with any broken
telephone that took place between
members of the opp in that regard I
cannot okay
um and I think it's also fair to say
that regardless you would not have
gotten involved in the operational plan
uh for that first weekend going into
Ottawa into the conversation okay
um if we can pull up OPP four five eight
zero page 29 please
um this is a text between uh you and
commissioner karik on January 29th as of
at 3 P.M so just to orient you this is
the Saturday of the first uh weekend if
we scroll down
sorry Council what was the page number
29 thank you
and if we look at the uh green update
from commissioner karik he's referring
to the fact that there's some aggressive
and threatening
um Behavior no incidence of violence
um and you'll see the second from the
bottom indications are that a number of
demonstrators are planning to remain
until January 31st and that would have
been the Monday right yes okay and so
your understanding from commissioner
Creek at this point would have been that
there could be some people staying until
Monday
right but this was not the first time
that I heard of that possibility right
okay
that this was going to be a long-term
occupation
um I had some of that information
earlier yes that there was a concern
um through intelligent sources that some
elements of the trucker Convoy were
intending on staying much longer than
the weekend I actually saw a tweet
myself to that effect monitoring social
media that the intention of some of
these truckers don't know how many were
to to stay the course yes and that is
absolutely correct there were
indications in the intelligence reports
there were indications in social media
but of course what an intelligence group
has to do is take all of the information
and come up with an overall assessment
right I agree with that okay
um
now you have also given evidence that
after the first weekend you recognize
that what the city of Ottawa was now
facing had turned into an occupation
right yes and you spoke to Chief slowly
and uh solicitor general Jones spoke to
Chief slowly on on February 2nd yes and
these weren't detailed conversations
about the merits of operational plans or
anything like that no okay
um but by the following day February 3rd
you started hearing from commissioner
karik that there were people expressing
some concerns about Chief slowly right
right and and I have to say that all of
the
um concerns that
um commissioner karik
was expressing to me about Chief slowly
there was also the mitigation as well
that he was taking action to either
confirm the reports or to talk to Chief
slowly so I was getting a sense of
comfort that there were significant
dialogue going on between two
exceptional leaders okay I got it and
one of these concerns that there started
to be grumbling about around February
3rd was this perception of a lack of a
plan yes
and you've given very uh careful
evidence about what the commissioner
should understand about this issue that
this is not an issue of a lack of a plan
there was always an operational plan
this is an issue about whether the
dismantling of the occupation plan was
ready to go right correct and that is a
very different plan right yes
um
so
when people didn't leave on the 31st
when you and police leaders and everyone
realized that this was an occupation the
Ops had to Pivot right yes and
they now were facing an occupation
involving a large number of people yes
in an urban environment yes
hundreds of heavy Vehicles yes many of
which has children yes
um this dismantling an occupation of
this nature would be incredibly
complicated I agree and you you
mentioned it involves multiple subplans
Pou traffic Towing Etc right yes
and it's not only complicated at
dismantling an occupation of this nature
is high stakes and high risk I agree and
you don't want an operational plan like
that to be rushed I agree and it is a
huge job to figure out how to dismantle
an occupation of that nature correct
so you as a senior police officer and a
senior police leader yourself
would have understood uh what is
involved in pivoting an operational plan
like that right yes but many members of
the public and politicians would have no
idea is that fair I would agree and they
would look out their windows and see
bouncy castles and fires and say to the
police why aren't you doing anything
I agree and that becomes a very
significant confidence issue for the
police and for the police chief
yes if that perception is out there I
agree yes yeah and that perception was
out there
yes
um
Foley and the Ottawa Police Service at
this time were immense right I agree and
the time pressure was immense as well
right I agree and if we compare this I
don't know if you had any involvement in
G20 in Toronto that may have been after
at your your time there but if we think
compare it you were you did have
involvement okay I did so one of the
things we learned after G20 was that the
four and a half months
that the police service in Toronto had
to prepare was not enough right
that's one thing we learned yes okay for
a planned event yes
and what we're seeing in terms of
grumblings here is three days
after the Police Service had to Pivot
their operational plan to deal with an
occupation right
I'm not sure
um about your reference to three days so
if we look at January 31st yes and we
say okay at this point
what was expected you know some people
might remain until Monday and then we
realize on the 31st no they're they're
sticking around longer right
and so at this point you've agreed with
me the police service has to Pivot right
and and In fairness I think that the opp
was providing
um incredible number of resources
subject subject matter experts as well
to assist the Ottawa Police Service
including the integrated planning team
so that if the planning for such a major
event was outside of the capacity and
capability of the Ottawa Police Service
subject matter experts were in fact
being provided to Ottawa Police Service
to help them out absolutely and the
integrated planning team arrived
February 8th for example
right
I I don't recall I will accept your word
okay so I just want to go back to where
we are in time here
we're pivoting as of January 31st and by
February 3rd there's grumbling about the
lack of an operational plan to dismantle
the entire occupation right yes and you
as a senior police leader know that
that's not fair right
no I I think developing
um an operational plan to dismantle um
one of that magnitude is incredibly
difficult and complex and one requires
time and one requires subject matter
expertise thank you
um now
over the next few days
um
the
uh commissioner karik was updating you
on what he was hearing on the ground and
he passed along other complaints or
concerns that were being expressed about
Chief slowly right yes and things like
there's too many changes in the incident
command
yes my understanding that was that there
were changes to four incident commanders
so certainly that was a concern uh I did
not have the level of detail as to why
that was happening right so without that
detail did I have a concern about that I
did but I didn't have the level of
understanding to know why that was
occurring either exactly or to
understand if that was the chief slowly
issue
at the end of the day the chief is
ultimately responsible for the police
service so I think the buck stops with
him with regards to that
absolutely but for example you wouldn't
have known that one of the changes for
example that was made to incident
command was because of a very difficult
interaction between the deputy one of
the Deputy Chiefs and the Incident
Commander and that she asked that that
be done I I didn't have that information
okay
um and when these complaints
um were passed along to you you
understood that they were third or
fourth hand right commissioner karik
wasn't there in the room
uh I understood that commissioner karik
was getting his information from a
senior OPP officers and other very
reliable sources I don't believe
commissioner Creek was in the room and I
certainly recognized that
uh you know that was hearsay the
information that was coming to me right
okay
[Music]
responsibilities you were briefing at
solicitor general Jones yes and in
fulfilling her responsibilities she was
briefing the premier
yes and we also know that the premier
was expressing his views all the way up
to the prime minister right we saw that
in the readout I did okay
and
I don't want to go in any detail you've
given a lot of evidence about the 1500
in the statement about the 1500
um
that just to be very clear it was the
statement I I've looked at it again and
you're absolutely right it says from the
beginning
um but those still aren't 1500
independent officers right so if if I am
the officer and I work for 10 days I
count as 10.
did you understand that yes okay
um and so and you've given evidence that
you you appreciate why that created
pressure on Chief slowly I do uh when he
was already under incredible pressure
right and because of that you went to
the solicitor general and asked about
making a correction yes and can you tell
us why a correction wasn't made it was
made
um so the correction was
um that the communications officer in
The Minister's office uh clarified in
much greater detail the following day in
response to Media questions that that
number was cumulative so there was an
attempt to dispel the misinterpretation
by having the communications officers
tell the media and anybody that was
asking that that was a cumulative number
and not an indication of 1500 officers
in the Ops on any given day
but just just to be fair the Ops first
corrected it correct and then the the
government got questions about the
correction and then they provided the
further clarification is that fair
I don't know what the order was about
Ops correcting it I'm sorry okay
um
now
there's also the issue of the doubling
of resources and you've given some
evidence about that
um you didn't speak to Chief slowly
about this suggestion that he made a
comment about doubling resources right
um I did not and and quite frankly
um I was not overly concerned about that
issue simply because I knew that the the
ultimate plan to dismantle that would be
tested and validated by the by the
planning team right okay but it did get
past just on to the solicitor general
right yes
and you you said in your evidence you
said if that was accurate and then you
said it made no no difference to the
province right
correct wouldn't the The Province would
continue to support the Ottawa Police
Service right and um and when you say if
that is accurate it's a recognition of
the fact that you're hearing it through
multiple layers right correct
um and you know we've heard evidence for
example that other members deputy chief
Bell who was on the call doesn't recall
it no contemporaneous notes of that
that were you aware of that I was not
aware of Chief belt's um testimony okay
but is it fair to say just it became
part of the picture that people had
about Chief slowly's leadership I can't
say that okay
okay
um now commissioner karik has testified
that any suggestion or concern at the
time that this was a random doubling of
needed resources was completely
incorrect right
I don't know what commissioner Curry
testified to on that issue I'm sorry
well okay that's fair enough but you
also accept uh that we needed the city
of Ottawa needed 2 000 officers
um so any suggestion that 1800 was some
sort of random doubling would not be
fair right
correct
okay
um
you talked about the impact of the fact
that the operational plan to dismantle
um the occupation wasn't ready yet and
that that had an impact on uh the the
passing along of resources to Ottawa
right
correct and
but you've also testified that it made
good sense from your perspective that
this is the kind of plan that would take
time to do properly right yes
and
I suggest that the bigger impact in
terms of the availability of resources
to Ottawa was the fact that those
resources were needed at The Ambassador
Bridge
I'm not entirely sure of that from my
perspective two things if there was a
fully developed operational plan to
dismantle and had all of those other
demonstrations and occupations not
happen elsewhere in the province I think
that Ottawa could have been ready for
positive action much sooner
if the other if the other protests
weren't happening correct okay but given
that we know that the other protests
were happening uh the resources
um and regardless of whose priority it
was whether it was the government's
priority or the OPP's priority the
priority was Windsor right with regards
to the deployment of Opp officers and
and public order unit to the Ambassador
Bridge yes right and you've stated in
your interview summary that the police
could not clear Ambassador Bridge and
clear the occupation in Ottawa at the
same time right correct okay
and
were you did you watch any of
superintendent early from the Windsor
police's evidence I did not okay because
what superintendent early testified was
that the resources were dispatched to
Windsor even before she had a formal uh
operational plan to dismantle that
blockade are you aware of that
um
I knew that there were OPP resources
being provided to Windsor
um
for what purpose I'm not aware
likely it was for maintenance purposes
to make sure that Public Safety was
maintained I don't know when the public
order units were provided to Windsor
with regards to dismantling the entire
blockade okay but if I suggest
were provided for dismantling the
blockade
um even before a plan was finalized that
would be inconsistent with the position
that you need that plan finalized before
the public order units are dispatched
right
uh no I I don't think so because the
footprint in Windsor was much smaller uh
the number of
um protesters was much smaller so an
operational plan uh could have been
developed to dismantle the blockade in
Windsor in a much more timely fashion
because it was not as complicated as it
was in Ottawa so the provision of Pou
officers in Windsor before a fully
developed plan to dismantle Windsor was
completely appropriate okay and and I'm
out of time so I'll just um I'll end it
with this
um
it took um from the time that that she
slowly asked on February 6th for the
1800 officers to uh sufficient officers
being available in the city of Ottawa to
dismantle the operation took from
February 6 to February 17th okay
that's fair yes
um and is it fair that one of the things
that the commissioner can consider in
doing his work is how
resources might be deployed more quickly
and understanding that there were a lot
of competing interests here more quickly
while the very complicated planning
exercise is taking place
that would be one of the considerations
that the opp commissioner could think
about yes okay okay thank you very much
thank you
thank you next uh the Convoy organizers
good evening Deputy Minister good
evening my name is Brendan Miller and I
am counsel for Freedom Corp and I'm a
part of the that which is a entity that
represents the protesters that were in
Ottawa in January and February of 2022.
uh sir I want to start off with
something you had mentioned in your
Chief with respect to Mayor Watson
stating that he invoked the state of
emergency to put pressure on the
province
and you said that uh that seemed to be
political can you didn't get much of a
chance to elaborate on that and I just
wanted to give you a an opportunity I
didn't say it was political what I said
was that section four of the emcpa
um does not allow for a municipal
Declaration of emergency for the purpose
of putting pressure on another order of
government
okay and so that purpose in your view
then uh if it was the true purpose based
on the call
transcript with respect to Mayor Watson
that was not a proper purpose to declare
that if that was the exclusive reason
for declaring a municipal emergency
would not have been proper okay now
I understand and just dealing with this
the background you're familiar with
mayor Watson's background is that fair
what do you mean uh his his history and
and work in
prevent your politics and then the
municipal politics are you I've I've
never met mayor Watson the only thing
that I've learned about mayor Watson was
that he was at one point in time a
provincial Minister I don't know what
portfolio he had okay he held but you're
familiar of course with uh Minister
Blair you used to work with him when he
was at uh the uh Toronto Police Service
I take it yes sir and that was you were
in a superintendent there at the time he
was Chief yes sir right and is it fair
to say and there's a history between
Minister Blair and Premier Ford they
have a very uh very not good
relationship let's say that I can't
speak to that sir when you were at the
Toronto Police Service were you aware at
the conflict that both Minister Blair
and Premier Ford had with one another
commissioner
occlusive for the province of Ontario
I'm not sure the relevance
based on the records that aren't yet in
evidence that I've reviewed over the
last few days it is
I'm not sure what the relevance is as
between the
whether they're they got along or didn't
get along well it appears from the
record sir that part of it was that the
minister was trying to
at times and text messages sir I don't
want to get into it just too far yet but
the relationship between himself and Mr
Ford is referenced in various text
messages not yet in evidence from
Minister Blair sir I want to establish
what that relationship is like if you'd
like me to deal with it directly with
Minister Blair I can hold off I think
that's probably where it's appropriate
given
this witness is not familiar with the it
was simply he was a superintendent uh
during the conflict that arose uh and it
was during the time that now Minister
Blair was the chief of the Toronto
Police Service when he had a conflict
with then Chief Blair when he was a
counselor under the tutors of his
brother who was the mayor at the time
but I can move on uh sir if you I just
thought this witness of course having
been a superintendent at the time would
have that information
I can move on from it
well if I'm you can ask him the question
whether he knows what either of them
were thinking uh right to let that but
yes so sir you're aware that uh going
back to their days is uh Minister Blair
when he was the chief and Doug Ford when
he was City councilor both Minister
Blair and Doug flord had a conflict with
one another at that time and you were
aware of that I can't speak to that okay
thank you
so with respect to your discussed
mediation and the use of politicians in
that regard with respect to a protest
and respect to a blockade and said that
that's how sometimes politicians can be
used
do you want to give some examples of
when that has happened that you've seen
in your experiences both a police
officer as well as in your current
position
so two examples come to mind Minister
Jones made herself available to the
protesters in in Windsor another example
was when Federal Minister Mark Miller
made himself available to the blockade
the CN real blockade in January of 2020
in an attempt to mediate and negotiate
right and I take it that a lot of that
uh happens in coordination with the
relevant Police Service of the
jurisdiction they actually make a
request that some of the political
executive branch come and attend and
help assist them quell the issue is that
fair as to where it ought to happen it
did not happen that way in January of
2020.
January of 2020 uh or 2022 in January of
2020 when Minister Mark Miller
made himself available to negotiate the
CN blockade okay and so that was outside
of uh he did that outside of police
advice is that what you're saying I'm
saying that he did that without
consulting the opp oh okay so in this
case I take it now we've heard an
evidence that OPP uh inspector Boudoir
who's uh in essentially doing all the
PLT work he was putting forth a plan of
PLT that would involve uh either someone
from the federal government provincial
government I don't think he really cared
who it was as long as it was effective
if the inspector had asked your
government for assistance based on your
knowledge uh would one of the Executive
Branch the political executive Branson
has elected members uh being ministers
would they have participated in that yes
and from your understanding despite uh
inspector boudoir's request of the
federal elected executive do you have
any knowledge of the political branch of
the Federal Executive despite uh or upon
his request from inspector Bulldog
agreeing to do the same
no I had discussions with Deputy
Minister Stewart about getting Federal
ministers to the table and Minister I'm
sorry Deputy Minister Stewart was not
successful okay but your
government was willing and able to do
that if was asked I know for a fact that
Minister Jones was yes right and I just
want to deal with a little uh spend my
last point in time and to clarify both
for the public and I know that you've I
think been the first witness here to
make this very clear and I think it's
worth emphasizing
um when it comes to policing in this
entire country
police are supposed to be 100 percent
independent
of the political branch is that fair
when it comes to investigations
deployment operations yes right and so
just because a mayor just because a
prime minister just because the minister
of emergency preparedness or a premier
wants them to do something
that's not supposed to have an effect on
their decisions they have to assess them
themselves and they don't follow
essentially directions from elected
government they're independent
correct with regards to operations and
deployment and investigations yes and
one of the reasons that's the case is is
that you don't want police who have
probably the most power out of any
officials in the country domestically
you don't want them to do things for
political reasons right correct right in
your opinion in looking at the facts as
you know it as a deputy Minister as a
former police officer in your view was
this situation politicalized
I know that there were many politicians
that were involved in discussions that
it was an urgent situation
and so many politicians expressed their
views publicly
and did that undermine police
enforcement and police tactics and
police decisions
uh no I don't think so I think the
commissioner and I certainly the
commissioner were focused on providing
the resources that Ottawa needed to
dismantle the entire occupation so from
my perspective all of that was noise the
commissioner was focused on providing
those resources subject to a fully
developed operational plan to dismantle
the entire occupation did any of the
conduct of the federal political branch
that is the elected ministers and prime
minister did any of their statements in
the media and to the public at large
create any issues for the police dealing
with the situation
that would be a question for the police
that we're dealing with the issue I'm
sorry thank you thank you
okay next uh if I could call on the ccla
good evening Mr D Tomaso my name is Eva
kravska I'm Council for the Canadian
civil liberties Association hello
uh let me pick up from a point that my
friend was just speaking to you about uh
civilian oversight of the police I
understand from your testimony Mr
ditamaso that you're familiar of the
Morden report arising after the G20 yes
and that's built upon the ipper wash
inquiry and previously from the
McDonald's Commission
I wasn't aware that it was built upon
the two other reports that are
relevant to the issue of Civilian
oversight are the report after the ipper
wash inquiry and the McDonald's
Commission
um okay
all right well let's stick to the modern
report then
um and Sir as my friend told you the
independence of the police is uh
quintessential with respect to uh
criminal investigation correct correct
because we do not want uh it would be an
infringement of the rule of law to have
uh politicians direct criminal
investigation I agree but with respect
to
um operational decisions I I'd suggest
to you that civilian oversight is a
little bit more nuanced from the modern
report
and on the first point that there is a
role for civilian oversight in with
respect to the receipt of information
with respect to operational decisions I
agree and commissioner karik was
discharging that Duty by supplying you
with information with respect to his
operational decisions correct
and uh similarly
um it is possible and it is possible for
um for civilian oversight to provide
opinions and make suggestions with
respect to operational decisions that is
a specific recommendation in the Morden
report yes and that and that it that is
the Morton's reports
um qualification to section 31-4 of the
police act correct that's its
interpretation of that section
I I won't fight you on that okay I
accept that all right and and that is
especially important uh to provide those
suggestions or opinions on operational
plans to ensure that they're consistent
with legal requirements and Community
norms and values
and board policies and board objectives
yes thank you sir
um now sir we've reviewed a number of
your handwritten notes uh that uh arise
out of uh
the uh the facts that we're reviewing uh
of this commission and I just want to
get a sense of of your notes taking
practice
um do you do you essentially take notes
of all of your telephone calls and
meetings no okay so this is a selection
of notes that you had arising from these
events right this was a major event and
I reverted to my past practice as a
police officer and taking as many notes
contemporaneously as I possibly could
there are and certainly there are gaps I
did not record each and every discussion
that I had I simply didn't have that
capacity
okay thank you and so
um if you had report if you had been
providing reports to the solicitor
general there may not be notes of those
reports even if you provide you may not
be notes of those even though you
provided those reports correct and was
what was your practice with reporting to
the solicitor general with respect to
these events would you have been at the
beginning of these events would you have
which was she asking you to report to
her daily on the events
so the practice was with regards to the
Daily situational reports that were
coming in to me from commissioner Creek
I would do a copy and paste and send the
same text message to the minister by
text message yes
and and what she scheduled calls with
you if she had follows up or questions
with respect to commissioner karik's
reports yes
um and
uh
and you would also have meetings with
her in person and I assumed by telephone
correct but you would not necessarily
take notes of those discussions correct
thank you
um and if I understand your evidence at
the beginning of these events
uh your view your characterization of
them was that this was a a police issue
that required the correct deployment of
police resources correct and you did not
see this as necessarily A a political
issue
and that would be fair however there was
a role for ministers and politicians to
play with regards to exploring possible
solutions the art of the possible as you
yes as you stated okay
and would it be fair now
you had a number of discussions with
Deputy Minister Stuart at the federal
level correct yes and those were kind of
uh at the at the bureaucracy level of
discussions yes and is it fair to say
that you got the sense from him that the
federal political level was frustrated
that there was not more engagement from
the Ontario provincial level yes
okay and in my review of the documents
it appears that uh the political
engagement from Ontario appeared to
shift around February 9th would that be
fair
um
no
um I know that Minister Jones and the
premier were certainly engaged in many
bilateral conversations
throughout this entire period so when
when do you feel like the provincial
government became more involved at a
political at a political level at what
point in time
I I can't determine that because I was
not privy to those conversations I knew
that both Premier Ford and Minister
Jones were having many bilateral
conversations with a whole host of
people
okay would you you may not be aware but
would you be aware that for example
Minister Al gabra on Transportation was
was not able to book telephone calls
with Minister malarone I was not aware
of that
and the reason that I suggest that
February 9th may be a pivot point is
that that is when Premier Ford has a
telephone call with Minister Mendocino
where Premier Ford suggests that he may
he's spoken to the chief medical officer
of health and he may take down vaccine
passports were you aware of that I was
not okay
and you'd agree with me that at least by
February 10th uh the solicitor general
had informed you that there was
consideration of invoking the Ontario
emergencies Act
the empca
Premier Ford signaled his intention to
declare a provincial emergency on or
about the 10th
would it be fair to say that the
political level in Ontario became more
engaged when the Windsor bridge the
Ambassador Bridge was was blocked and it
was causing significant economic
repercussions with respect to
manufacturing and trade that would not
be fair no
and so with respect to the emergencies
orders if I can
if I can ask the registrar to please
um pull up
um
doc ID
on ont405155
so that's the last page of this document
so these are your notes from February 10
2022 and on the last page of these which
is page so I page 19 not 20 sorry
um there's a star and uh solicitor
general is lead department on this issue
emergency at our borders line waiting
for direction thinking about EO list of
seven not doing anything until more
Direction what does list of seven is
that list of seven or am I risk reading
that I don't know what that references
I'm sorry okay but would it be fair that
as at February 10th your ministry was
being tasked with considering what
potential orders you think should be uh
made under the empca yes okay and uh sir
you're familiar with the legal
requirements to invoke the empca yes and
you'd agree that any orders that are
made under the empca must be necessary
and essential in the circumstances yes
and they have to be tailored to be
Charter compliant as well correct and so
they have to be the least restrictive
possible in terms of the uh in terms of
their impact on Charter rights of of
ontarians yes and that was something
that you considered and your ministry
considered in drafting the enpca orders
that were enacted yes
and so just going going back
um in January of of 2022 if we go back
there were significant provincial
mandates under the reopening Ontario act
that were in place in January 2022 as a
result of the Omicron wave you remember
that yes and Ontario had been placed
back into kind of stage two of the
reopening Act
at that time
I I'm I'm sorry I'm not prepared to
speak on that I I have not reviewed any
notes or any material so I'm
not prepared to speak on that I'm sorry
okay uh let me let me make it simple
under the reopening act there were three
stages of opening that were available to
for the cabinet to place uh to place the
various uh Health units in depending on
the severity of the pandemic in that
health unit
foreign
I can't help you there I'm sorry I'm I'm
not prepared okay
um if I can just ask you under the
reopening Ontario act some of the
measures that were put put in place
included vaccine passports
I believe so Mass mandates yes capacity
limits yes
um
school closures
yes
and you I understand from your evidence
that despite what the note says from
February 6th in response to miss Jody
Thomas and the at the nsaia that you
understood that some of the protests
that were happening in both Ottawa and
Windsor related not just to the federal
vaccine mandate but to Public Health
measures much more generally that was my
evidence yes
thank you sir those are all my questions
next if I could call on the CCF please
uh good evening Mr Tomaso my name is
sujit Chaudhary I am
uh Council for the Canadian Constitution
Foundation
um I'd like to pick up on a line of
questions that my friend uh Ms Rodriguez
uh LED regarding intergovernmental
processes
uh for uh coordinating Federal
provincial and Municipal responses uh to
the Convoy and I want to put it to you
that the reason why she spent so much
time on that theme and why I'd like to
go back to that theme is that that issue
goes to the very heart
of this commission's mandate
and so sir do you know
that the emergencies Act is a last
resort
that's my general understanding yes and
that the last resort requirement is
actually a legal condition
for the federal cabinet to declare a
public order emergency so I'm not an
expert on the emergency act but that's
my general understanding and so and so
and and isn't it true then if the ACT is
meant to be a last resort
Municipal provincial and federal legal
tools have to somehow fall short
so so that's that's a legal question uh
I'm not prepared to answer that I'm
sorry but are you prepared to answer
this question that sometimes for tools
in the hands of one government to be
effective
those governments must cooperate to use
their tools together
I'm not sure how to answer that sir well
let's talk about this Convoy
and so um what we're trying to
understand here in this commission is
whether these intergovernmental
processes to get governments to work
together
to use the different tools they have
worked or didn't work and that's why we
want to learn about these meetings and
these conversations that you had so it's
true that you had many conversations
with diff with representatives of
different levels of government isn't it
yes and it's true that you participated
in a February 6th meeting yes uh and and
other meetings yes uh and and so and is
it true
uh that your role uh in these meetings
and I'm quoting it here uh was to um was
to receive information
yes and to put forward possible
solutions to the blockade in Windsor and
the occupation in Ottawa that could be
achieved or facilitated by Ontario
correct so you were on those calls and
at those meetings to see how Ontario
could help yes
and so and would you also agree
that one of the fundamental purposes of
those calls and those meetings was that
every level of government had different
information
and a and the purpose of conversation
and communication was that no one
government had the complete picture but
only by discussing with each other and
exchanging information could the big
could the complete picture come into
Focus I would agree with that and so and
and then with the complete picture in
hand
governments could connect the dots
between problems and issues on the one
hand and Solutions on the other
I agree with that including solutions
that could be achieved or facilitated by
the province of Ontario right but those
discussions were in fact happening they
may not have been at the formal
tripartite tripartite tables at the
federal level with politicians but they
were happening bilaterally so there was
an exchange of information going on well
let's talk about the tripartite meetings
because that's where I'm going to so
we've there've been a number of
questions put to you
about the tripartite meetings at the
most senior political levels although
there were Deputy level civil servants
there yes
um that took place on February 7th 8th
and 10th and I'd like to call up if Mr
registrar if you would
ssm.nsc.can
dot four zeros
2052 underscore Rel dot zero zero one or
that those are the that's the
um readout from the February 8th
tripartite call
so some um
sir so you've been asked questions about
these notes
before
um I'd like to take you to
um two parts of the notes for this call
or the readout so Chief slowly
participated in this call and so if we
could go please Mr registrar to the
bottom of page two
stop there and so uh sir do you see
there
um a question posed by mm that's
Minister Mendocino
saying do you see Wellington Red Zone
being tackled within two to three days
and then Chief slowly responds
and so there's a reference there to a
Wellington Red Zone so I'd put it to you
that that is a no-go Zone
on Wellington Street
that Chief slowly was proposing a no-go
Zone I don't know what Chief slowly was
proposing okay but but you what do you
think the term Red Zone means on
Wellington in the context of the
protests that were taking place in
Ottawa I don't know what Chiefs
following means by Red Zone sir sure but
if you'd had been at the meeting you
might have known to ask correct
I was not invited to the meeting but
Minister Jones was invited to the
meeting she'd been at the meeting she
did she would have known to ask correct
I was not invited to the meeting and so
I did not attend let's go down to the
next page
so three quarters of the way down
if you could go down a little bit more
there's a bold there under the long
paragraph from Chief slowly a reference
to an impound Zone
now sir what do you think an impound
Zone refers to
it appears that she slowly is uh
talking about a Zone where Vehicles can
be impounded and towed from good
so now
um in your you said that prior to the
February 6th call
you familiarized yourself with the
Emergency Management and civil
protection act correct yes uh and uh and
so you said in your interview summary
that the city of Ottawa did not make a
formal request for Premier 4 to declare
a provincial state of emergency is that
right yes but isn't it true
that a no such request by a mayor is
required
as a matter of law
under the emcpa for the premier to
declare a state of emergency in any City
in this province correct
so are you aware
that under the emcpa the provincial
cabinet wants a state of emergency has
been declared
can regulate or prohibit travel or
movement to
from or within any specified area and
that's what they did and are you aware
that um they can that the provincial
cabinet can evacuate individuals
and remove personal property from any
specified area
right but that was not an applicable
section for this particular emergency
and why is that can you uh put up the
EMC it's uh so Mr registrar at CCF
six zeros 38.
and it's page seven
Mr De Tomaso I believe you're referring
to point three at the top of the page
there yes I am and could you explain
could you please elaborate on your
answer sure so uh with regards to
evacuating individuals and animals and
removing personal property uh for many
specified area
evacuating individuals from my
understanding pertains to invoking that
Authority when there is a large natural
disaster impacting the health and safety
of of people and so taking uh and making
arrangements for the adequate care and
protection of individuals and property
that does not apply to the current
situation interesting so you don't think
it would it would it would extend to
removing individuals and their personal
effects from an area while evacuating in
my view has a very specific meaning I
don't think it is applicable at all well
and I can tell you sir that in drafting
these emergency orders
uh legal departments from the ministry
of the Attorney General solgen cabinet
office primer's office the Ministry of
Transportation War all engaged and had
that been a section that could have been
leveraged it would have been the opinion
of the legal department from all of
those Ministries was that that
particular section was not applicable to
the situation
Mr tabasso would you agree
that when the provincial cabinet
exercises its powers
under this provision of the emcpa it's
not trenching on the authority of the
opp or the Ops over policing
correct
and would you agree
that the provincial cabinet could have
used these powers to create a Red Zone
on Wellington
what do you mean by a redstone a Zone in
which there could be no vehicles
illegally parked in which all vehicles
would be cleared and we're all no
persons could go
well that in fact was done by the
emergency order sir but but do you agree
that it could have been done by the
provincial cabinet
it was done by the provincial cabinet
sir
the Red Zone sir was created by the
emergency emergency measures regulation
under the emergency act no no sir
um the the prohibition to block any
roadway or walkway and the Ingress and
egress was something that was
specifically done in the provincial
emergency order so blocking impeding
egress and Ingress into any Highway and
walkway was something that was done by
the emergency order in the province of
Ontario well well let's we'll return to
that
um would you agree that the provincial
cabinet could have used these powers to
create an impound Zone
so um
I think that point would have been Moot
and I say that because the problem was
already there it was already defined
the problem was these large heavy trucks
in a defined area and what the
provincial cabinet did was give
substantial authority to remove those
trucks to impound and seize those trucks
and hold them until the emergency orders
were no longer in place so so Mr Di
Tomaso
um Minister Jones was not on the call
on February 8th when the Wellington Red
Zone and the impound Zone were presented
for discussion
at this intergovernmental table was she
she was not and had she been
on that call
on February 8th I isn't it reasonable to
conclude that she would have connected
the dots
between the red zone
and the impound Zone and the powers at
the provincial cabinet would have
if it were had declared a state of
emergency under provincial law
Province did declare a state of
emergency under provincial law that
wasn't my question
had she been on that call
on February 8th would she have connected
the dots
between the problem that was at hand and
the tools in within the jurisdiction of
the province I think Minister Jones was
well aware of what the problem was
without
without attending that call she was well
aware of what the problem was and and Mr
D tommaso there were deputies on that
call yes
um if you had been asked to attend that
call
uh and you had been there to receive
Chief slowly's ideas
uh and would you have connected the dots
between what he was proposing in terms
of a red zone and an impound Zone
and the potential to use the province's
emergency powers to implement those
proposals the provincial emergency
orders dealt with the red zone and the
impound Zone they did they provided
prohibitions against Ingress and egress
and blocking highways and and walkways
and they provided police with the
ability to seize vehicles within that
zone there so in effect it did create
both I was asking about you sir did you
ever make that recommendation to
minister Jones to create those zones
yourself
yes or no
they were created but did you recommend
the issue sir the issue sir was
addressed in the emergency orders
the issue was addressed
Mr commissioner I think I think we're
done here okay thank you thank you uh
next is the Ottawa Police Service
good evening Mr Di Tomaso my name is
David mijikovsky I'm a lawyer for the
Ottawa Police Service
I understand
um that you have um some oversight of
the opp that falls within your sphere of
responsibility yes and in that regard
you received regular reports from
commissioner Carrick yes and another
person who reported to you was Chris
Letang the provincial security advisor
at the ministry of the solicitor general
yes and I assume he has access in that
position he obviously has access to
intelligence information from the opp
and others yes
and it's important that he get you
reliable information and uh and timely
information yes and in fact he did
satisfy you in that regard in terms of
the information he provided to you
he was providing me with the information
that he was in receipt of right and he
and you were satisfied with the quality
of the information he was generally
speaking yes and so if we could please
call up uh opp405099
could you confirm that document ID
please uh OPP four zeros
5099
having difficulty locating that one uh
could you tell me what sort of document
um it is a report from uh Chris Letang
the provincial security advisor
of January uh 21st or 22nd I believe
would it be possible to spell his last
name
um l-a-t-a-n-g I'll move on and in the
meantime
um if I could ask you um instead to call
up uh ont
405126
thank you very much uh that's a uh one
of the reports that Mr Letang was
providing to you and those are being
provided on a regular basis yes and so
if we could just scroll down to the
bottom of page one please
you'll see that the report
um is the assessment is currently there
is no specific identified threat and
monitoring remains attuned and then just
below that you'll see Freedom uh Convoy
if you could just turn to the next page
please
and so um you'll see that there is
reference
um
in the uh the those paragraphs uh to the
protest disrupting the movement of
vehicular traffic correct
yes and the disruption of vehicular
traffic is not in itself a basis to stop
a protest is it I agree
and some vehicular disruption is
obviously going to be expected and
tolerated correct
I agree and if we could look at the
third page please
a page three please
thank you
um the second paragraph uh at this point
uh the um and this is January 25th just
so you're aware the uh second paragraph
says that the Convoy organizers have
repeatedly stated the intention to
conduct a lawful protest and there's a
Code of Conduct you see that yes and
then we see in the next paragraph that
the number and it's bolded that the
number of participants and supporters
who may participate uh is unknown at
this point
yes and there's no indication
um in this report that overall the
Convoy will engage in assault of
behavior or widespread anti-social
Behavior or bylaw offenses nothing like
that correct
I haven't read this entire report but I
accept your word okay and so similarly I
didn't see any indication that the
protesters would become a long-term
occupation if we could please go to the
next one which is OPP 405127
foreign
my guess is it must be ont five one I'm
sorry did I not say that I apologize is
it a strategic update yes I apologize
for that thank you for catching that
and so that's another report on January
26 and you'll see on page one if we just
scroll down
uh the first paragraph again there's no
specific identified threat
correct correct
and if you look at um the first bullet
under uh National Convoy
yes uh you'll see uh that an accurate
estimate was complicated by the number
of non-convoy vehicles in the area
correct yes
and if you go to page two
uh and you go to the first bullet on
page two
you'll see the last sentence the
organizers have repeatedly continued to
urge for a peaceful demonstration
I'm sorry where is that sir uh the last
sentence in the first bullet
yes
and if we go to page three
under the uh
assessment if you could just scroll up
please
oh sorry assessment starts on page two
and then if you go to page three the
third paragraph the third paragraph
again no identified threat with regard
to the freedom Convoy protest
and there's no reference at this point
to the Convoy staying long term and
becoming an occupation is it no I no
you're correct I'm I believe the first
indication in these reports that there
would be a longer term uh stay was on
the 27th right and so the 27th is in
fact the day uh before they arrive
correct that's on the Thursday and the
Convoy is arriving on the Friday correct
correct
Council sorry to interrupt I have your
first document that I couldn't find uh
that that's okay
um I'll I'll move on
and you're aware that many of the um
many of the um Convoy were traveling on
400 series highways policed by the OPP
yes and there was uh you're aware no
Direction given or any discussion with
the opp about whether to divert them or
stop them from coming into Ottawa based
on the information that was available at
the time correct there were no grounds
to stop or divert no
and if we go to ont405126
which is Mr Tang's report that we
previously looked at of January 25th
on page two
the third bullet
uh you'll see that uh reports from RCMP
in Manitoba indicate that Convoy
participants were upset as a result of
having been directed to weigh scales and
having been issued uh HTA infractions
and
um some online messaging suggests that
those who are an intentional tactic by
police to disrupt the protest and so OPP
information is that the way scales in
Ontario will be closed correct yes and
so Ontario wasn't trying to disrupt the
convoys arrival and in fact the opp
actually ushered them into Ottawa did
they not
um I wouldn't say the word ushered
um they certainly facilitated the right
to Peaceful protests and my
understanding was that the opp did not
have any grounds to stop or divert
generally speaking there may have been a
reason to do that on an individual basis
but generally speaking there was not a
right to uh to do that and um if we
could please go to ont405303
thank you
that is a text series of text messages
from commissioner karik to you and I'm
just giving you that page to see that
it's January 29th uh so that would be on
the Saturday yes and then if you scroll
down to the bottom of that page and then
go up to the uh uh
you'll see the um then go to the next
one which is uh ont 5304 I simply gave
you that so you would see the date uh so
if you could please go to uh ont405304
and if you go to the fifth bullet
and so this is the report you're getting
on the 29th from commissioner Kari and
he's now telling you that a number of
demonstrators are planning to remain
until the 31st of January so that's the
Monday correct yes
and so you agree with me that the
information you're getting from the
provincial security uh advisor uh does
not forecast what turned out to become
an occupation for three weeks in Ottawa
with the kind of behavior that we
ultimately saw correct
uh I would not say that I know that
there was a report from the provincial
security advisor on the 27th that
indicated that some elements of the
Convoy uh were going to be staying
longer than the weekend there was
information on the 27th from the
provincial security advisor
that one of the reasons
why the truckers were there was to get
rid of the federal Trucking I'm sorry
Federal vaccine mandate on truckers and
that they would not be leaving until
that demand was met
um well let's let's go and look at that
assessment on the 27th please it's a ont
405128
and if you go to the assessment section
on page three
so what we see is that and this is um
bear in mind the 27th so it's the
Thursday so what we see is the second
sentence uh
once in Ottawa some Convoy organizers
have stated an intent to remain at
Parliament Hill until the federal
government concedes to repeal all
coveted Health restrictions and mandates
correct yes so we don't see any
indication of the number
how many
correct we also don't see any indication
that they're in going to engage in the
kind of behavior that they ultimately
did engage incorrect
well can I give me a second to read this
please
so there's talk about disruptions that
may gridlock areas around Parliament
buildings and other parts of Ottawa so
that part of it is in there in the
assessment okay
there is no Express departure date for
participants or a clear timing of when
actions may end and that's in there
of an unknown number of people correct
correct but there's also information
here that some supporters may attempt to
disrupt businesses of government by
holding events at or near City Hall's
provincial government facilities Etc so
that did in fact happen well you're
aware sir that Parliament continued to
set the municipal government continue to
operate throughout that period correct
and there were significant disruption to
business yes I'm aware of that
another office in the provincial
government that monitored both Ottawa
Toronto Windsor was the emergency
management office yes and I understand
from January 28th to February 21st they
produced multiple briefing notes every
day and sometimes multiple times a day
right and the the flow the information
that the provincial I'm sorry the
emergency management office had was
primarily from Municipal sources
I think you're out of your time so two
more minutes thank you
you would agree with me I take it
um Mr dito maso that if um
trucks if the Convoy was coming in or if
there were trucks on the 400 series of
Highways uh in which uh there was
information that the opp had uh that
there were bombs and that those bombs
were going to be detonated in Ottawa you
would expect that the opp would do
something to stop those convoys from
coming into the city correct
I'm not aware of any information
indicating that there were bombs on
these trucks I I appreciate that I'm
giving you a hypothetical if you had
such information presumably as the
person who has oversight uh who has some
oversight you'd be concerned if the opp
allowed those vehicles to come into the
city
certainly there would be a concern if
the opp knew a particular truck had a
bomb and permitted it into the city yes
that would be a concern and similarly
you would uh expect that if the opp had
knowledge that uh the Convoy was going
to engage in the kind of disruptive and
anti-social Behavior they did engage in
you would have expected that they would
not have allowed it to come into Ottawa
Fair
I think the opp was also Duty bound to
respect the Charter of Rights and
Freedom which gives protesters the right
to protest and and assemble and so you
would not have expected that they would
stop the Convoy correct thank you very
much I have no additional questions
okay next uh the Ontario Provincial
Police
for the opp no questions commissioner
thank you
The Windsor Police Service
I'm here commissioner I'm just having
trouble starting my video
thank you uh
good evening Mr D tommaso could I please
uh my name is Tom McCrary and I am
acting for the Windsor Police Service uh
could I please ask uh Mr clerk that you
go to uh Mr D Tomaso's witness statement
which is uh three six zeros pardon me
41.
if you could go to page seven please I'd
be grateful
as I and I'm starting right here after
requests for assistance and policing
jurisdiction
um I'm sorry where are you where are you
at I'm sorry there's a heading on oh
please scroll down Mr Clerk and we can't
see there it is there it is sorry
requests for assistance and policing
jurisdiction
uh Mr D Tomaso explained that the police
services act sets out how Municipal
Police Services are to make requests for
assistance pursuant to section nine can
you slow down a bit for the interpreters
please
uh which applies when the chief of
police is of the opinion that an
emergency exists in the municipality
um Mr clerk could you please go now to
um commission document
50819 this should be if I got my number
right
um the police services Act
if you could scroll down to section 9
which is I think about seven pages in
okay sorry I'm wrong down some more
please
a little more uh okay we're getting
there
uh yes
could you go down to
um go down scroll down a little more
please
uh
if I can draw your attention Mr D Tomaso
to a sub paragraph six of that uh
section 9 of the police services Act is
that the subsection of section nine that
you were referring to in the first
sentence of the paragraph your witness
statement we just went to yes
uh is it correct that there is no
requirement in the police services act
that this request must be given in
writing
I agree
and if I can take your attention to the
next subsection it says a chief of
police who makes a request under
subsection 6 shall advise the chair of
the board of the fact as soon as
possible yes
uh is it sir that this subsection
contemplates an emergency which is so
vital that
the chief of police would speak to the
commissioner before he speaks to the
chair of the board
yes
and in fact in those circumstances it
would be unreasonable or unnecessary for
the initial request to be put into
writing
I agree
yeah thank you
we've heard evidence within this
commission hearing about requests that
have been made to the opp in just by
speaking with them on the phone and the
opp has responded with
PLT service or other Frontline officers
is that the ordinary course of contact
for the opp
well I can't speak for the opp in terms
of the way in which they receive
requests but I would generally agree
with you
okay thank you those are my questions
thank you next I'd like to call on the
city of winter
you still okay
good evening Mr tommaso my name is
Jennifer King I'm counsel to the city of
Windsor hello hello
mayor dillkins of the city of Windsor
testified on Monday that he had at least
one conversation with the solicitor
general during the blockade of the
Ambassador Bridge
were you present during these calls no
were you aware of these calls
generally speaking okay what do the
solicitor general or her office do in
response to her call or calls with mayor
dillkins
you'd have to tell me what the nature of
the conversation was before I can
respond well were you aware of the
nature of the conversation no okay
and I'll just move on you testified that
you consulted with commissioner karik on
the emergency declaration and measures
correct yes did you consult with Windsor
or the Windsor Police Service to
determine what tools they may need to
more effectively resolve issues in
Windsor
not to my knowledge okay
you agree that the blockade of the
bridge the Ambassador Bridge impacted
people's livelihoods not only in Windsor
Essex region but also throughout the
province of Ontario yes
you acknowledge in your testimony today
that the impact of the Ambassador Bridge
blockade on the economy of Canada and
Ontario was apparent right yes could you
go a little slower again please yes and
it was apparent how important the
crossing is to Canada and Ontario it was
all over mainstream media yes so you
would agree with me then that the
provincial Federal and of course
Windsor's efforts and resources expended
to clear the blockade and protect the
bridge from the return of a blockade
benefited the entire province
yes
earlier this evening you talked about
the importance of a coordinated response
at all levels of government right yes
I'm not going to bring up the letter in
the interest of time and the time of day
but there is a letter from mayor dilkins
of Windsor to the solicitor general
Minister Minister Mendocino and Minister
Blair are you aware of that letter from
March
well then I will ask the clerk to bring
it up it's win four zeros2240.
so as I said this is a letter in March
that is to the solicitor general and
others and I take it you were not aware
of the letter no it was not raised to
your attention
no okay
and if you could just go to the second
page please
you'll see here the second full
paragraph last sentence
mayor dillikin writes that it is
apparent
or the need for broader collaboration
and support from provincial and federal
governments to bolster the Safety and
Security of our borders appears obvious
would you agree with mayor dilkins
foreign
yes
mayor dilkins goes on to request a
meeting to debrief emergency regulatory
obligations regarding the Ambassador
Bridge
did you discuss the mayor's request for
a meeting at the time with the solicitor
general
I was not aware of this letter
okay
the mayor has testified that he did not
receive a response to this letter
can you tell me now is the Minister of
this uh of the solicitor general willing
to meet with Windsor other Ministries at
the provincial level and federal
representatives to discuss long-term
needs and planning to protect Windsor's
International Crossings I have not
spoken to the current Minister about
this issue
okay
as of February 2022 Emergency Management
was your responsibility as part of the
Public Safety Division of communities
sure as of what date February of this
year yes and you were the commissioner
of Emergency Management yes
and you'll agree that Ontario like all
jurisdictions in Canada uses a bottom-up
approach to Emergency Management correct
used a what approach bottom-up approach
I don't know what that means okay this
means that municipalities are generally
responsible for managing most
emergencies correct
local authorities are the front lines of
Emergency Response yes
emcpa requires that each municipality
prepare and adopt its own emergency
response plan correct yes
and in your experience I take it the
Province does not typically critique or
override these plants
the uh the Emergency Management of
Ontario is in receipt of these emergency
plans from every municipality they are
reviewed so I don't know to what extent
any advice or critique is presented back
to the municipality what is the it is
the municipality that adopts those plans
correct yes
and by order and counsel you're aware
that Ontario has assigned a number of
Ministries and their ministers
responsibility for preparing Emergency
Management plans and programs for
specific types of emergencies yes
are you aware is there an emergency plan
or program at the provincial level
targeted at the prevention mitigation
preparedness response and recovery of
emergencies related to critical
infrastructure like the Ambassador
Bridge I know that every Ministry is
required by the emca to have an
emergency management plan
are you aware if any of those plans
address threats to critical
infrastructure like at The Ambassador
Bridge I am aware that there is current
legislation on the books keeping Ontario
open for business act that does just
that okay which Ministry would be
responsible for such a plan
um the ministry to my understanding that
is responsible currently for the keeping
Ontario open for business act which
addresses critical infrastructure is
treasury board okay
and the ministry of the solicitor
general is responsible to coordinate the
overall provincial emergency response
not currently
that's been transferred to the treasury
board as well correct as of February
2022 it was your ministry's
responsibility yes
are you aware has the order and Council
assigning responsibility been updated
I am not aware
so turning briefly back to Municipal
emergencies will you agree with me that
the poeoc does not send someone to
manage Municipal emergencies alongside
the municipality
are you talking about peacock yes
they do send field advisors to provide
support and I know that that was done
with regards to Windsor
so this is a field officer who liaises
with the community correct with the
community Emergency Management
coordinator yes correct and but the
management of the emergency is left to
the Emergency Management experts and
trained emergency responders in the
municipality
correct and there is support and advice
provided by the field officer from emo
and it's your understanding that advice
was provided by the field officer of emo
to Windsor
those are the duties of the field
officer that was deployed it is my
understanding that the chief laforet the
CEMC for the municipality of Windsor
provided information to the field
officers
throughout this protest I accept that
okay
all right so we've heard about the uh at
the municipal level the roles of
Municipal Emergency Management in these
protests earlier in the hearing
at the provincial level you'll agree
with me that the solicitor general was
the lead Ministry for Ontario's response
yes
and will you agree with me that the
solicitor General's office did not
communicate to municipalities that the
solicitor general was the lead Ministry
I don't know that okay we've heard that
other Ministries had a role in the
emergency response including MTO yes and
mmah
to what extent mmh had a role I'm not
entirely sure I know that they managed
to
Disaster Recovery funds with regards to
people individuals and businesses well
it was the solicitor General's office's
role to coordinate the ministry's
response yes okay
did your ministry circulate to
municipalities through Emo or peoc or
otherwise the roles and responsibilities
of the different Ministries engaged in
the emergency response
I don't know the answer to that
other than collecting and sharing these
daily Consolidated situation reports
that we've been referring to did
Emergency Management Ontario or peoc
have any other role during the protests
in February
right so they played an advisory role
should municipalities have any need for
advice from the provincial experts that
were made available to them are you
aware that any municipalities asked for
advice from these provincial experts
I'm not sure that there would be a
requirement to ask first the duties of
field officers are to be present and to
to provide that advice upon request and
if they see that something is not going
according to plan they are certainly
free to provide that advice okay
did you have any conversations with the
fields off field officers yourself who
were assigned to Windsor I did not okay
thank you
um you had told the commissioner that as
a February 11th the peoc was put in full
activation mode correct yes
is it possible that prior to February
11th the peoc was an enhanced monitoring
mode but for covid-19 and not the
protests
no I wouldn't I wouldn't say that they
were in enhanced monitoring mode for
both
okay
and are you aware that there have been
amendments to the emergency management
and civil protection act yes and they
received Royal Ascent in April of this
year
I'm not sure of the date I'll accept
your word were you consulted on these
amendments
yes
um and are you aware was there any
consultation with municipalities and
preparing the amendments to the emcpa
I don't know the answer to that okay
there's a number of new sections to the
ACT
yes yes and one of them requires the
solicitor general to develop a written
framework for accountability and
governance during emergencies yes and
that written framework has to be made
available to the public
yes
no such framework was prepared or
publicized prior to the protests earlier
this year
there was not a requirement to publish a
framework prior to April of this year
understood but there was there wasn't a
framework that was available publicly
there was a provincial Emergency
Management plan that was available
online okay I am aware of that document
thank you very much those are my
questions thank you
thank you next day I'd like to call on
the city of Ottawa
okay
good evening Mr Di Tomaso my name is
Alyssa Tompkins I'm one of the lawyers
representing the city of Ottawa hello
now you testified earlier that the
police Board of jurisdiction is in the
best position to determine whether
adequate and effective police services
are being provided correct yes
uh you also testified that the board has
the exclusive responsibility for the
oversight of the chief and ensuring
adequate and effective police services
are being provided in the municipality
do I have that right yes and what I want
to follow up on initially is
uh how this relates to section 3 sub 2
of the police services act and I I think
you adjust it with one of my friends but
that section of course provides that the
solicitor general
shall monitor police forces to ensure
that adequate and effective police
services are provided at the municipal
and provincial levels correct I mean I
ask you you put that section up please
sir so um the police services Act is uh
at the document com
zero zero zero zero zero I think that's
five zeros eight one nine
and uh page seven Mr Clerk
so if we if we just scroll down
um right there so 3 sub 2 right under
duties and powers of solicitor general
we start right away with the solicitor
General's Xiao
monitor police forces to ensure that
adequate and effective police services
are provided at the municipal and
provincial levels yes that's one of her
one of the duties yes and um I put to
you that the Supreme Court of Canada has
said that the solicitor general has a
duty to ensure that the board provides
adequate and effective services
in a municipality so I'm not aware of
that Supreme Court case but I will take
your word for it yeah we'll we'll deal
with that in submission okay
um but you you don't have any reason to
contradict that understanding correct
okay now one of the ways that the
solicitor general fulfills this Duty as
I understand your evidence is through a
police services advisor correct that's
one of the ways the other way she
fulfills this duty is by
um speaking to Chiefs of police and
receiving public complaints with regards
to adequate and effective police
services so if the solicitor general is
aware of
public complaints that the service is
not delivering adequate and effective
Police Services the solicitor general
can take action right and we'll come to
that of course but I want to focus right
now on the police services advisor so we
looked earlier at the February 5th
meeting of the Ottawa Police Services
Board and it was the one you were
texting with commissioner karique about
so if we could bring up a document ont
and I think it's four zeros one one one
five
if you can just scroll down I'm going to
focus on the first four bullets oh if we
can actually go to the top first uh so
this is
um we've discussed earlier uh you
discussed I should say that Lindsey gray
was that solicitor and we see that it
this is a board meeting summary note for
the Inspector General of policing and
that was the gentleman that you said
reported to you yes okay now if we so
this is her her report so if we can
scroll down the the first the four
bullets
so we have
chair Deans commented that the city is
under siege and this is a threat to
democracy a nationwide Insurrection the
current situation is madness and stated
that there needs to be a concrete plan
to end this now
and this gets important here chair Dean
stated that the meeting was called to
ask the chief one question
in accordance with the Mandate for the
delivery of adequate and effective
policing she asked the chief if he still
believes he is able to provide given the
fluid nature of the application
occupation adequate and effective
policing to the city of Ottawa if not
the terrorist what legal authorities
what resources from the board or what
assistance the board can provide at this
time
and the chief starts answering and he
says the chief committed to let where
the service is at and what their plan is
he did comment that there is nothing in
the definition of adequate and effective
policing that could resolve a city under
siege a threatened democracy a
nationwide Insurrection he further
commented that a police service is not
created contemplated to deal with a city
under siege and as such there is not
necessarily a concrete plan for such a
scenario as described now I don't think
we have time to review the whole
document but but you'll agree the chief
does not say yes
he does not say I'm able to provide
adequate and effective police services
so I wasn't there at that meeting and
I've only read this particular report in
preparation for this testimony yeah so
what I want to understand though is that
this report was provided to your
subordinate and I'm wondering did alarm
Bells not start ringing at the ministry
so I was relying on the information
provided to me by Ken weatherhill okay
and at the same time by this point
you're aware that February 2nd former
Chief slowly has stated that he doesn't
believe there's a policing solution
right so your department is getting this
report at the same time he's saying that
and I ask again are alarm Bells not
ringing
no because Ottawa Police Service was
getting sufficient and significant
support and resources from the opp
sir you testify that the police Service
Board is in the best place to assess
whether there's adequate and effective
Police Services being provided right and
those Services were being provided by
Ottawa Police Service and the opp
we see here that the chief was asked on
point if he could
and he didn't answer yes
and we can go to an internal OPB
document uh let's bring that up
Charities says speaking notes from this
meeting
opp000655
sorry is that OPB or yeah OPB
as in bravo five zeros six five five
and these are Charities speaking notes
from that and if we scroll down I'm
sorry whose speaking notes are these
chair Diane Deans I've never seen this
before okay but these are from the the
minute so I'm just gonna go scroll down
further
and the the chair says I called the
meeting to ask the chief if he was still
able to provide adequate and effective
policing to residents of the city this
Chief confirmed that he could not which
was very troubling to hear the board
requested what a additional resources he
needed to restore calm and protect
residents
so that that was that what was stated by
her and what your staff member reported
and she she didn't say no but she did
not say yes you'll agree
so that information was not communicated
to me any concerns about the provision
of adequate and effective Police
Services were mitigated by the fact that
the opp was providing significant
resources to assist the Ottawa Police
Service sir you testified earlier that
those resources were contingent on the
existence of an operational plan that's
not what I testify to
the resources for the provision of
public order units to dismantle
the occupation were contingent on a
fully developed plan to dismantle the
occupation the opp was providing
significant and sufficient resources to
address any of those concerns
sir I put to you that what the chief
described was that with the state of the
occupation he called it a near Siege a
threat to democracy that with the
occupation in place that he was unable
to provide adequate and effective
policing and that that's noted in in the
the report that went to your subordinate
right and any risks as I've testified
I'm sorry any concerns were mitigated by
the fact that the commissioner of the
opp was working hand in hand with Chief
slowly and providing significant
resources to address those concerns
they were contingent on their provision
of a plan though no no no please do not
put words in my mouth
the resources to dismantle the
occupation were contingent on the
operational plan that dealt with that
issue
the opp was providing resources
Ruth with regards to maintenance and
Public Safety without that plan and we
looked at text messages earlier that by
February 6th you acknowledged or it was
in the text to you that there was a lack
of a plan to dismantle the operation by
Chief slowly correct correct okay now
one thing I want to look at because I'm
running out of time is questions because
we see the board is floundering the
board is asking we need we don't know
what authorities we have in the event
there's not adequate and effective
policing so there is a modern report
that speaks to that and what I'm going
to put to you though is that the
provision there's a provision of the act
and it's section 9. and I'm going to
suggest you that that section is what
deals with a situation where a police
board or a commission or a chief
determines that he's unable to provide
adequate and effective policing you'll
agree
yes section 9 deals with that issue okay
now what I want to understand so the
board was asking lots of questions of
your subordinates and if we go first to
ont 40111
and if we scroll down a bit I just
wanted to draw this your attention that
it it goes to Kenneth Wetherill and I if
I'm not mistaken that's the gentleman
that that's the Inspector General yeah
and I I just wanted to show you that he
notes that these are very good questions
and if we scroll down we see that
they're from the Ottawa Police Services
Board
looking for guidance from the solicitor
general
right and that guidance was provided
because it clearly states in that email
that the Morden report was referenced
chair Deans had the knowledge as you
indicated just now that the
Ottawa Police Service according to Chief
slowly was not providing those services
so then section 9 would apply under that
situation
my testimony is that the chair
on upon a resolution of the entire board
had the ability to ask the opp
commissioner
to come in and give assistance I agree
with you but let's go to the answer to
these questions so if we can go to uh
the response to make it quick yeah I
will I'm getting out of town
um if I could just have a bit more time
I think this is an important Point yes
but short make it okay to the point
o-n-t000118
and this is the response that was
provided
and I'm gonna put to you that nowhere in
this document is section 9 mentioned
I don't know what this document is I'm
sorry uh this is the response if you
look at the top and I you are going to
have to take my word but it says q a to
support Ottawa PSB meeting report roles
and responsibilities
and and if we look at the list of
questions that Mr weatherall said were
good questions these are the questions
and these appear to be the responses
they're they're produced from from your
department
so if we scroll through
and I am short in time I'm cognizant but
what we see is that section 9 is never
suggested and I want to understand why
was that never suggested that would be
that would be a question for the Police
Service Board advisor having said that
it is my expectation that Police Service
Board chairs and all members be
intimately familiar with their duties
and responsibilities in the Police
Service Act they have access to
Independent legal counsel they have
access to executive directors as well
the advisor cannot be the only source of
information that they rely upon
we were we started this examination by
talking about the duty on the solicitor
general to ensure that the board is
providing adequate and effective
policing it was very clear from these
questions that the board was having
trouble understanding what to do and
what we've all described as an
unprecedented situation
I what why was section 9 not suggested
so the board as an option in light of
the fact that the chief could not
confirm as Lindsey gray stated in her
note the chief did not confirm that he
was able to provide adequate and
effective services so that's a question
for Lindsey Gray
so I put to you that it was never
mentioned because Ontario didn't want it
to happen
I reject that assertion completely and I
put to you that Ontario didn't want the
province to publicly take responsibility
for the situation in Ottawa I reject
that assertion completely those are my
questions thank you thank you hey thank
you next is the government of
Saskatchewan
good evening sir my name is Mike Morris
I'm Council for the government of
Saskatchewan I only want to talk about
one phone call with you tonight so it
should hopefully be pretty
straightforward it's a phone call you
had with Deputy Minister Stewart of
Public Safety Canada at about 8 55 a.m
on February 14th
and like any good police officer I think
he made good contemporaneous notes so
that's going to help us out quite a bit
I would just ask that the following be
pulled up by the registrar o and t four
zeros
3847
do you recognize your notes sir I do
uh dated February 14 2022 time recorded
as 8 55 I take it that's am correct yes
this is a call with Deputy Minister
Stewart uh did you initiate that call or
did he do you recall I don't recall
okay uh your notes State I inquire as to
whether Federal emergencies act will be
invoked today
and the next note is silence with an
exclamation point correct yes
so you asked the question you were met
with silence then
correct
can we go to the next page of the PDF I
think this is a continuation of your
notes from that same call I'm just going
to ask you to confirm that for me though
I believe so
so if I read this correctly you then
have written down I am informed PM made
a decision
that FM meeting called followed by press
conference
cabinet meeting held last night did I
read that correctly you did
PM would mean prime minister yes
FM meeting would be first ministers
meeting then yes
so was this uh Deputy Minister Stewart
advising you then that a cabinet meeting
had occurred last night
that the Prime Minister had made a
decision
and that a first Minister's meeting was
to occur and to be followed by a press
conference that day is that fair that
would be fair
and then your next note is I advise from
my perspective
that sounds like federal government
invoking emergencies act correct yes
and your final note of this phone call
if I understand it correctly is Silence
from Rob Stewart is that correct yeah so
I think some context is important as
well the reason why I'm having this
discussion and asking these questions is
because Deputy Minister Stuart
referenced the previous day I believe on
the 13th that the federal government was
considering an emergency declaration but
they were exceptionally reluctant to do
so because the provincial emergencies
regulations had
uh more teeth in terms of financial
penalties so that's why this discussion
was happening
and this was a very important discussion
from your perspective I take it yes
and did you report this information
after you received it to anyone yes
who did you report it to Sir Minister
Jones
and was it your understanding then that
the first Minister's meeting was going
to occur after this phone call that
you'd had with uh Deputy Minister
Stewart
yeah I'm not I'm not entirely sure on
the timing
okay we can clarify the timing with a
different witness likely from from the
federal government
thank you sir those are my questions for
you thank you thank you next I'd like to
call on the government of Alberta
good evening my name is Stephanie Rose
I'm here as counsel for the province of
Alberta just one area to ask you a
couple of questions on
um it was it your understanding
regarding tow trucks and Ottawa that
there were providers that were hesitant
to provide towing services because they
were concerned about being provided with
an Indemnity yes and was it your
understanding that the Emergency
Management and civil protection act does
not Grant the power to compel tow truck
operators to provide towing services
that's exactly right
but is it also your understanding that
pursuant to that same act an order could
be made in respect of procuring
necessary Goods services and resources
permitting the procurement yes and that
could include towing services
yes and also under that act an order
could be made authorizing but not
requiring any person to render Services
of a type that person is reasonably
qualified to provide
yes and that does not provide the
ability to compel correct and that again
could be towing services correct
do you also understand that the ACT
makes it an offense to interfere with or
obstruct any person in the exercise of a
power or performance of a Duty conferred
by an order under that act
you'd have to put that section up
I'm sorry okay well we can do that very
quickly it's um document ccf6038
and um Mr clerk if you could please go
to page 10.
and scroll there we see the offenses
section
7.0.11 yes
um and you'll see there that it does
make it an offense to interfere or
obstruct with the person
um exercise in a power under that and
under an order I agree and then
scrolling down again to page 13 we'll
look at section 11 sub 1.
in this section protects anyone acting
under an order made under the earlier
section
um that deals with an order authorizing
services to be provided protects them
from liability as long as they're acting
in good faith pursuant to that order you
see that there I agree
and then down to page 14
section 13.1
and subsection 3 there is a compensation
for loss of property there's a mechanism
within this act for someone to be
compensated for any loss of personal
property the person suffered as a result
of an order being under the ACT do you
see that
yes so do you agree that certainly there
are ways under under this act although
not to compel toe tuck tow truck drivers
to act but to at least ameliorate some
of their concerns with respect to
financial liability for providing towing
services with respect to the protest in
Ottawa
to some extent one thing that
13.1 subsection 3 does not do is provide
for compensation for any loss to to
property from a future perspective so if
the tow truck companies were concerned
about uh being reimbursed for
an arson for example at their warehouse
that would not be provided for in my
view in regards to this particular
section and just to be clear you're
talking about the theoretical
possibility of a tow truck operator
Towing that vehicle to their own
Warehouse as opposed to a government lot
no not necessarily even participating in
the program and having their building
burned down at some point in time in the
future
I'm sorry I missed that answer
so I'm talking about the theoretical
possibility of a tow truck company
having their building burned down for
participating in the removal of uh tow
trucks so you're talking about an act of
arson yes okay
thank you those are my own questions
today thank you
thank you next to the Democracy fund
um
good evening commissioner Alan Hunter
from the for the Democracy fund we do
not have any questions for this Witness
uh next the CLA ccdl
uh good evening it's Colleen McEwen our
questions have been asked thank you very
much
the National Police Federation
thank you Mr commissioner this is Jen
del rico for the npf our questions for
this witness have been asked in answers
we have nothing further thank you
the Ontario representative
thank you commissioner my name is Daryl
kluza I'm counsel for the province of
Ontario good evening Mr D Tomaso
I only have a few questions for you and
honestly these are just for purpose of
clarifying the record given that um
we're not a part of this proceeding and
we will not be attending at the evidence
of the federal Representatives the one
point I wanted to raise uh Mr D Tomaso
you were asked questions uh both by
commission Council and by Council for
Canada about the tripartite meetings
taken at the ministers level so these
are the meetings that this solicitor
general was invited to
and I think commission council did put
it to you that uh at some point
there were calls between Federal
Minister Mendocino and the premier and
the premier had expressed that he would
send this Lister General
uh to these meetings but then later said
that he would not send the solicitor
general to remember those questions from
the commission Council yes uh Council
for Canada put a reference to you a
document reference and I believe it was
SSM
c-a-n-n-s-c-402832 and that's the
document reference uh where the I think
it was the chief of staff of the
minister Mendocino
confirmed that the premier said he would
have Minister Jones attend
uh we don't need to bring it up but I
just want to put on the record the
second document reference that wasn't
put to you uh by Council for Canada and
we can put that up
ssm.nsc Dot c-a-n
four zeros one one four h
and obviously uh Deputy you weren't at
any of these meetings you weren't on any
of these calls so you won't have any
knowledge about them I just wanted to
put that document up so we can see
and if we can just scroll down a bit
that Mike Jones I understand is the
chief of staff for Minister Mendocino
um on Wednesday February 9th in the
afternoon the first paragraph my boss
spoke with Premier Ford just before
today's Avail I understand that to mean
press availability
and my boss said he needed the province
at the table on policing efforts and
that the current blockades are harming
the economy
and costing jobs Ford responded that he
understood
and if we go down to the second
paragraph immediately following the
media Avail Ford called my boss again to
say that he wouldn't be sending Minister
Jones to the tripartite conversations
and uh I understand you weren't part of
this uh these calls but that seems to
confirm to me that the premier was not
going to send the minister
thank you
and did you have any discussions with
the minister about either of these uh
conversations no
the second point
actually the second point I think has
been covered
uh and other questions
one final Point actually I do want to
raise with you
um
and and this came up at the very
beginning of your uh evidence today
commission Council asked you about
whether the province participated in
injunctions in Junction hearings and I
think it was agreed that the province
did
intervene at the request for an
injunction in Windsor yes and and the
province also
had a an application to freeze the
Assets in with regards to the GoFundMe
as well
and that was on around the same time as
the uh as the injunction at Windsor on
around February 11th I believe so and
that injunction or that freezing order
was was made by the court yes
um if there was a question as to whether
the province intervened in the
injunction brought in Ottawa I
understand there were two injunctions in
Ottawa one by a private citizen but
there was a second injunction are you
aware by the city of Ottawa yes uh to
and in respect of bylaw enforcement yes
and are you aware that the province
actually did intervene in that
injunction as well I am aware
and one final matter you've you've
mentioned a number of times in your
evidence and I just want to make this
legislative reference if I can you've
mentioned that
under the federal emergency declaration
tow truck tow truck drivers were
compelled under that order to provide
services if requested by police yes
under the provincial act the emcpa
you've said it does not give the
province that authority to compel that
type of to compel that type of service
right it it authorizes but does not
require okay and if uh if we can just
turn up the act so we can see what it
actually what it says on that
um
and we've had the reference before a
number of times I believe it's
CCF six zeros 38.
thank you Mr registrar if you could turn
to page seven
and
just turn to the top of the previous or
the bottom of the previous page so the
emergency orders you see that sir yes in
accordance with subsection two the
lieutenant governor and Council may make
orders in respect of the following
and so these are the types of orders
that can be made if an emergency
declaration is is made by the by the
either the premier or the cabinet yes
and if you turn to paragraph 12 of that
just down
and is that what you're referring to
when you say that uh there's no ability
of the province to compel a service
right and it reads authorizing but not
requiring any person or class of persons
to render services
of a type that that person is reasonably
qualified to provide yes
uh thank you sir those are my questions
thank you commissioner okay
any re-examination
uh no no re-examination from the
commission
um I just wonder if one of the parties
may have been skipped the National
Police Federation
no
they had no questions no I believe I
asked the National Police Federation
perfect well fell asleep on that one yes
wouldn't be the first time I've missed
people before but usually they speak up
so I think it was me who was sleeping
this time it's been a long day thank you
commissioner okay
um
if if you have the strength there's just
a couple of questions I'd like to ask
you
um
as you know I'm uh this commission is
concerned with the Declaration of the
emergency uh and uh but also can make
recommendations on the emergency act and
presumably dealing with the public order
emergencies
and I guess I'm I'm interested in views
you may have as to knowing as you do
what happened in Ottawa what happened in
Windsor
uh whether you might have some uh some
comments or suggestions and in
particular on how
for whether there should be more
coordination on in areas where
there is uh clear overlap such as border
crossings
where the impact if you like is is much
broader than on Ontario it's a federal
or
Ottawa where as we know the impact
certainly was greater on the federal
government and in the Parliamentary
Precinct
and uh
whether leaving aside whether it was
properly declared an emergency which is
something I have to deal with are there
things in
do you view aspects of coordination in
particular or other aspects of the act
that might be reviewed
certainly I think there is an
opportunity for greater coordination
amongst governments and police services
and intelligence agencies might think
Chief slowly referred to that very thing
especially in regards to intelligence
sharing and I would certainly endorse
that um suggestion recommendation by
Chief slowly I've also had the
opportunity to briefly review the
recommendations made by commissioner
Creek and I certainly support and
endorse those recommendations that he's
made
over and above that I would also
suggest this is my own personal opinion
that a task force of some type be put
together to study
the issue of the right to protest and
it's enshrined in the Constitution but
what are the limits because my
understanding is that people have an
understanding that protests can occur at
any time in any location for any length
of time so are there reasonable limits
that ought to be imposed I don't know
what the answer to that is that's
something that this commission could
certainly suggests that that matter be
be studied
um in regards to lawful protest there
are limits that can be prescribed I'm
not in a position to determine what
those limits ought to be but certainly I
think that the public needs to be
reminded that when you exercise your
rights under the Canadian Charter of
Rights and Freedom that you also have
responsibility to your fellow citizens
as well and that those rights are
certainly not absolute those are my
comments commissioner
okay if I could push you a little bit on
the an aspect that I I'm I'm interested
in which is the coordination and and
we've heard about the coordination in in
Windsor that was very effective police
and messaging from the city from all of
the parties
and
that messaging uh or the coordination in
Ottawa does not seem to have been as
fluid at the police level I think we've
heard evidence about that nor at the
political level and I think we've heard
about that
is is there something should there be a
process or a protocol for such events
that involve uh the different orders of
government in such events a protocol or
a best practices or or something
that's certainly something that this
commission could make recommendations on
um I think there is opportunity there
there are opportunities for greater
collaboration I think one of the key
differences between
um
the
um
the police operations in Windsor in
comparison to Ottawa was that the opp
provided uh key leadership in terms of
command and control and they made it
clear to the Ottawa I'm sorry to the
Windsor Police Service that they were in
charge there was a a very rapidly
developed unified command very rapidly
and the scope and scale of the Windsor
blockade was certainly much smaller but
it was that coordination where Windsor
Police Service accepted unified command
and the lead by the OPP very quickly I
think that was a a critical point for
Windsor to have done that resulted in
the dismantling of the blockade that
much more quickly
and do you have views on whether any uh
recommendations regarding unified
command and
if you like drawing uh on expertise
which I think is what was described in
in uh in Windsor
it should be made by this commission I I
do I do I think that in those rare
occasions when police services do not
have the capacity and the capability to
deal with
um
urgent events prolonged events of the
size and scale and scope that we saw in
Ottawa that there be some way to compel
a police service to accept
these Services the leadership and the
subject matter expertise of those police
services that do have that capacity
and
just pursuing that a bit with the Police
Services Board I I seem to
for a call from your testimony there's
something being looked at in terms of
the police services act or a committee
and I'm just
I'm just wondering given the
cross-examination you had but also the
evidence here of
let's just say the issues with respect
to the information the Police Services
Board at
is there do you think there's room for
reform on that here in that area I do
and I can assure you commissioner that
this province right now is in the
position is in in the process
of implementing the brand new community
safety and policing act and we are in
the process of Consulting with many
stakeholders with regards to the
regulations to support that act and I
can assure you commissioner that we are
listening with years wide open with
regards to what is happening here in
this commission and the evidence that
has been presented I cannot speak to
what regulations will be implemented but
that this is certainly a concern that I
will be taking back and sharing with the
minister
because that was going to be my next
question either if our findings from
this Commission in respect of what
happened
because obviously there's dispute at
this point which is going to have to be
sorted out that that is something that
can be taken here that could be useful
to your the work the ministry is doing
absolutely I believe that the
recommendations made by this commission
uh with regards to policing will
certainly inform decisions made by the
minister and by cabinet okay and one
last question and that deals with the
emergency acts as such is there
room for or should there be room for
coordination between emergency acts
because we hear about what Ontario's
emergency act can do what the federal
could do
what triggers one what doesn't trigger
the other
um and obviously in this case the
emergency Act of Canada I guess is
40 years old or 30 some years old so
is there room for coordination or is
that something that you you don't think
is should be pursued or looked into
so in Practical terms commissioner the
provincial Emergency Management civil
protection act in the last four years
has been
emergency declarations have been made
four times
with regards to the federal emergencies
act as you've indicated once in 40 years
so I'm not sure that
um
the the reality is such that both acts
ought to be
um
coordinated I think the provincial act
um is certainly invoked more often to
deal with all sorts of
um emergencies and the federal act
obviously less frequently
okay well thank you very much and thank
you for your patience
uh you're staying late and for coming
back after uh
yesterday's uh yesterday's failure to
complete your examination so
uh you're free to go we're now uh
not early but uh we're uh we're finished
for the day and we'll adjourn till
Monday morning at uh 9 30. and I expect
next week will be
uh longer days again the same sort of
days we're having uh this week so
um
bury yourselves accordingly
[Music]
the commission is adjourned that
Commerce